Oh, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Ah.
Es lag an der Telekom.
Geil, oder?
Was macht die Telekom, bitteschön?
Oh, ich übersteuere.
Was macht die Telekom eigentlich?
Was soll denn der Scheiß?
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt funktioniert es wunderbar.
Soll ich mich einen Ticken leiser machen, oder ist gut so?
Ja.
Ja, wunderbar.
Dann können wir jetzt hier anfangen.
Perfekt.
So, da mache ich mir nochmal ein neues Tab auf,
dass der Kram auch ordentlich lädt.
So, jetzt muss ich mir das nochmal selbst in der Vorschau angucken.
Wie sieht das hier aus jetzt?
Hast du noch Kontakt mit dem Kaboom?
Äh, ja, ab und zu.
Das ist ja schon antik, die Copypasta.
Das ist ja, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend.
Okay, jetzt scheint alles zu funktionieren.
Super.
So, na, wenigstens etwas.
Perfekt.
So, können wir jetzt hier anfangen.
Hallo, T-Zap.
Dann können wir jetzt hier anfangen.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Habe ich ja gerade gesagt.
Ich streame jetzt zum ersten Mal vom neuen Rechner.
Und mit ein bisschen Anlaufschwierigkeiten hat es jetzt hier auch funktioniert.
Ich zeige euch, passt mal auf, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Ich hoffe, das geht überhaupt von hier.
Passt mal auf.
Ich habe jetzt...
Ich habe jetzt meinen Rechner Stable übertaktet.
Ähm, da sieht man das nicht.
Ich müsste mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen Last verursachen.
Ich habe meinen Rechner jetzt Stable übertaktet auf 5 Gigahertz.
Ich muss mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Prime 95, irgendwas, irgendein altes Prime oder so runterladen.
Wobei, ihr könnt es mir einfach glauben.
Ich habe meinen Rechner jetzt übertaktet auf Stable 5 Gigahertz.
Er läuft mit 5,1.
Mein, mein, mein 8700K, er läuft mit 5,1.
Allerdings muss man, ähm, übertrieben viel Spannung draufhauen, dass er das macht.
Äh, Pavillonman fragt, ob man damit jetzt...
Achso, ist die, äh, die Chat-Einblendung, ja, die Chat-Einblendung funktioniert, gut.
Ähm, ob damit jetzt das neue COD ordentlich läuft?
Naja, es kackt immer noch ab und zu ab, wenn man raus tappt.
Es ist halt, es ist halt COD.
Aber es läuft besser als auf dem alten Rechner, also, also es läuft schneller als auf dem alten Rechner.
Also, stabiler läuft es auch nicht als auf dem alten Rechner.
Zumindest Stable ist er jetzt auf 6 Kern mit 5 Gigahertz.
Und ich habe da stundenlang Prime laufen lassen, Real Bench und hast du nicht gesehen, den ganzen Scheiß.
Und das funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich super.
Ich habe jetzt halt eingestellt, dass er sich runter taktet, das wäre ja auch total beknackt.
Wenn, wenn er sich, na, warum sollte ich mehr Strom verschwenden als sein muss?
Ja, ist nice.
Und das, ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht noch an den Übertaktungs-Stream erinnern, also ich habe die CPU jetzt.
Ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht noch an den, an den Übertaktungs-Stream erinnern, den ich, kann ich sagen, dass ich das nie machen will.
Ich will never translate German, will ich haben.
Außerdem will ich mein, außerdem will ich meinen Browser auf Englisch haben.
Settings, Language, geht das hier?
Ey, es ist doch schon auf Englisch.
Warum ist, warum ist Google denn jetzt auf Deutsch?
Achso, weil es Google.de ist.
Aber Google, selbst Google.de ist halt, ah, change to Englisch, geht doch, ja.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ähm, ich habe ja riesen Glück gehabt, ne, und habe noch einen 8700K bekommen.
Also ich habe vorbestellt bei drei verschiedenen Shops, direkt zur Release, quasi noch, noch vor Release, habe ich den bestellt.
Und bei drei Shops, bei Konrad, bei Mindfactory und bei so einem Berliner IT.
Dann kam ich auf den Display-Laden, keine Ahnung, stand halt bei Geizhals, stand der halt drinnen.
Ich zeige euch das mal, weil mich jetzt einige Leute schon gefragt haben, wie ich den 8700K gekriegt habe.
Ähm, das könnten die gewesen sein.
Der war aber nicht so teuer, meiner.
Wobei so 40 Euro Aufpreis, wenn man den jetzt unbedingt haben will, ist auch okay.
Ähm.
Ach, mittlerweile sind 8700K lieferbar.
Ne, doch nicht, lagernd.
Machen wir mal lagernd.
Ah ja.
Boah, die hauen aber rein hier vom Preis her
Also ich hab bei Mindfactory Konrad
Und ich glaube, die hier waren das
Wo ich auch bestellt hab noch
Jaja, in Berlin, genau
So, und die haben wohl irgendwie
Scheint wohl ein bisschen kleinerer Laden zu sein
Und die haben wohl welche bekommen
Und ich war wohl einer der
Wenigen oder einer der ersten
Die dort was bestellt haben
Und dann hab ich quasi
Zwei Wochen oder eineinhalb Wochen nach Release
Quasi den 8700K gekriegt
Der jetzt da quasi schon nicht zu bekommen ist
So, und
Also ich seh's aber auch nicht ein
Manche Shops hier, ne
Die irgendwie, man die CPU soll mal 399 kosten
Und manche Shops hier unten
Hier so 500, 600, ja ist klar, ne
Also so viel wert wär's mir dann doch nicht gewesen
Sagen wir mal so 39 Euro Aufpreis
Wenn man jetzt unbedingt einen haben will
Würde ich sagen, das kann man machen, ja
Am besten ist natürlich
Man kriegt die CPU für das, wie es gedacht ist
Ich hatte halt übelst Glück
Wie gesagt, ich hab
Irgendwie keinen Kontakt irgendwie mit Intel gehabt
Oder sonst was in der Richtung
Ja, einfach Glück gehabt
So, und der läuft jetzt stable
Weil irgendjemand gesagt hat, auf 5 GHz
5 GHz braucht man nicht
Der läuft jetzt stable auf 5 GHz
Und Cache glaube ich auf 4,4
Nachdem ich ein bisschen
Im BIOS rumgebastelt hab
Also sprich ein bisschen Spannung umgestellt hab
Ein bisschen, wie hat das denn jetzt
Wie heißt das, wie heißt das bei Intel jetzt
Line Level Calibration
Und Zeug halt
Rumprobiert
Und ich hab jetzt die Lüfte auch so eingestellt
Auf Silence, also sprich
Ich höre jetzt vom Rechner nichts
Außer, er macht halt was
So, gut, das wollte ich jetzt mal loswerden an der Stelle
Ja und weil jemand geschrieben hat 5 GHz braucht man nicht
Ich mein, warum braucht man die nicht
Das ist jetzt die Frage
Ich mein, warum nicht
Ich mein, die CPU hat man
Man hat für die CPU schon Geld ausgegeben
Man hat auch den Geld für das Lüfter ausgegeben
Also für den ordentlichen Lüfter ausgegeben
Für das Mainboard ausgegeben
Warum soll man das nicht übertakten
Nur weil man vielleicht
Anstatt
Keine Ahnung
Die 10 oder 15%
10% 20%
Keine Ahnung FPS
Am Ende nicht mehr braucht
Weil man eh schon so viel hat
Auf der anderen Seite kann man sagen
Man kann nie genug FPS haben
Mal angenommen
Man schafft es mit Übertakten
Von Grafikkarte und CPU nochmal irgendwie so
20% oder so an Leistung rauszuholen
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen 120
Und 144 FPS
Und das ist doch nicht schlecht
Zumal es kostet ja auch nicht mehr
So, Grafikkarte übertakten muss ich auch noch machen
Muss ich mal ausprobieren
Wie viel meine 1008 Stil letztendlich packt
Habe ich noch nie getestet
Aber ich denke mal
Das was ich hier so am Start habe
Dürfte jetzt somit das schnellste System sein
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig auch ziemlich gut
Was man zur Zeit für Gaming so kriegen kann
Ohne jetzt
In die ganz Extremen zu gehen
Also in die ganz Extremen meine ich jetzt irgendwie irgendwelche
Titan X
Dings TI
Oder wie heißt das Ding
Titan XP oder so
Oder irgendwie
Keine Ahnung
Preis-Leistung finde ich mein System echt nice
Aber, jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema heute
Jetzt habe ich hier lange über meinen Rechner gelabert
Was wir machen wollen
Und zwar, ich habe gesehen
Das
Ähm
Ist das der Richtige?
Ich habe gesehen, dass
ZFS on Linux
Den Encryption
Pull-Request
Gemerged hat
Wenn ich das jetzt mal finden würde
Dann haben die schon vor einer Weile gemerged
Also sprich
Die ZFS Implementierung
Für Linux hat jetzt
Verschlüsselung eingebaut
Und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
Das einzige Problem bei der Sache ist
Es gibt noch keinen offiziellen
Release
Ich finde den Branch nicht
Bin ich jetzt doof?
Wo ist es denn?
Es gibt noch keinen offiziellen Branch dafür
Beziehungsweise noch keinen offiziellen
Release dafür
Wo ZFS
Mit eingebauter Verschlüsselung
Release ist
Ah hier
Wo ist das denn?
Ich finde den Branch jetzt gar nicht
Das ist er nicht
Und das schöne ist
Ah hier sieht man es
Und das geile ist
Das man damit jetzt zum ersten mal die Möglichkeit hat
Und das werden wir heute mal ausprobieren
Ob wir das überhaupt gebacken kriegen
Zum ersten mal die Möglichkeit hat
Alles mit ZFS zu machen
Also sprich
Ne ne tracksfreak
Du hast ZFS noch nicht verpasst
Wir haben noch gar nicht angefangen
Man hat zum ersten mal
Die Möglichkeit quasi alles mit ZFS zu machen
Bisher war das unter Linux so
Ich hole jetzt mal ein bisschen
Weiter aus
In der Zwischenzeit laden wir uns schon mal ein Ubuntu ISO runter
Wir brauchen übrigens das Desktop ISO
Obwohl wir kein Desktop System installieren werden
Sagt zumindest die offizielle Anleitung
Ähm
Ja lad mal runter
In der Zeit wo das runter geht kann ich ja noch was erzählen
Also ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter ausholen
ZFS ist ein
Ganz grob gesagt ist es ein Dateisystem
Also
Wenn ich jetzt sag sowas wie NTFS unter Windows
Wird das der Sache nicht so wirklich gerecht
Ähm aber
Dateisystem erstmal
Wie NTFS
Bloß das es halt noch viel mehr drum herum kann
Das ist auch kein reines Dateisystem
Das hat quasi äh
RAID Funktionalität
Mit eingebaut
Das hat ähm
Integritätschecks eingebaut
Also sprich das das auf der Platte auch wirklich noch stimmt
Was da steht
Das kann sich selbst reparieren
Das hat habe ich schon gesagt das es RAID Funktion eingebaut hat
Keine Ahnung
Es kann Snapshots erstellen
Man kann beispielsweise
Von seinem Rechner an einen anderen Rechner
Wo ZFS drauf ist
Das steht hier auch ganz
Kann man quasi komplette Snapshots
Und ähm
Ich nenn es mal Partitionen
Sind keine Partitionen nennt sich Dataset
Man kann komplett zu einem anderen Rechner rüber schicken
Das macht natürlich Backups
Auch ziemlich einfach
Und ZFS ist an sich schon
Eine richtig geile Geschichte
Kommt ursprünglich von Sun
Ähm
Von Sun für Solaris
War das mal
Ist das mal ursprünglich entwickelt worden
Und der Code kommt soweit ich weiß
Noch aus Zeiten wo Sun mal gesagt hat
Wir machen jetzt äh
Teile von Solaris
Und ähm
Mittlerweile wurde Sun ja von Oracle
Aufgekauft
Und Oracle hat jetzt gesagt wir machen das ganze wieder dicht
Und der Code
Den Sun allerdings mal veröffentlicht hat
Ist immer noch unter Open Source Lizenz
Verfügbar
Das hat sich das OpenZFS Projekt genommen
Die hier haben sich das genommen
Und es gibt jetzt
ZFS Implementierung für BSD
Und für Linux
Und für diesen OpenSolaris Nachfolger
Und solche Sachen
Ähm und mittlerweile hat das
Zur
Close Source Lösung
Nicht nur aufgeschlossen sondern sie teilweise
Sogar schon überholt
Und
Der letzte Schritt für mich war jetzt eigentlich
Das sie jetzt auch quasi
Verschlüsselungssystem eingebaut haben
In ZFS das bedeutet
Also was das ganze richtig cool
Macht ist
Früher hat man unter Linux quasi 3 verschiedene Teile
Gebraucht um einen RAID zu betreiben
Ähm ein verschlüsseltes
RAID zu betreiben wo man
Das man auch ordentlich noch unterteilen kann
Dann die Festplatten dann hat man
Man hat quasi für das RAID
Hat man MD-RAID
Verwendet für
Die Festplattenverschlüsselung hat man sowas wie LUX verwendet
Und für dieses
Äh Partitionierung
Und Volume Management
Hat man LVM verwendet
Und das kann man jetzt
Alles mit ZFS
Alles in einem machen
Plus die Vorteile die man eben mit ZFS hat
Das Problem ist
Wie ich schon gesagt habe
Es gibt noch keine Version
Die eben diese Verschlüsselungsfunktion anhält
Deswegen kompilieren wir das selbst
Und dann
Und das ist der große Knackpunkt
Ähm
Und dann versuchen wir
Also ich glaube ZFS selbst zu kompilieren
Und die Module zu laden ist nicht so schwierig
Wir haben ja auch eine ganz gute
Anleitung hier dafür
Wir suchen jetzt mal die Anleitung für Ubuntu
Custom Packages müssen wir uns erstmal raussuchen
Ähm das ist nicht so schwer
Aber der richtige Knackpunkt wird dann
Wir versuchen das System
Von diesem ZFS
Dann zu booten
So und ich
Ob das funktioniert
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel ehrlich gesagt
So äh jetzt legen wir
Also es kann durchaus sein
Das es in die Hose geht
Weil es ist ein Unterschied
Ob man quasi ein System bootet
Und dort dann irgendwie
Laufwerk einhängt
Und so eine ZFS Funktion verwendet
Oder ob man quasi direkt
Davon bootet
Also sprich man hat kein laufendes System
Wo man das dann lädt
Sondern man versucht davon zu booten
Das bedeutet es muss alles glatt gehen
Sprich der Crab darf einem keinen Strich durch die Rechnung machen
Ähm beim booten braucht man
Alle Module
Und Zeugs
Also
Mal gucken ob das funktioniert
Also es gibt hier eine schöne Anleitung für
Für Ubuntu wie man
Wie man ein Ubuntu
Von ZFS bootet
Das äh
Gibt es die funktioniert auch
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert
Mein Server hier daheim läuft auch auf einem ZFS Root
Allerdings
Ohne Verschlüsselung
Und das von Ubuntu mitgelieferte ZFS
Aber wir kompilieren das jetzt ja selbst
Ja doch tracksfreak
Natürlich will ich das verschlüsseln
Oder was meinst du mit keine Passphrase
Also natürlich will ich das mit passphrase
Ich will ein Passwort eintippen
Und dann
Das soll quasi Passwort Prompt
Oder naja
Es muss kein Passwort Prompt sein
Es ist auch ok
Wenn er mich irgendwie auf eine Shell schmeißt
Ich dann quasi manuell das anlocken muss
Und dann continue
Also ihn weiter booten lasse
Das ist auch ok
Aber der soll nicht booten ohne dass ich Passwort eingegeben habe
Ja Mr Army
Ich verwende den neuen PC
So ähm
Ok
Nein
Downloads
Ubuntu
Zack
Ich will
Nein nein
Wir sagen lieber das wir das later installen
Sonst macht forever noch komische Dinger
Linux wir haben nen Ubuntu 64
Ähm wisst ihr was
Wir stellen mal 3 CPUs ein
Ich mein ich hab jetzt einen neuen Rechner
Wunderbar
Ich weiß nicht wie das sein kann
Bei mir hat das irgendwo versteckt
Nur mit Schlüssel versteckt funktioniert
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Also ich glaube auch nicht das das schon eingebaut ist
Also ich glaube nicht das dort äh
Inits RAMFS
Scripts und Sachen
Schon mit dabei sind
Die das quasi von Haus aus ermöglichen
Direkt zu booten von ZFS
Und dich nach ner Passphrase fragen
Das wird nicht funktionieren
Aber
Das booten wird ja irgendwie
Vor oder später abkacken
Und wenn das booten abkackt schmeißt es mich auf ne Shell
Und wenn ich von der Shell ZFS
Anlocke und dann weiterboote
Das sollte eigentlich funktionieren
Wichtig ist nur das wir boot auf ne eigene Partition legen
Und nicht mit verschlüsseln
Weil äh Krupp kann kein
Kann keine ZFS Encryption
Soweit ich weiß
So legen wir mal die VM an
Kommen wir hier
Nein
Wir haben ja genug
Höh warum sieht der Taskmanager so kacke aus
So hier
Wir haben ja genug
Ist ja nicht so das wir hier zu wenig Leistung hätten
Ich hab
Muss ich mal überlegen wie hängen geblieben das ist
Ich hab 3 Netzwerkkarten
Auf dem Mainboard
Ich brauch keine 3 Netzwerkkarten
Aber ASRock war der Meinung
Nein wir müssen da jetzt 3 Netzwerkkarten draufbauen
Gut das hier ist vor allem
Also ich mein ich hab ja genug
16 GB RAM
So Kerne
Kann ich also ordentlich draufhauen hier
Äh Bridge Network
Bla bla bla
Ist eigentlich Musik
Und mein Gelaber von der Lautstärkeabmischung so
Ok ja denk schon
Ich hab ja so ein bisschen Chill
Entspannungsmusik
Hintergrund laufen
So create new disk
Store in single file
Ach keine Ahnung 40 GB
Boah wir könnten es jetzt nochmal ne Runde krasser machen
Wir könnten nen ZFS RAID 1 machen
Ne ne
Wir lassen es mit einer Disk von der wir booten
Wir müssen es ja nicht komplizierter machen als es ist
Ach ja und übrigens
Eine Sache würde ich auch noch gern mal ausprobieren
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind
Ich geb zu das ist ein bisschen
Advancede Geschichte
Aber ich wollte es schon lange mal ausprobieren
Also das ganze was wir heute machen
Bisschen advanceder
Und ihr könnt mich auch gerne alles mögliche dazu fragen
Auch so nach dem Motto WTF was machst du da eigentlich
Ähm
Ich will es schon lange mal ausprobieren
Und zwar ich möchte meinen Rechner
Also quasi die
Die verschlüsselte Partition
Und die verschlüsselte Festplatte
Wo ich beim Booten dann mein Passwort eingeben muss
Das will ich nicht lokal machen
Vom Rechner sondern über SSH
Das heißt wir müssen in unser Boot System
Auch noch nen SSH Server reinhauen
Ähm
Da weiß ich aber grob wie das funktioniert
Ja
Ja geil es grösselt hier
WTF was machst du da eigentlich
Ähm
So
implementiert ist was auch immer das ist dass da ich möchte das nicht tätschen
doch ich habe auch install ist gefinisht und alles so was das wieder für musik
ich hasse ich hasse chill musik oder mir im ende noch rumgelabert wird aber wird
schon gleich vorbei sein wir treiben jetzt mal ubuntu und ich
mache mal fullscreen und dann gucken wir uns das ganze mal an kann man das nicht
ausblenden hier oben geh weg piss dich alle und das release soll auch weg vmware macht
dich vom acker ich will das nicht sehen da oben jetzt ist weg sehr schön okay hat
funktioniert so als erstes installieren wir jetzt mal vmware tools dass wir das
in vollbild kriegen und dann machen wir uns die anleitung hier drauf auf wie das
funktioniert
eigentliche tastatur das war das war auch klar stellen habt install open vm
open v open vm tools jetzt aber genau max was hältst du von camelot
unchained ich habe das gepackt wo ist das user
user
so heißt glaube ich bei ubuntu wunderbar jetzt haben die ganzen kreppeln nämlich
auch fullscreen jetzt stellen wir das mit tastatur um was halte ich für ein
camelot and chain moment language deutsch einstellen ich habe es gepackt
aber also ersten sind sie das tolles hinter Zeit plan ja mehr hinter dem
zeitplan kannst du eigentlich nicht sein wie die ich weiß gar nicht wie das mit
der aktuellen Beta überhaupt aussieht.
Ob das da jetzt... Ist die... Weißt du das?
Ähm, wir hatten das gerade gefragt.
Äh, 2U
Matri. Weißt du, wie das mit der aktuellen
Beta von Camelot Unchained aussieht? Das letzte Mal, wo ich
geguckt hab, die hätte ja schon 2016 oder
irgendwie so rauskommen sollen.
Ähm...
Naja, Fail halt, ne?
Was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt, ist
dieses
Crafting-System, was sie eingebaut haben.
Das nervt mich einfach nur.
Ich mach mal die
Schrift ein bisschen größer, dass man hier was sieht.
Das Crafting-System von Camelot Unchained
geht mir einfach nur auf den Sack.
Also, dass man sowas einbaut. Also nicht das Crafting-System,
sondern dieses, dieses
Fake, Fake, äh, Minecraft.
Ähm...
Wo stellt man... Wo stellt man hier?
Ach, hier unten.
Aber dass man ordentlich was sieht.
Ah. Was haben wir hier sonst? Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Ach, das passt schon.
Klaus.
Ich mag die, ich mag die Ubuntu,
die Standard-Ubuntu-Terminal-Schrift nicht.
Also das ist, das ist Live-CD,
was wir hier gebootet haben jetzt.
Und jetzt machen wir mal die Anleitung auf
auf GitHub vom ZFS-Projekt,
wo drinne steht, wie man sich
eigene ZFS-Pakete baut.
Denn das Ziel ist ja, wir wollen
ein native-encrypted ZFS-System
verwenden und davon gibt's noch kein
offizielles Release.
Bei Ubuntu.
Ubuntu ist, ähm...
Ach, wie heißt das?
ZFS-Linux, das Paket?
Ne, wie heißt denn das?
Ja. Also bei Ubuntu ist
ZFS 0.6.5 dabei.
Aktuell offiziell letztes
Release ist, glaube ich, 0.7.3.
Und Encryption soll
erst mit 0.8 reinkommen.
Verstehe ich auch. Die wollen, dass das System erstmal
getestet ist und stabil ist.
Bevor sie da offiziell
was raushauen, releasen.
Aber, äh...
Wir wollen das ja jetzt schon ausprobieren.
Ja.
Gut. Ähm...
Ganz wichtig.
Ohne mach ich nix.
Und erinnert mich dran, falls ich's
vergesse, ich muss Snapshots machen.
Also immer, immer wenn ich was
hingekriegt hab, was ganz gut funktioniert,
muss ich einen Snapshot machen.
Sonst wär das echt blöd.
Weil das ist die Live-CD, die speichert ja nix.
Okay, ähm...
Packages. Wir wollen Custom-Packages
haben für
Ubuntu.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal
äh, wir müssen jetzt erstmal irgendwelche
Build-Tools installieren. Das kriegen wir gebacken.
RPM-Only bringt uns nix.
RPM und Debian ist okay.
Oh, es gibt
es gibt kein DKMS
für Ubuntu. Das ist doof.
Das ist blöd.
So, mal, ähm...
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist
zwischen dem und dem?
Also, rein rhetorisch gefragt, dass ich, dass
ihr jetzt sagen könnt, nein, dass ich's dann erklären kann.
Also, sprich, ähm...
Wenn man, wenn man Körnel-Module
zusätzliche Körnel-Module
einbauen möchte,
gibt's da verschiedene Varianten von.
Und ich finde, das hier ist eigentlich die
angenehmste Variante, weil
normalerweise muss das Körnel-Modul exakt
zum aktuell benutzten
Körnel passen. In dem Fall
ist es hier ein Nilungs-Körnel
4.13.0.16
bla, Dings, Ubuntu.
Und wenn ich jetzt ein Körnel-Modul baue, muss das exakt
zu dieser Körnel-Version passen.
Und sobald ich den Körnel update,
müsste ich quasi die Körnel-Module neu
kompilieren. Und wenn ich das
mit DKMS mache,
das enthält quasi alle Build-Skripte und sonstige Sachen,
ähm, dann macht er das beim Körnel-Update
automatisch. Oder kann er beim Körnel-Update
automatisch machen.
Kannst du dafür nur Fudora
empfehlen? Ja.
Ja, könnte man, könnte man machen. Aber wir machen das jetzt mit Ubuntu.
Okay, also, das erste,
was wir machen müssen, wir müssen irgendwelche
Voraussetzungen installieren, dass wir
überhaupt kompilieren dürfen. Das machen wir mal.
Was? Ach so,
ha, Moment, ha, ich hab
eins vergessen. Ich muss erstmal updaten.
Und wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Pakete,
ein paar Paketquellen, ähm,
und ein paar Paket-Repos
aktivieren, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja.
Danach geht das
wahrscheinlich.
Ja, jetzt lädt er sich auch mal die
neuesten Paketquellen runter, das heißt, jetzt
gibt's auch ein bisschen mehr zur Auswahl und jetzt
funktioniert's. So, das sind die Voraussetzungen,
die man braucht, laut, äh,
dieser Anleitung, dass man überhaupt
ZFS, äh, kompilieren darf.
Oder kann.
So, den anderen Krempel installieren wir auch noch.
Hallo, Browser.
So, ganzen Krempel
installieren. Wohlgemerkt, das hier ist nur ein
Live-System, ne? Also alles, was ich hier drauf installiere,
ist nach dem Reboot weg.
Deswegen muss ich unbedingt Snapshots
zwischendurch machen.
So, ich mach mal die Schrift ein bisschen
größer, ich hoffe, man erkennt das hier ganz gut.
Ich guck mal kurz in die Vorschau, ob das so weit passt.
Was ist hier? Ja, na,
ich glaub, man erkennt alles ganz gut, oder?
Erkennt man alles gut?
Also in meiner Vorschau sieht's okay aus.
So, was, was muss man jetzt hier machen?
Also sprich, wir wollen jetzt Debian-Pakete
bauen, beziehungsweise Ubuntu-Pakete
wollen wir bauen, für das neueste ZFS.
Ähm,
Voraussetzungen haben wir installiert,
also für Ubuntu und Debian.
Übrigens, geht euch das neue
Twitch-Layout auch so auf den Keks?
Better Twitch TV
funktioniert einmal richtig.
Ähm,
Alt-T als Shortcut
für Theater-Modus funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das, äh, dunkle,
dunkle Twitch-Theme
ist kacke, find ich.
Das, das, das selbstgebaute von denen.
Ich fand das Better Twitch TV, ähm,
Dark-Theme viel besser.
Und, was bei mir
auch nicht mehr geht, ist, dass er, während ich
quasi die, die Seite browse, das
aktuell, den aktuellen Stream, den ich offen hab,
dass er den unten beibehält, in so nem
kleinen Mini-Fenster.
Ich versteh den Sinn überhaupt nicht mehr.
Also, ich versteh generell nicht, warum,
warum,
wozu, also, ich seh,
ich seh keinen Unterschied, so richtig,
von der alten zur neuen Twitch-Seite.
Es funktioniert bloß die Hälfte nicht mehr.
Da frag ich mich, wozu braucht
man denn die neue Twitch-Seite?
Zumal die jetzt ja auch geforst am
Start ist, ne? Also, man kann die nicht
mehr, also, es gibt keine
Möglichkeit, das nicht, das alte noch zu verwenden.
So, ähm,
für, für, für, äh,
äh, Fedora.
Fedora ist ein Essen-Liefer-Service.
Ähm, so, Zeug haben wir installiert.
Und jetzt
muss man die
Zerraverse-Repos klonen. Wunderbar.
So, T-Max und
Git muss ich auf jeden Fall noch installieren, sonst kann ich nicht
arbeiten, das funktioniert nicht.
Gut.
Mal die ZFS-Repos.
Irgendwie finde ich auch, dass das Terminal-Theme
von Ubuntu grausam.
Kann man das hier nicht umschalten?
Keine Ahnung.
Naja. Ähm, so, jetzt haben wir das, äh,
äh, äh, hab ich das Repo jetzt schon geklont?
Ne. So, das
SPL-Repo muss man klonen und
die sagen, das ZFS-Repo muss man klonen.
Äh, klingt ja auch irgendwie logisch, dass man das ZFS-Repo
klonen muss, wenn man ZFS kompilieren will.
Hallo, Informatiker.
Ist das das neue Ubuntu ohne
Unity? Ja.
Das ist 17.10.
Ich glaube, 17.10 ist schon,
ist Gnome 3.
In der VM läuft
halt nicht gut, aber ich brauche
eine Live-CD, die funktioniert.
Also, es, äh, wir werden gar kein,
wie gesagt, wir installieren kein Desktop-System,
obwohl wir hier die, die Desktop, den Desktop-Installer
haben.
So, was muss man jetzt machen?
CD, SPL und jetzt muss man
Skripte ausführen.
Machen wir.
Führen wir Skripte aus.
Hey, Larin.
Ja, nochmal zum Zusammenfassen
für alle, die jetzt neu dabei sind, was wir vorhaben.
Wir wollen uns ZFS selbst
kompilieren in der aktuellsten Version, die
im Master drin ist.
Weil dort
die Encryption-Erweiterung, der Encryption-Patch
schon mit dabei ist. Dann wollen
wir uns einen ZFS,
also quasi ZFS
anlegen auf
der einzigen Platte, die hier in der VM drin hängt.
Allerdings verschlüsselt. Und
der Knackpunkt davon, wir wollen davon
booten. Nicht einfach nur
verschlüsseltes ZFS verwenden.
Das ist nicht so das Problem. Das dürfte wahrscheinlich
relativ easy sein. Aber wir wollen
davon booten.
Und
ich glaube, damit ist es echt kompliziert.
Ups.
Habe ich das alles richtig gemacht?
Skripte ausführen. Und dazu
kommt, dass ich auch nur halb jetzt so
im Kopf mich auf die Sache konzentrieren kann,
weil ich mich mit der anderen Hirnhälfte
quasi auf Stream und Chat und sonst was
konzentrieren muss. Aber
das wird schon, irgendwie wird das schon funktionieren.
Zumindest ZFS zum
Laufen kriegen werden wir. Ob wir dann, ob wir
wirklich davon booten können, da
müssen wir mal gucken.
So, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Also ich habe mir die Anleitung im
Vorfeld schon mal ein bisschen angeguckt, dass ich jetzt nicht
total wie der letzte
Kack-Noob das mache.
So, und jetzt soll man,
also die Vorbereitungen waren
jetzt, ich soll hier irgendwelche Make-Skripte
ausführen.
Und dann soll ich
noch mehr Skripte ausführen.
Machen wir alles.
Wird alles gemacht.
Solange ich mich einfach nur nach der Anleitung
richten kann.
Ich glaube, das wird funktionieren.
So Packages, das Zeug
kompilieren und Packages dazu bauen.
Das ist ja schon mehr oder weniger fix und fertig von denen,
die ganzen Skripte. Da muss ich eigentlich,
muss ich eigentlich nur ausführen. Ich glaube, das wird funktionieren.
Danach wird's,
danach wird's spannend.
Weil wir haben,
ähm,
wir haben hier eine Festplatte dran.
Das ist die,
die 40 Gigabyte,
40 Gigabyte Platte, die ich an die
VM dran gehängt habe.
Ja, Informatiker, die, also
Shortcuts hier, ich werde, ich werde
diesen Desktop hier nie verwenden.
Ich kenne mich da auch null aus mit
Gnome Shortcuts und sowas.
Was Larine sagt,
hast du gelesen, was Microsoft gemacht hat?
Da haben
sich welche die Mühe gemacht, ein altes
executable zu reverse
engineeren und sind dabei bedacht
genug vorgegangen, um die Änderung im Code
quasi genau an die Stellen des alten Codes
zu droppen und das in Assembly.
Äh, hä?
Was?
Also, die haben quasi was Neues gebastelt,
was man an der Stelle vom Alten verwenden kann, oder wie?
Muss ich mir nachher mal angucken. So, äh,
wir haben jetzt SPL ge...
Make Dapp.
Dann lasst, dann bau mal ein Debian-Paket da draus.
Nee, das habe ich nicht gelesen, Larine.
Nee.
Muss ich mir später mal angucken.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal ZFS kompilieren.
Weil es geht.
Und weil da der Encryption-Patch... Fuck, ich habe nicht
geguckt, auf welchem Brandstich ich bin.
Ich müsste auf Master sein, weil ich das Ding
gerade geklont habe.
Äh, ich muss auf jeden Fall auf Master sein.
Wenn ich nicht auf Master bin, habe ich ein Problem.
Uh, da habe ich was von 0.7.0
gelesen als Versionsnummer.
Das heißt, ich wäre nicht auf Master, ich wäre wegen dem
Ural-Tag.
Doch, ich bin auf Master.
Ja, doch, passt.
Hä, aber Glück gehabt.
So, ähm,
Install Packages. Das heißt, er hat jetzt
Debian-Pakete gebaut.
Der hat Debian-Pakete gebaut, ja, wunderbar.
Paste.
Ja, dann installiere mal.
Mach mal.
So, wie geht es dann weiter?
Next change to ZFS Directory.
Machen wir.
So, Krempel ist installiert.
Change to ZFS Directory.
Configure. Das wird, das, das, das
könnt ihr jetzt ein paar Minütchen
kompilieren.
Äh, Limbo Chains.
Sagt, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du hier machst.
Also, was ich heute probiere, ist
folgendes. Ich möchte ZFS, äh,
aus dem aktuellen
Gitmaster vom, vom, äh,
ZFS on Linux Projekt selbst kompilieren.
ZFS ist ein, so ganz grob umschrieben,
Dateisystem mit, äh,
ziemlich geilen Features.
Und am Ende will ich quasi von einem verschlüsselten
ZFS-Dateisystem booten.
Das hört sich jetzt ziemlich
simpel an, wird es aber nicht sein.
Und jetzt sind wir gerade
dabei, überhaupt erstmal ZFS zu kompilieren.
Da guckt man mal.
So, ähm, wie geht es denn weiter?
ZFS, Splat, Next.
Das haben wir ja
gerade schon gemacht.
Und dann machst du Millionen, ja, mindestens.
Mindestens Millionen.
Aber es gibt lustigerweise,
also, wenn wir das hier hinkriegen, wäre das richtig cool,
weil es gibt, ich habe keine
Anleitung gefunden,
äh,
die das irgendwie beschreibt, wie man
von einem verschlüsselten ZFS
bootet.
Also von einem
verschlüsselten,
mit, mit, in ZFS eingebauter
Verschlüsselung bootet.
Da habe ich keine Anleitung zu gefunden.
Das heißt, wir wären einer der ersten, die das hier mal
quasi im Stream irgendwo nachvollziehbar
für andere noch gemacht haben.
So.
Was habe ich jetzt als letztes ausgerichtet? Configure und jetzt
sage ich Configure und dann sage ich
Make. So, jetzt kompiliert
der ZFS.
Das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt
zwei, drei Minuten dauern, denke ich mal.
Übrigens,
wer sich jetzt denkt, boah, krass, wie viel
im Hintergrund passiert, das muss, bis man
das versteht, braucht man Jahre. Man versteht das auch
nach Jahren nicht. Nur mal so angemerkt, ne?
Klar, man könnte sich die einzelnen Sachen angucken
und kommt dann schon dahinter, was da Sache ist. Aber
ganz ehrlich, was weiß ich, was
Current BioTale
exists? No. Weiß ich, ob das gut ist.
Oder schlecht. Was ist BioTale?
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ja, Limbo Chains, wir schreiben hier Geschichte, sozusagen.
So, und jetzt machen wir
schon mal die Anleitung auf für Ubuntu
17.10 Root ZFS.
Da haben wir nämlich eine eigene Anleitung
für. Das heißt, wir müssen das jetzt so ein bisschen
kombinieren.
Die haben hier halt die Anleitung, wie man
einen Ubuntu auf einem ZFS
installiert, beziehungsweise halt
Root, also quasi
von dem Laufwerk, wo man bootet, ganz billig
gesagt, wie man das darauf
installiert. Die Anleitung funktioniert, das habe ich schon mal
ausprobiert, aber in dieser
Anleitung beschäftigt sich halt
null mit
der ZFS-Verschlüsselung. Die machen das
noch mit LUX, also sprich mit der
in Linux eingebauten Verschlüsselung
für komplette Festplatten.
Und das heißt, wir müssen
das ein bisschen abwandeln.
G-Win fragt, was sind denn
die Vorteile, die ZFS bringt?
Wo fange ich denn da jetzt am besten?
Also normalerweise brauchst
du ja unter Linux ganz viele verschiedene Tools,
um quasi
einen Software-Rate zu machen, um
zu partitionieren, beziehungsweise
für Volume-Management, für Verschlüsselung
und sowas in der Richtung. Das vereint
ZFS alles in einem,
aber es hat noch viel mehr Vorteile.
Du kannst beispielsweise relativ einfach
Snapshots machen von deinen, bei ZFS
nennt sich das Datasets.
Du hast jetzt Verschlüsselung
eingebaut, du kannst
relativ einfach quasi
sowas, so eine Art
Partitionen anlegen, sowas in der Richtung.
Es sind keine wirklichen Partitionen.
Es sind entweder Z-Volumes oder
Datasets, also sprich
entweder sowas wie Ordner oder sowas wie
eigene Festplatten, aber
die halt nur so aussehen. In Wirklichkeit gehören sie
zu diesem ZFS-Pool
mit dazu.
Es ist
schnell, es ist sicher,
also sprich ZFS
verifiziert,
das, was es geschrieben hat, ob das übereinstimmt,
also selbst wenn
die Festplatte irgendwelche Fehler hat
und
irgendwelche Sektoren und so kaputt gehen,
ZFS merkt das, ZFS kann das bis zu
einem gewissen Maß auch reparieren.
Es ist so eine reine
Software-Rate, was für mich,
da kann man sich trefflich drüber streiten,
was für mich ein riesen Vorteil ist
gegen irgendwelche Hardware-Rate-Controller.
Man kann nämlich einfach seine Festplatten nehmen und
an jede x-beliebige andere
Linux-Distribution mit ZFS stecken,
Pool importieren und es funktioniert.
Was bei Hardware-Rate nicht so ohne weiteres
der Fall ist. Da brauche ich erstmal einen
neuen Controller, falls der alte kaputt ist, oder
einen zweiten Controller und nach Möglichkeiten auch
einen halbwegs baugleichen Controller,
dass er das versteht, wie die Festplatten zusammenhängen
im Rate.
Du hast auch normalerweise
keine Probleme damit,
wenn der Strom zwischenzeitlich weg ist,
weil ZFS hat
einen
Log, also quasi
ZFS schreibt nicht einfach auf die
Platte die Daten, sondern hat
einen Log, was es macht.
Also sprich, ZFS hat quasi ein Protokoll,
da steht drinnen,
das und das mache ich jetzt
und mal angenommen,
der Strom fällt aus und das ist
nicht richtig auf der Platte drauf,
dann kann ZFS es anhand von diesem
Log erkennen.
Weil es könnte ja
und das wäre
mal sein Windows-PC früher,
zu FAT32-Zeiten und sowas,
mal ab und zu ausgeschaltet hat, ohne das Ding runter
zu fahren, dann wird festgestellt, die Festplatte geht
relativ schnell kaputt. Oh, wir sind fertig,
es ist halt fertig kompiliert.
Also sowas beugt das Ganze
ein bisschen vor, was natürlich für Server super ist.
Wie gesagt, es repariert sich
in gewisser Maßen auch noch selbst und es ist halt
eine Lösung, alles in einem. Man kann da ganz
abgedrehte Sachen noch mitmachen, mit quasi
für jeden
User ein eigenes
Dataset und sowas in der Richtung.
Das kann man auch beschränken und
richtig coole Funktionen sind Snapshots,
also sprich, vom aktuellen
Stand Snapshots machen. Diese Snapshots,
kosten erstmal relativ wenig zusätzlichen
Speicherplatz, weil die speichern sich halt nur
das Diff von Snapshot
zu Snapshot. Und was
auch noch gut an ZFS ist für Backups,
ich kann einfach
meine ZFS
Snapshots
zum Beispiel, Datasets,
was auch immer, kann ich rüber schicken
übers Netzwerk, übers Internet, sonst wo hin,
zu einem anderen Server mit ZFS.
Und das ist dann quasi sowas wie ein eingebautes Backup.
So, ZFS-Kompilierer,
jetzt haben wir hier, was müssen wir jetzt als nächstes
machen? Wir müssen den Kram installieren.
Paste.
Ich ahne Schlimmes schon.
Das Problem ist jetzt,
ja jetzt, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben
wir das erste Problem. Also,
ich glaube, dass wir das Problem haben.
Wir müssen gerade mal, ich muss gleich mal gucken,
da muss ich dann was zu erklären, warum das
ein Problem ist.
Ist die Schriftgröße so okay?
Oder soll ich eine andere Schriftart und
andere Größe nehmen?
Okay, Robot, I try to
pile my own
ZFS-Version from GitHub
Masterbranch with
built-in native
ZFS-Encryption and
then try to boot
from this encrypted volume
and I have no idea
if it will work. So, jetzt haben
wir den Kram installiert und
ich glaube, wir haben jetzt ein Problem, weil
in Ubuntu
ist ja selbst
ZFS eingebaut.
Und in Ubuntu ist ZFS-Version,
äh, 6,
4, 0,
6, 5 eingebaut. Hallo
Käpt'n Sike.
Das Problem ist, Ubuntu hat ja selbst
ZFS-Module mitgeliefert.
Und ich
habe jetzt zusätzlich quasi meine
eigenen ZFS-Pakete installiert.
So, und wenn ich jetzt mal
nachgucken würde, was der
Kernel für ein ZFS-Modul laden,
laden würde,
könnte ich wetten,
er versucht, das in Ubuntu,
eingebaute ZFS-Modul
zu laden. Was wir ja nicht wollen.
Wir wollen, dass der unser eigenes
ZFS-Modul lädt.
Also, also quasi das,
was unter Extras liegt.
Oh, wie ging der Scheiß nochmal?
Ich muss Ubuntu jetzt sagen, welche Reihenfolge
ein Kernel-Modul lädt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ähm, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie das ging. Da gab es irgendeinen Befehl für
eine Config-Datei.
What is the sequence loading?
Ja, ja.
Depp-Mod. Depp-Mod klingt gut.
Das brauchen wir.
Ich muss dem jetzt sagen, in welcher Reihenfolge er was lädt.
Weil wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich ihn jetzt einfach
ähm, ZFS-Module
laden lasse, lädt er das in
Ubuntu-Eingebaute. Und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Wir wollen ja unser selbstkompiliertes verwenden.
Wir haben das jetzt kompiliert, wir haben die Pakete installiert, aber
er hat jetzt halt zwei Module
zur Auswahl, das Eingebaute oder halt
unser selbstgebautes. Und er lädt halt standardmäßig
das Eingebaute.
Hallo, Nico.
Hey Max, was hältst du eigentlich von iPhone X?
Holst du dir eines von deinem krassen
YouTube-Money? Also, krasses YouTube-Money ist ja bei mir
jetzt eh schon eine Weile nicht mehr am Start, weil ich schlicht und ergreifend
viel zu wenig mache.
Und ich hab ein iPhone 6.
Solange das noch funktioniert, werde ich das behalten.
Wie hat der Kram
nochmal funktioniert? Man konnte dem irgendwo
sagen,
man konnte dem irgendwo sagen, in welcher Reihenfolge
er Module lädt.
ETC Depp-Mod
Config, das ist gut.
Äh.
Nicht wirklich, aber gucken wir mal da rein.
Ach, ist nicht installiert. Okay.
Jetzt erleben wir noch einen Wim. Auch gut.
Wisst ihr was, Leute? Wir machen mal einen Snapshot.
Wir machen mal einen Snapshot.
Sicher ist sicher.
So.
Okay, und was sagt mir das jetzt?
Search Updates Ubuntu Build-In.
Ah ja, okay. Build-In ist was im
Kernel einkompiliert ist. Ubuntu ist was Ubuntu
mitliefert.
Äh.
Was will ich für das
Kram funktionieren?
Ähm.
Also, wenn ihr Fragen habt,
schießt los. Ich habe immer ein Auge auf den Chat
nebenbei.
Weil, wenn ich jetzt einfach stumpf irgendwelche
Anleitungen lese, ist das ja auch nicht so spannend.
Übrigens, Autokorrektur
von Google Beste muss man, muss man
verwenden. Hallo, Zweit92.
Ah, ja.
Extras und das will ich haben.
Wir schreiben
das einfach rein.
Easy. Extras.
Bam.
Ah, Moment. Es ist, es ist
extra.
Extra.
Jawoll. Nice.
So, und wenn ich jetzt mal den, wenn ich
jetzt mal nachgucke, was würde er jetzt
für ein ZFS-Modul laden?
Hoffe ich mal, dass es, ähm,
07 irgendwas ist.
Ja. Jawoll.
Nice. Nice, nice.
Jetzt würde er das aktuelle ZFS, das richtige
ZFS-Modul laden. Und ich
hoffe, ich habe noch kein
ZFS geladen. Ne, habe ich nicht. Wunderbar.
Ja, dann funktioniert doch alles.
ZFS?
List?
Geht nicht, weil keine Module geladen sind.
Dann laden wir mal das Modul.
Komm, please. Ah, nice.
Okay, das Kompilieren hat schon mal funktioniert.
Alles da. No-Data-Sätze. Funktionieren.
Also prinzipiell unser selbstkompiliertes ZFS
funktioniert. Sieht zumindest auf den ersten Blick so aus.
Ähm, Iron Horse HD.
Wie kompensierst du die Trauer, die Deutschland
hinsichtlich der läppischen mobilen
Datentarife verursacht?
Ähm, das ist bei mir relativ einfach. Ich bezahle den
einfach nicht selbst.
Ich habe einen 3GB-Tarif von der Arbeit.
In Anführungsstrichen gesponsert.
Nicht wirklich gesponsert, aber
ich meine, die kriegen ja auch was für. Ich meine, ich habe ein Handy
und bin da potenziell
erreichbar, wenn was ganz
Schlimmes wäre. Aber
die Handytarife, beziehungsweise
die Datentarife in Deutschland sind echt der allerletzte
Witz. Ich habe letztens mal geguckt.
Ich glaube, Kongstar war das.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass wir solche Streams machen?
Wissen wir eigentlich, dass wir solche Streams machen?
Ich glaube, dass wir solche Streams unglaublich Bock machen.
Ich kann irgendwas erzählen, was mich interessiert.
Irgendeinen Scheiß labern zwischendurch.
Links und rechts nochmal ein paar Sachen angucken.
Und so muss das sein.
Das ist mir auch vollkommen egal, ob ich da jetzt
tausend Leute
oder hundert Leute zugucke.
Solange wir ein paar zugucken.
Ich habe letztens mal geguckt
bei Kongstar
und zwar auch, wie hieß der Kram?
Ja, Kongstar
bietet kein LTE. Das juckt mich nicht.
Brauche ich nicht.
Für Streams reicht.
Hier Daten.
Kongstar hatte doch irgendwie sowas, wo man
so einen Slider
wo man selbst konfigurieren konnte
oder so.
Ja, sowas hier, wie ich will. Kongstar zum Tarif.
So, da konnte man nämlich sagen,
ich telefoniere
nicht, ich schicke keine SMS,
ich will surfen und
ich habe da letztens
was gefunden mit 4 GB.
Ich bilde mir ein,
ich habe da letztens was gefunden mit 4 GB.
Warum
gibt es denn das jetzt nicht mehr?
Warum gibt es das nicht mehr?
Ich könnte wetten, ich habe letztens
einen 4 GB Tarif gefunden.
Und vielleicht gibt es das nicht mehr.
Ja, den Kack
hier will ich ja nicht. Ich will nicht telefonieren,
SMS verschicken will ich auch nicht.
Hi Cyberlink,
zum Tarif.
Ne, das war nicht das.
Aktion, genau, man konnte Turbo.
So, und das ging aber doch hier auch.
Ich habe mir letztens einen Tarif konfiguriert,
da konnte ich den ganzen Scheiß rausschmeißen,
den ich nicht wollte, weil ich brauche keine
Telefonminuten, ich brauche vor allem
schon mal gar keine SMS mehr.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht.
Naja, egal.
Das soll jetzt ja nicht um irgendwelche
Handy-Tarife gehen.
Aber es ist traurig in
Deutschland. Es ist wirklich traurig
in Deutschland, wie das um Datentarife ausschaut.
Und ein Vogel
abschießt die Telekom, da ist das Zeug so
teuer. Also die, die sich lohnen, wo man
sagen würde, hey, damit kann man arbeiten, damit kann man was machen,
die sind so teuer, das ist
für den Arsch.
So, weiter geht's.
Also, wir haben ZFS kompiliert,
ZFS funktioniert, ZFS-Module geladen,
ZFS-Kommandos funktionieren.
Prinzipiell
soweit, so gut.
Dann machen wir mal weiter mit dieser
Anleitung hier. Also sprich,
wie installiert man, ich mach nochmal einen Snapshot.
Ich kann nie genug
Snapshots machen.
Wie gesagt, das ist eine Live-CD, wenn
wir das abkacken und die Scheiße baut, ist halt alles weg.
Deswegen Snapshots.
So, dann gucken wir uns
nochmal die Anleitung an. Also das hab ich auf meinem
Server selbst schon gemacht hier.
Ubuntu install auf ZFS root,
das funktioniert. Wir müssen das
bloß ein bisschen anpassen.
Prepare install environment.
Ah, das haben wir schon gemacht, haben wir auch schon gemacht.
Brauchen wir nicht, PSSH,
wir sind direkt drauf.
Become root muss ich auch nicht, hab ich auch schon.
Den Kram muss ich installieren.
Allerdings den hier muss ich nicht installieren.
Weil
den hab ich ja selbst.
Und wenn ich jetzt hier nämlich suche, nach
ZFS, dann sieht man auch,
dass es install local install ist.
Also sprich, von selbstgebauten Paketen.
Also eine wirklich dauerhafte
Lösung ist das natürlich nicht.
Also sprich,
wenn ich das jetzt wirklich live, also wenn ich das jetzt
wirklich auf einem Server betreiben würde,
dann wäre es ein bisschen blöd, da müsste ich
bei jedem Kernel-Update quasi neue
ZFS-Module kompilieren.
Und
wahrscheinlich viel von Hand
rumfrickeln.
Aber mir geht es ja erstmal darum, dass man prinzipiell weiß,
wie es funktioniert.
Um das live einzusetzen, also wirklich produktiv auf
irgendein System, würde ich warten, bis es dann
ZFS 08 gibt, also sprich
die Version, die Encryption
mit eingebaut hat. Aber wir wollen es ja nochmal
ausprobieren.
Be happy, das stimmt. In anderen Ländern
gibt es viel bessere Flatrates.
Sogar in der Schweiz.
Man sagt, oh in der Schweiz ist alles so teuer.
In der Schweiz gibt es richtig gute
Unlimited Mobilfunktarife.
Für,
finde ich,
Schweizer Verhältnisse will ich Geld.
Ansonsten ist der Kram ja da
übertrieben teuer.
Okay, wie geht es dann weiter?
Install ZFS, haben wir gemacht.
Unser eigenes, und zwar nicht das von Ubuntu.
Disk Formatting.
If you are reusing a disk,
clear. Nein, wir re-usen keine
disk. Oh,
jetzt wird es interessant.
Partition your disk.
Run disk.
Oh, könnt ihr euch noch
daran erinnern? Habe ich jetzt auf EFI Boot
umgestellt, am Anfang meine VM?
Ich hoffe.
Oh, wisst ihr das noch?
Habe ich in der VM
BIOS oder EFI eingestellt?
Ich glaube, ich habe auf EFI
umgestellt am Anfang, oder?
Ja, ja, zum Glück.
Jetzt könnt ihr den Scheiß nochmal machen.
Weil, ich meine,
ich will ja, dass es auch irgendwas mit der Realität zu tun hat.
BIOS Boot.
Naja, mach es ja heute einstimmig.
So, partition
your disk.
BIOS partitioning. Uefi booting,
genau. So.
Wir wollen jetzt
partition, warum macht er denn
Partitionsnummer 3
für Boot?
Beziehungsweise, warum macht er Partitionsnummer 3
für Uefi?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich mache das jetzt aber mal
genau so, wie das die Anleitung schreibt.
Allerdings
nicht devdisk sonst was,
sondern devsda,
weil halt VM.
Gut.
Wir können uns das auch gleich nochmal
grafisch dann angucken,
falls es drauf ist.
Und hier, bla, bam,
512 Boot
EFI Partition.
Dann brauchen wir,
wie machen sie
denn hier weiter?
Ja, hast du extra gesagt.
Ja, ich habe nachgeguckt, habe ich wirklich gemacht.
Zum Glück.
Also wir brauchen am Ende
brauchen wir 3 Partitionen.
Wir brauchen 3 Partitionen.
Wir brauchen eine EFI Partition, die haben wir jetzt hier schon
gemacht. Wir brauchen
eine Boot Partition. Ganz
wichtig, wenn wir das vergessen, bin ich mir sicher,
wird es garantiert nicht funktionieren,
weil Crap kein
Encrypted ZFS, also Boot
nicht von einem Encrypted ZFS laden kann.
Noch nicht. Gibt es bestimmt schon, gibt es
bestimmt schon einen Patch, gucken wir mal.
Aber
einen eigenen Crap kompilieren wir uns
jetzt definitiv nicht.
Ne, Lux wollen wir nicht.
Auch kein Lux.
Native Encrypted ZFS.
Ja,
guck, hier gibt es schon einen Feature
Request, gibt es noch nicht. Also Crap kann
das nicht.
Also Crap kann nicht von
Native Encrypted ZFS booten. Das geht
nicht. Deswegen brauchen wir auf jeden
Fall eine Boot Partition.
Könnt ihr mir halbwegs folgen?
So, war blöd
gefragt, weil ansonsten kann ich noch ein bisschen
mehr drum herum erklären.
Also Linux Boot Vorgang
läuft ja prinzipiell so ab.
Du hast erstmal, oder sagen wir mal, was heißt
Linux Boot Vorgang? Boot Vorgang, allgemein.
Ähm, nachdem
das BIOS
die Sache an den Boot Manager übergeben hat,
in dem Fall Crap,
ähm,
und Crap hat halt eine Konfiguration,
wo drinnen steht, äh,
was es für Betriebssysteme zur Auswahl hat
und auf welcher Platte die sind und wo die anfangen
und sowas in der Richtung, ähm,
und wenn dann das Booten von Linux
anfängt, muss Crap
irgendwo ja her
quasi an den Linux Kernel
übergeben. Also Crap muss irgendwie den Linux Kernel
starten. Und
Crap kann das normalerweise
von allen handelsüblichen
Filesystemen machen.
Und der Linux Kernel liegt gewöhnlich
in einem Verzeichnis, das nennt sich
Slash Boot. Und
von dort versucht eben Crap
den Linux Kernel zu laden und
an den quasi dann
zu übergeben. So nach dem Motto, Kernel starten,
auf geht's. Ja, in den starten,
auf geht's. Und
ähm, das
kann Crap aber nur machen,
wenn Crap
das, den Kernel
von der Platte lesen kann. Und Crap
kann den Kernel von der Platte nur lesen,
wenn Crap eben
das, das Dateisystem versteht.
Was, worauf der Kernel liegt.
Und ZFS versteht
Crap mittlerweile, aber
verschlüsseltes ZFS versteht
Crap nicht. Das heißt, wenn ich mein
Slash Boot in einem verschlüsselten
ZFS drinne hab, wird
Crap das nicht starten können.
Deswegen brauchen wir
unbedingt, neben unserer
EFI Partition, dass es überhaupt anfängt
zu booten, brauchen wir
unbedingt Slash Boot auf
einer eigenen Partition, die eben
nicht ZFS ist, beziehungsweise
nicht Encrypted ZFS, sondern
sagen wir Ext4 oder sowas, oder Ext2
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
So. So, soweit zur Erklärung.
Deswegen brauchen wir am Ende
drei Partitionen, nämlich eine
EFI Partition, eine
so denke ich mir das zumindest,
eine Boot Partition mit irgendwas
anderem, mit irgendeinem normalen Dateisystem drauf,
könnte wahrscheinlich sogar FAT32
sein oder sowas, und
eine dritte fette Partition
mit dem restlichen Speicherplatz,
die dann ZFS verwenden wird.
So.
xshadowghost fragt
Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu
Bitcoin und anderen Cryptocurrencies?
Ich finde das prinzipiell gut.
Also ich
hänge nicht unbedingt
jetzt hier an echter
Kohle, ja. Also ich finde
Cryptowährung an sich gut,
weil es auch ein relativ unabhängiges System ist.
Die Frage ist aber
ob. Also wenn die Frage
ist, ob es sinnvoll ist quasi in
Cryptowährungen zu investieren oder
mitzumachen oder sowas, ist das halt einfach
Spekulation wie bei vielen anderen Sachen
auch, ne. Ich meine
man spekuliert ja da auf mehrere Sachen.
Man spekuliert drauf, dass die Cryptowährung
auf die man setzt,
erfolgreich wird, beziehungsweise
wenn es sich abzeichnet, dass sie erfolgreich wird,
dass der Kurs ungefähr gleich bleibt
oder am besten auch steigt.
Man investiert Zeit,
Geld, Strom, alles mögliche da rein.
Also sprich, das ist eine Spekulation
wie wenn ich mir
ne, es ist vielleicht
nicht ganz so schlimm, wie wenn ich jetzt zu
irgendwie, wie wenn ich CSGO Skins
wette oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber sag mal so,
ich würde es mal in ähnliche
Sachen
Kategorie sagen, wie ich kaufe mir Aktien
in irgendeiner Firma, ja, wo ich nicht genau weiß,
wie sich das entwickeln wird.
Also das ist schon Spekulation da
in Cryptowährung zu investieren.
Und es gibt Leute, die
sagen, wieso? Kostet mich doch nix.
PC mit Grafikkarte hab ich eh.
Die einfachste Antwort ist da drauf,
bezahlst du nix für deinen Strom?
Minen
kostet Massenenergie,
ja, also sprich,
Cryptowährung mining lastet den
Rechner ordentlich aus. Grafikkarte,
CPU, hauptsächlich Grafikkarte, je nach
Cryptowährung.
Und das zieht Strom ohne Ende.
Und der Strom ist nicht billig
hier.
Also es ist generell fraglich,
ob sich Cryptowährung mining mit normaler
Rechner, also mit so normaler Desktop
Hardware überhaupt lohnt.
Wo es sich lohnt, sind
neuere Cryptowährungen, wo es noch recht
einfach ist, neue
Einheiten,
neue Münzen, wie auch immer es da heißt,
in der jeweiligen Währung zu generieren.
Dann spekuliert man aber wieder drauf,
dass sich diese Cryptowährung in Zukunft
durchsetzen wird. Also wenn die sich nicht
durchsetzt, ich mein, es gibt ja hunderttausende
Cryptowährungen, wenn die sich nicht durchsetzt,
dann hab ich die Zeit und Geld und Stromkosten
auch in den Sand gesetzt.
So, weiter geht's.
Also wie gesagt, drei Partitionen brauchen wir.
Wir haben jetzt die erste,
die erste EFI Partition.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch eine,
und zwar, warum fangen die
in der Anleitung eigentlich von hinten an? Hat das
in irgendeinem Sinn,
dass quasi, dass quasi EFI Partitionen
und Boot, dass die hinten kommen?
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung. Wir machen das einfach auch so.
So, wir machen noch eine zweite Partition,
die fängt jetzt ab 513
Megabyte an.
Warum 513? Naja, weil die
andere ja schon, ne,
weil die andere bis 512 geht. Die machen
wir mal 2048
groß, ist einfach so über den Daumen gepeilt,
keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Das ist meine Partition, die ich für Slash-Boot
verwenden werde.
So, und nun machen wir abschließend
noch,
jetzt machen wir abschließend noch ne
Partition
mit dem Rest
für
wo dann
mein ZFS drauf kommt.
So,
gucken wir uns das mal hier in Gparted an.
Wir haben drei Partitionen, eins, zwei, drei.
Hier kommt später ZFS drauf.
Äh, hier kommt Boot drauf.
Hab ich genug Platz, kann ich einige Körner drauf
installieren und das ist die EFI Partition.
Also, von vorne nach hinten.
Gut. Ähm,
Smoker
Jumper
fragt, moin Max, habe angefangen
Medieninformatik zu studieren
und bin in der
Programmierwelt relativ neu. Lerne jetzt
mit Java zu programmieren. Was ist
deiner Meinung nach die wichtigsten Sachen, die man wissen
muss?
Ähm, hast du schon
irgendwelche Vorkenntnisse?
Ansonsten würde ich mir einfach mal irgendwie
nen Einsteiger-Java-Buch
schnappen, gibt's ja auch kostenlose.
Und mir das einfach ein bisschen angucken.
Ansonsten ist
das Wichtigste, dass man sich auf die Sache einlässt.
Das ist ja eigentlich bei den
meisten Sachen das Wichtigste, dass man
nicht von Anfang an sagt, so ne Kacke.
Ja, und
der Nilsson hat Recht, Google gucken.
Man sollte sich nicht so fein
sein, zu sagen, hey, ich krieg das selbst
raus oder ich find's sogar
fast übertrieben, stundenlang
irgendwelche, ähm, Hilfedokumentationen
zu lesen,
weil man kann sich das zwar alles
selbst erarbeiten und
selbst rausfinden,
aber oftmals gibst du in Google was ein und
die erste Stack-Overflow-Antwort ist genau das, was du
haben willst und vor allem von jemand, der
weiß, was er macht. Hoffentlich.
Zumindest. Okay, weiter
im Text jetzt hier. Nicht so viel rumlabern.
So, wir haben die Festplatte
partitioniert.
...
Sprich, ähm,
wir haben drei Partitionen, äh,
Lux Encryption können wir auslassen, brauchen wir nicht.
...
Ähm, wie geht's denn weiter?
Create
Root Pool. Genau das wollen wir
jetzt machen. So, das wird jetzt nicht
funktionieren, weil es den Pass nicht gibt. So,
und jetzt müssen wir ZFS
Encryption einschalten. Ja,
CaptainZKStack, Overflow-Driven
äh, Programming, Development, beste.
So,
jetzt müssen wir dem Pool sagen, da hab ich schon
nachgeguckt, wie das funktioniert.
Jetzt müssen wir beim Erstellen des Pools sagen,
bitte Verschlüsselung verwenden.
Und das funktioniert erst ab
Vers... ab Version
08, wenn sie dann mal irgendwann released ist,
oder halt, wenn man den aktuellen
ähm, Masterstand sich selbst kompiliert hat.
Ja, dann gibt's hier quasi
auch die Einträge für Encryption.
So.
Äh, was?
Was gibt's denn hier zur Auswahl?
Für Algorithmen.
IIS 128,
IIS... ganz ehrlich,
kein Schimmer. Wir nehmen
einfach mal den hier. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm,
geht ja auch nur ums Ausprobieren. Okay,
also, wir wollen
einen neuen ZFS Pool
erstellen. Und zwar
wollen wir sagen Encryption
gleich das hier.
Wir wollen das Verschlüssel verwenden.
Und wir wollen, äh,
KeyFormat gleich Pass
Rates. Also sprich, Passwort.
Wir wollen keine Special
Keys auf nem USB-Stick oder irgendwie sowas
verwenden. Nein, wir wollen einfach ein stinknormales
Passwort eingeben.
Wenn man on nimmt, ist da Standard IIS
256 TCM.
Okay.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal den. Ist zum Testen ja ziemlich
wurscht. Hallo, Imperatorchen.
So.
Die restlichen
Settings. Das ist ja hier so
Standard für 4K.
Blöcke.
Mountain.
Müssen wir
das nicht direkt.
Compression
würde ich immer einschalten.
Also wenn ihr mal vor der Wahl steht,
sei es jetzt ZFS oder viele andere Dateisysteme,
bieten ja mittlerweile auch
sowas wie Verschlüsselung an. In der Regel
kann man heute Kompression einfach
einschalten.
Das ist so optimiert mittlerweile.
Und, äh,
ich weiß nicht, ob es
CPUs gibt oder sowas, die quasi
direkt Unterstützung für spezielle
Kompressions-Dekompressions-
Algorithmen haben, glaube ich nicht. Aber
man kann die Sachen relativ effizient mit
den richtigen CPU-Instruktionen
abbilden. Und
Kompression ist eigentlich sauschnell
und kostet kaum Performance. Deswegen würde ich
eigentlich Kompression immer einschalten,
wenn es geht. Bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla. So, jetzt müssen wir noch die
Festplatte angeben.
So, und zwar, das wollen wir jetzt
erstellen auf SDR1.
SDR1 ist ja die Partition, die wir angelegt haben.
Für unser ZFS.
Hast du bei ZFS schon mal mit
Deed Application gearbeitet? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Hat mich bisher immer, äh, abgeschreckt.
Weil
überall, wo man was zu Deed Application
mit ZFS liest, liest man, dass das
Naja,
es ist nicht schlecht implementiert. Es funktioniert,
aber es braucht wohl Unmengen RAM
und hat viele Fallstricke.
Ja. Ich finde so wirklich wichtig
bei Deed, äh, so wirklich wichtig
bei Deed Application ist es eigentlich
hauptsächlich bei Backups.
Äh,
ah, äh, Rosenpliatschen,
darf ich mal blöd fragen, was
ZFS überhaupt ist? Darfst du natürlich fragen.
ZFS ist, ähm,
mal ganz grob gesagt ein Dateisystem,
allerdings noch viel mehr. Es ist eigentlich
Dateisystem, Volume Manager,
ähm, ja,
Encryption mittlerweile,
ähm, Software Raid, alles in
einem.
Ja, mit vielen Vorteilen noch dabei.
Ein, also eines der Nachteile
von ZFS ist tatsächlich der RAM Verbrauch.
ZFS braucht ziemlich viel RAM, oder was heißt
braucht ziemlich viel RAM, hätte
gerne ziemlich viel RAM.
Okay. Zpool Create, blablabla,
blablabla, so, das wird schon stimmen.
So. Es, es
funktioniert prinzipiell schon mal. Es fragt mich nach
meinem Passwort. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Oh, ist zu kurz.
Na gut, ähm,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Bam.
Nice.
Also unser selbst kompiliertes ZFS
funktioniert.
Inklusive Encryption. Das ist schon mal
der erste wirklich wichtige
Schritt. Wenn das nicht funktioniert,
dann hätten wir es eigentlich gleich sein lassen
können. Machen wir gleich mal einen Snapshot.
Ähm, was hältst du von,
hallo, warum,
kann ich das jetzt mal auf
Vollbild schalten? Ich habe keinen
Bock das jetzt im Fenster zu verwenden.
Alter Lan.
Was ist hier los?
Okay, äh,
äh, ich glaube vor allem
wer hat, oh, ach,
der speichert noch meinen
Snapshotstand. Vielleicht geht es deswegen nicht.
Der ist aber
ganz schön lahm hier unten.
Naja, ich meine,
ich kann immer hier noch Display. Man könnte,
man kann das glaube ich so einstellen.
Was sind das für Drecksauflösungen? Warum gibt es
nicht einfach 1900?
Gibt es Customauflösungen?
Seht ihr hier irgendwo 1920, 1080?
Machen wir es halt so.
Kann ich auch mitleben.
Vielleicht geht, vielleicht geht es ja gleich wieder, wenn der
Snapshot, wenn der Snapshot gespeichert ist.
Oh, es gibt mittlerweile einen Dark
Mode. Das ist ja cool.
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine Customauflösung
hier?
Hängengeblieben.
Naja, aber stack mal, so geht das auch.
So,
ähm, äh,
was gibt es noch für Fragen? Was ist ein Dateisystem?
Boah, das ist schwierig zu umschreiben.
Ähm,
im Endeffekt ist
ein Dateisystem so die Zwischenschicht
zwischen Festplatte
und dem, was du so in deinem
Windows Explorer siehst.
Äh, der Buch halt, da sage ich
gleich was dazu. Also
sprich, ein Dateisystem
ist, ist der
Teil dazwischen, der halt
managt so die,
die logische Sicht auf
die Platte.
Mit dem, wie es wirklich auf der
Platte gespeichert ist.
Also ich meine, wenn du in deinem
Windows Explorer siehst, dass du jetzt hier
Video.mp4 hast,
dann gibt es dieses
Video.mp4 natürlich nicht so auf
deiner Festplatte drauf.
Sondern das liegt auf irgendwelchen Blöcken
verteilt auf der Festplatte oder auf der SSD.
Und das Dateisystem weiß
jetzt quasi, welche Blöcke
zu dieser logischen Datei
oder zu dieser logischen Einheit gehören.
Und wenn du dann das in deine
Windows Explorer anklickst, das Video,
dann sagst du, hey, ich möchte Video.mp4
öffnen, dann
sorgt das Dateisystem für, dass die Daten aus
den richtigen Blöcken geladen werden.
So, so ungefähr. Das glaube ich, umschreibt es
ganz gut, was ein Dateisystem ist.
Ähm,
hast du vor, ZFS produktiv
einzusetzen? Und wenn ja, für was?
War am Anfang des Streams nicht da.
Ich setze ZFS schon produktiv,
zumindest bei mir daheim ein, auf meinem Server.
Der bootet auch von ZFS, aber
der Gag hier im Stream ist jetzt
ja,
der Gag im Stream ist ja, ich möchte
eine eigene ZFS-Version
kompilieren
mit Encryption.
So, jetzt ist der Snapshot fertig und es geht immer noch nicht
ins Vollbild. Nein, ich will auch nicht installieren.
TF, äh,
cancel, quit, geht's, geh weg.
Kann ich das Display
wieder, kann ich wieder sagen,
mach mal Auflösung automatisch?
Geht das?
Kann man das
abschießen, dieses VMware-Zeug?
Ah ja,
vor allem mal tut's.
Die killen wir jetzt einfach mal, bam!
Ah, Quatsch, was mache ich denn hier? Kill, wo ist dann hier die?
Äh,
okay, naja, die VR mag
das nicht mehr, die Auflösung
ändern, aber da müssen wir jetzt hier mit
auskommen.
Custom Resolution,
ich hätte schon ganz gerne mal wieder den
Bildschirm.
Hallo!
Macht's doch komplizierter, äh.
Naja, wir kommen, wir kommen glaube ich
mit der Auflösung auch aus.
So, machen wir mal weiter. Ähm,
wisst ihr was, wir
Restoren einfach jetzt mal, ach komm,
äh, wurscht.
Ähm,
wo sind wir denn jetzt stehen geblieben bei der Anleitung?
Wir haben jetzt unseren,
wir haben jetzt unseren ZFS-Pool angelegt.
Apfeltroll fragt, warum ich nicht reinsappen
kann, weil ich noch kein Twitch-Partner bin.
Und bis jetzt das auch noch nicht
angestrebt hab. So, wir haben jetzt unseren ZFS angelegt.
Ähm,
hier machen sie irgendwas mit
Encryption, das müssen wir nicht machen.
Ich muss jetzt bloß aufpassen,
dass ich nichts vergesse.
Create a File System Dataset
to Act as a Container. Okay, das machen wir,
das wollen wir haben. Hier drauf
werden wir dann letztendlich, beziehungsweise in einem Dataset
hier drin. Ein Dataset ist quasi
in ZFS, ähm,
man könnte sagen
sowas wie, so ein Zwischending zwischen
einer Partition und einem Ordner. Es ist
eher ein Ordner.
Also die voneinander getrennte
Ordner,
wenn man so will.
Ähm,
Create a File System Dataset for Root
File System of Ubuntu System. Genau das
wollen wir haben.
Darauf installieren wir jetzt gleich
unser,
unser Ubuntu drauf.
ZFS Mounts,
Ubuntu, oh, ich hab ne Donation gekriegt.
Da fuck, muss ich, muss ich
nachgucken. Apfelschorle,
5 Euro, danke.
Muss man das halt so regeln.
Ja, das ist nett
von dir, dankeschön. Ähm,
so.
Jetzt haben wir das angelegt.
Wir haben es gemounted.
Äh,
haben wir es schon
gemounted?
Wir haben es gemounted, ne?
Wir haben es gemounted,
ja, genau.
So, und jetzt machen wir
ne Ubuntu Installation
von Hand. Also quasi,
das, was der Installer unter der Haube macht,
müssen wir jetzt von Hand ausführen, weil
wir können den Installer nicht verwenden.
Der Installer, ähm,
unterstützt kein ZFS
und vor allem diese Special-Sachen, die ich hier mache, schon mal
ganz und gar nicht. Ich muss jetzt nur aufpassen,
dass ich nichts vergesse.
Ich muss nämlich noch meine,
ich muss nämlich noch meine Boot-Position
formatieren.
Mit irgendwie nem x2 oder 4 oder so.
So, Datasets, das hier ist
ne schöne Variante. Jetzt, jetzt, hier sieht
man schön die Vorteile von ZFS.
Das ist hier ein ganz gutes Beispiel für,
ähm, was man
schönes mit ZFS machen kann. Also sprich,
die Teile, die unterschiedlichen, äh,
Teile von so ner Ordnerstruktur
unter Linux, werden hier in diesem
Beispiel, das machen wir jetzt nicht, weil es ja
alles in root rein und gut ist, ähm,
werden hier einzelne Datasets angelegt,
also quasi einzelne Ordner, die man
unabhängig voneinander verwalten kann.
Das heißt, und das richtig coole ist,
ich könnte jetzt beispielsweise, bevor ich nen
Systemupdate mache, wenn ich Angst habe,
dass ich quasi mit nem Systemupdate
oder mit nem Paketupdate was zerschießen
könnte, würde ich nen Snapshot machen,
von, äh, von meinem System,
und der würde dann nur
das System snapshotten und beispielsweise nicht
das Log verzeichnen, das heißt, ich verliere keine Logs,
und
wenn es nach dem Update, das Paket
irgendwelche Probleme macht, dann könnte ich
einfach diesen Snapshot wieder restoren,
rebooten, gut ist.
Das ist wirklich saumäßig praktisch.
Auch für Backups.
Snapshots an sich sind natürlich kein Backup,
wenn ich den Snapshot
dann aber mit ZFS Send
an ein anderes System,
an einen anderen Standort schicken kann,
dann ist es ein Backup.
So. Jetzt, jetzt,
interessant.
Das wollen wir machen,
wie gesagt, wir verwenden keinen Logs,
aber ich brauche ja ne extra Bootpartition.
Sonst funktioniert's nicht.
Und zwar SDA2 ist meine,
wird meine Bootpartition sein.
Ja, funktioniert.
Ähm, mounten wir,
mal. Jawoll.
Jetzt müsste ich hier das schon reingemountet haben.
Hier kommt unser Linux-Kördel rein,
klein. Und es ist wichtig,
dass er in nem, auf ner anderen,
das kann ich nur nochmal sagen, auf ner anderen Partition
liegt, dass Krupp den starten kann.
Weil Krupp kann das nicht, von ner
verschlüsselten
ZFS Partition.
So, jetzt haben wir das gemountet.
Das brauchen wir nicht, den Ordner gibt's nicht.
Und das hier ist die eigentliche,
eigentliche Ubuntu-Installation.
Das ist das, was der Installer unter der Haube ausführt.
Und wir haben, wir haben jetzt quasi
das, äh,
ZFS-System, auf dem, von dem gleich
unser Ubuntu laufen soll,
haben wir jetzt gemountet nach slash mnt
und sagen dem Installer jetzt,
installiere den Ubuntu-System,
das ist der aktuelle Codename für das aktuelle
Ubuntu, was wir hier runtergeladen haben,
installiere das System unterhalb von
diesem Pfad, slash mnt.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe, müssen wir kurz warten,
bis es fertig ist.
Und danach muss ich gucken, ob ich's richtig
gemountet hab, also sprich, ob Speicherplatz auf meinem
ZFS belegt ist. Was mir ein bisschen auf den
Sack geht, dass ich kein Vollbild machen kann, ne?
Das ist dezent nervig.
Warum ist das denn so langsam?
Das ist übertrieben langsam.
Oh, ist mal wieder
die, ist mal wieder die, die
Telekom-Anbindung für'n Arsch.
Das müsste normalerweise viel, viel schneller
gehen. Oh, und wenn's jetzt daran
scheitern sollte, wäre natürlich kacke, dass
sich mal wieder nichts runterladen kann.
Hab ich irgendwas vorher vergessen?
Ich hab ja das System noch gar nicht mal
installiert. Und prinzipiell
funktioniert ja hier Internet-Zeugs
über die VM.
Wartet mal.
Ich mach jetzt einfach noch mal
hier off und noch mal on.
Sollte eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen.
Die Verbindung zu den
Ubuntu-Servern ist einfach, einfach
lahm. So, ich bin wieder da.
Ja, ähm,
das ist natürlich doof.
Erstens, hab ich gehört, es gibt gleich Mittagessen.
Und zweitens...
Äh...
Die Ubuntu-Server sind am Arsch.
Ah!
Es funktioniert jetzt, okay.
Wir machen dann gleich nach dem Mittagessen weiter.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Aber das Ubuntu-System installieren wir jetzt noch.
Wir machen jetzt noch die nächsten paar Schritte
soweit fertig.
Also, wir installieren jetzt ein Ubuntu nach
SlashMNT.
Und, ähm...
Es gibt's ein leckeres Nudel. Nudel gibt's.
Wir installieren ZFS jetzt nach...
Äh, wir installieren Ubuntu jetzt nach SlashMNT.
Gucken, ob das ZFS-mäßig alles
funktioniert hat bis hierhin.
Dann machen wir nochmal einen Snapshot.
Nudels, genau.
Haha.
Tut er es.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da Pest dabei ist.
Eher nicht.
Ich tippe mal
eher auf irgendwie Schinken und
Pilze und sowas.
Ja, auf jetzt, komm. Go, go.
Zerlier den Krempel mal.
Das geht jetzt relativ schnell hier alles.
Weil ich meine, es ist eine VM
auf einer SSD.
Auf einer M2 SSD.
Also auf einer relativ schnellen SSD.
Normale Ubuntu-Installation, wenn man das hier
mit dem Installer macht. Am besten auch noch
auf einer Hardwarekiste.
Das dauert einen Ticken länger.
Aber hier in der VM geht das recht schnell.
So, habe ich irgendwelche Fragen überlesen
bisher?
Kann man inzwischen
nicht auch ihre Partnersubs haben?
Ja, kann man. Kann man.
Kann man als Affiliate anmelden, aber
das sehe ich nicht ein.
Will ich nicht.
Will mich nicht als Affiliate anmelden.
Dann kriegst du da ein Emote
und gedöhnt.
Also wenn ich mal
das irgendwann mache, dass ich hier quasi mich auch
dass ich hier einen Sub-Button habe
und mich so hier drüber
supporten kann, dann will ich das auch direkt
als Twitch-Partner machen, dass ich dann auch die Vorteile
habe von mehreren Emotes und sowas. Ich habe hier richtig coole
Emote-Ideen, aber habe ich jetzt
eigentlich mache ich jetzt die ganze Stream-Geschichte
hier wirklich nur,
dass ich machen kann, was ich will
und meine Ruhe habe.
Gut, Ubuntu ist installiert unter root.
Jetzt müssen wir noch so ein paar Basic-Konfigurationen
vornehmen, die normalerweise
der Installer für uns macht.
Unser System bekommt,
unser neues System bekommt, achso ich muss erst mal gucken.
Ja.
240 MB kommt ungefähr hin für eine frische Ubuntu-Installation.
Man sieht es jetzt auch, unser Slash-MNT ist quasi
mein zukünftiges
Linux-System installiert.
Jetzt muss ich noch einstellen, wie das System heißen soll.
Unser System heißt,
komm, unser System heißt
Hostname.
So, da müssen wir das System natürlich noch eintragen
in die Host, dass es sich selbst auflösen kann.
So, unser System heißt Hostname.
Bester Name überhaupt.
ENS33
ist die Netzwerkkarte.
Wir wollen ja auch, dass es eine IP
hat, wenn es hochkommt.
Äh.
Bring Swim,
Leute, ne.
Visual-Mode kopieren, gleich ist
neu formatieren.
Configure Package
Sources, jawoll, machen wir
auch Package Sources.
Zack.
So, und jetzt
kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Wir wechseln
unser neu installiertes Ubuntu-System
und gucken mal, wie es da so ausschaut drinnen.
Das ist prinzipiell von
Ubuntu.
Also, wir wechseln jetzt von der Live-CD
in unser installiertes Ubuntu-System
rein.
Sieht gut aus, funktioniert, läuft alles.
So, erstmal ganz wichtig, den T-Max installieren.
Sonst kriege ich später
Anfälle.
Also, die Verbindungen zu Ubuntu-Servern sind
abgrundtief langsam gerade.
Hallo, Jarobs
Streams. Boah, es ist langsam.
Wir müssen den richtigen
Ubuntu-Server erwischen, dann
geht's schneller. Lohnt
es sich mit Vim zu beschäftigen und die
Kommando-Shortcuts zu lernen und lernt man das alles so nebenbei?
Ja, das lohnt sich. Es gibt ein paar coole Sachen.
Meine Güte, sind die
Ubuntu-Server langsam, ey.
Meine Fresse.
Was ist denn das hier wieder? Telekom-Verbindung,
ja.
Das ist
mega langsam, ey. Boah.
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall,
sich mit Vim zu beschäftigen. Vim hat ein paar richtig
coole Sachen. Der Vorteil
ist von Vim, dass man
das Ding, beziehungsweise ein BI
oder zumindest in Vim
kannst du auf jeder Linux-Distribution installieren.
Die meisten Systeme haben zumindest ein BI dabei.
Und es gibt ein paar echt
coole Sachen.
Was zeige
ich denn da jetzt am besten? Zum Beispiel,
eine Sache, die viele
Leute immer cool finden in Vim ist,
also, wenn das hier jetzt nicht
läuft,
muss ich meine Paketquellen umstellen.
Aber ich gehe jetzt erstmal was
futtern. Danach machen wir weiter.
So.
Ich zeige jetzt mal eine coole Sache in Vim.
Mal angenommen, du hast irgendeine
Config-Datei.
Irgendeine Config-Datei, also ETC,
was weiß ich,
wo gibt es denn Config-Dateien mal
mit Anführungszeichen drinnen?
Ja, Python,
3,
gibt es da irgendwas?
Debian-Config.
Boah, jetzt mal eine Datei,
wo ich das zeigen kann. Sonst muss ich
selbst eine machen.
Also.
Irgendwas
drinnen.
Ah, wunderbar.
Mal angenommen.
Ich möchte jetzt den Inhalt ändern.
Hier.
Den Pfad möchte ich ändern, hier drinnen.
Die Noob-Variante
ist jetzt, wo man sieht, dass Vim-Shortcuts
wirklich praktisch sein können.
Die Noob-Variante ist jetzt folgendermaßen.
Pfeiltasten bis
dahin.
Insert-Mode.
Löschen.
Neuer Pfad.
Und Escape. Das ist die Noob-Variante.
Was ein bisschen besser ist,
ist,
man geht schon mal mit
F-Anführungszeichen an die Stelle.
F ist quasi F
gefolgt von dem Zeichen, was man
sucht, springt zum ersten Zeichen
dieser Art in dieser Zeile.
Und dann macht man eben so.
Ist aber auch noch nicht schön.
Aber schon besser.
Was richtig cool ist, ich gehe einfach
in die Zeile und sage
C-I
Quote. Bam.
Neuer Pfad.
Das sind coole Vim-Shortcuts
zum Beispiel. Also sprich
C-I und dann, was man ändern will.
Change Inner. Also C-I
kann man sich merken für Change Inner.
Change Inner Single Quotes.
Neuer Pfad.
Das ist eigentlich die schöne Variante. Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Wenn ich das
jetzt in der Zeile auch machen will, gehe ich einfach
in die Zeile und drücke Punkt. Punkt wieder
und erholt nämlich das letzte Kommando, was ich in Vim
ausgeführt habe.
So, dann gibt es noch mehr coole Sachen.
Ich möchte Defaults überall
ersetzen. Sternchen drücken
und schon
kann ich mit N
zu jeder Stelle springen,
wo Defaults
steht.
Highlight funktioniert hier jetzt an der Stelle nicht. Würde er normalerweise
machen. Das liegt wahrscheinlich an meiner Config.
Und die könnte ich dann auch
wieder sagen. Könnte ich dann hier sagen
ich das hier zu dem.
Dann sage ich Endpunkt, Endpunkt, Endpunkt
und habe alles geändert. Also schon cool,
was man da machen kann.
Also Vim Shortcuts
lernen lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, er hat im Hintergrund T-Max installiert.
Wunderbar. Okay Jungs,
wir machen gleich weiter.
Gibt es da Bücher oder so, um das zu lernen?
Es gibt
Vim Bücher, ja, aber
am besten ist einfach
ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Kannst dir, kannst Vim
subreddit, kannst du lesen.
Es gibt ein paar richtig coole Vim
Tutorials. So, also
aktueller Stand ist,
wir haben unser Ubuntu installiert.
Wir sind in unser
neu installiertes Ubuntu reingewechselt.
Und es sieht
auf den ersten Blick erstmal ganz gut aus.
Ich gehe jetzt Mittagessen und danach
machen wir weiter mit
Booten von
diesem Ubuntu.
Gucken wir uns gleich dann mal nach dem Mittagessen an.
Ich mache nochmal einen Snapshot.
Snapshot 4.
Jetzt haben wir hier mal Pause.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt vielleicht,
nachdem ich Resume gemacht habe,
funktioniert wieder.
Mit VMware.
Ganz schön sneaky.
Vim hat mich komplett überfordert. Ich brauche mein UI.
Naja, also
Vim hat ja ein UI.
Das mag nicht.
Naja gut.
Lässt du deinen Stream an?
Keine Ahnung. Soll ich meinen Stream an?
Kann ich machen.
Dann spare ich jetzt ein Overlay.
Mach ich jetzt Askiquarium an.
Und mach
ein Overlay, dass ich Mittagessen bin.
Ups. Äh.
Gibt es das überhaupt mittlerweile?
Was?
Gibt es kein Askiquarium?
Das ist aber... Was?
Es gibt... Unter Ubuntu gibt es kein Askiqua...
Das ist Fail. Distribution ist jetzt unten
durchgefallen.
Gibt es das nicht unter Ubuntu?
WTF.
Das gibt es nicht.
Ach ne.
Ha. Doch.
Ernsthaft? Es gibt kein Askiquarium
mehr unter Ubuntu standardmäßig?
Ne.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Ich bin echt
enttäuscht jetzt.
Jawoll.
Es gibt ein Repo mit Askiquarium.
Alles gut. Alles gut.
Die Ubuntu Server sind massiv langsam.
Okay.
Also die Verbindung zu den Ubuntu
Servern ist wirklich grausam schlecht gerade.
Okay. Dann mach ich hier Overlay an.
Zack.
Text.
Mittagessen.
Ups.
Äh.
Outline.
Black.
Dass man da was sieht.
Schriftgröße.
So.
Alles klar.
Soll ich die Musik bisschen lauter machen?
Das ist hier
Playlist. Irgendwie sowas.
Chill. Chill Playlist.
Den Kopf bisschen langsamer
drehen lassen. Oh. Ich weiß dann ob man da Einfluss drauf hat.
Habe ich keinen Einfluss
drauf. Wie schnell der Kopf
dreht. Oh hier Filter.
Filter. Kann man. Gif. Gif Filter.
Render Delay.
Ne. Geht nicht.
Ich kann es ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Okay Leute. Dann bin ich schon mal kurz
füttern.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Deshalb geht es schon.
Ach ich bin es jetzt zu hoch.
So.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Das Zeug hier ausblende.
So.
Wunderbar.
Ja.
Wo ich die Lautstärke jetzt richtig gemacht habe.
Vom Hintergrund gedudelt.
So.
Ungefähr.
so gut minimieren wir das zeug opundo hat sich immer noch nicht dazu überreden
lassen mal wieder mal wieder full screen zu machen
mal noch mal das ist mittlerweile funktioniert das ging ja flott ja wenn
wenn ich am futter bin das wird das wird reingeschaufelt und dann ist gut
opunto was ist das was das für komische taktik erinnert mich an irgendwelche
tablets wurde zeugs rumschieben muss das brauche ich am desktop aber jetzt
wirklich kann ich ja nicht so was sagen wie auto das war ich muss jetzt mal die
auflösung richtig einstellen das geht mir nicht auf den keks ich muss jetzt
mal die auflösung haus ist der kasten resolution das ist ja das ist wieder so
typisch linux gefrickelt was viel komplizierter ist als es sein muss ich
gehe das ja so not found ja ich weiß das muss das mal sein dass die schwarzen
balken geben wir echt auf den keks hier nur
neumarkt
oh man warum ist das so kompliziert at mod ach so ja was hat man ja ich habe
ich habe die open vm tools drauf captain siegel aber die normalen vor
immer tool also die open vm tools installiert die haben auch funktioniert
aber irgendwann haben sie sich gedacht jetzt hab ich kein bock mehr hat
bisher sag mal das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein
moore
custom resolution easy es kann also schwierig sein wenn das jetzt warum ist
das so kompliziert was was zum teufel ist kann nicht sein dass ich einfach
sagen kann hey ich stelle mal hier display ein reinstaller open vm tools
weiß nicht ob man kann ich mal machen ja aber ich glaube nicht dass das richtig
schreibt
ich glaube nicht dass das hallo ich habe immer noch ich glaube ich aber dass das
was damit zu tun hat aber vielleicht bringt ja was und du sagst mega langsam
ganz vergessen egal das wird jetzt verkleidet aber trotzdem man kann auch
hier ja wirklich die beste bestes also was muss man jetzt hier machen dafür
deswegen braucht man die max
jetzt macht sich schon ein bisschen weniger
1810 moore
eben
das kann ich mir selber noch mal anzeigen
1000 2110 80 neumode 1000 was 1000
und dann schreibt man diesen kak da hinten dran oder wie gut nein so
funktioniert schon mal nicht ich hab da schon wieder kein bock auf das gefrickel
das gibt mir los echt auf den sack warum kann ich einfach einstellen hier stellt
rum zu vorstellen.
Achso.
Falsch geschrieben.
Das ist mir zu kompliziert.
Da habe ich jetzt kein F drauf.
Okay.
Wir machen das mal.
Ah, copy, paste.
Easy.
Geht schon nicht mal.
Kannst du nicht mal reinpasten hier.
Bad name.
Was auch immer.
Geht einfach nicht.
Nice.
Darf man nicht.
So, und reinstall vor allem
weil Tools funktionieren auch nicht,
weil die Ubuntu-Server hängen.
Meine Güte.
Wie kann man hier die Mirrors ändern?
Die machen es einem aber echt kompliziert.
Die machen es einem echt kompliziert.
Dann,
den lad halt von da runter.
Ist auch okay.
Was?
Geht es jetzt schneller?
Nicht wirklich.
Die Ubuntu-Server sind
wahnsinnig schnell gerade.
Aber machen wir mal weiter.
Ja, komm.
Dann kamen wir zu.
So.
Wo ist das immer stehengeblieben
mit der ganzen Geschichte.
Wir sind jetzt reingewechselt
in unser
in unser neues interledes Ubuntu
und sind jetzt an der Stelle hier gewesen.
Jetzt muss man noch ein bisschen
Zeugs generieren für die Installation
dass es dann auch gleich alles funktioniert.
Ja, auf Englisch ist gut.
Machen wir.
Time Zone
können wir auch neu konfigurieren.
Alles gut.
Wir sind in Europe.
Wir sind in Berlin.
Das ist auch gut.
Das ist auch gut, machen wir auch.
Insofern ist die Anleitung ja noch relativ einfach.
Oh ne, jetzt müssen wir ein Update machen.
Hey, das geht schneller.
Sehr schön.
Haben wir einen anderen Server erwischt, der da schneller ist.
Ah ne, der hat umgestellt.
Sehr schön, jetzt geht es auch wieder.
Ne.
Immer wenn er den falschen Server erwischt, ist es lahm.
Okay, Update.
Wim install, habe das schon gerade installt.
Wim und T-Max, das brauche ich auf jeden Fall.
Oh, wie es mich nervt.
Das ist so langsam.
Ich will das nicht über das GUI machen.
Ja, weil ich muss jetzt gleich Zeug installieren.
Das heißt, ich brauche einen halbwegs schnellen Mirror.
Hallo Florian262000.
Wir müssen uns mal irgendwelche anderen Mirrors raussuchen.
Warum?
Weißt du, wisst ihr, unter Archlinos bzw. Manjaro gibt es einfach ein Kommando.
Das führe ich auf, äh, führe ich aus.
Sucht mir den schnellsten, sucht mir den schnellsten Mirror raus.
Mirror raus und gut ist.
Hier soll ich das hier von Hand machen.
Oder was?
Ubuntu, check fastest mirror.
Hier muss es doch ein fertiges Skript für geben.
Aha.
Upget now supports a mirror method.
Ah, das ist schön.
Also, up, up, mirror oder was?
Up, was, up, get, mirror.
Hä?
Ne, Moment, das soll ich da...
Das ist doch absolut, das ist doch total hängen geblieben, äh.
Wer kann es echt den Leuten kompliziert machen?
Warum?
Warum ist da kein...
Warum ist da kein Programm dabei, mit dem ich einfach meine Mirrors updaten kann?
So, was haben wir...
Oh, es ist doch mehr Mirrors-Game.
Ist das...
Ich habe...
Aha.
Ja, das ist gut.
Was, was habe ich denn überhaupt für ein Mirror?
Etc.
Okay, das CD-ROM-Laufwerk machen wir mal weg.
Das ist lahm, das ist lahm hier.
Das ist richtig langsam.
Gibt es, gibt es sowas wie...
Gibt es sowas, probieren wir mal aus, dass man sowas macht hier wie...
DE?
D, E?
Gibt es sowas?
Ah.
Okay, Security Ubuntu ist noch langsam.
Äh, gibt es, gibt es sowas hier wie...
D?
Aha.
Okay.
Jetzt geht es schneller.
Okay, was machen wir...
Hey, wir haben wieder Vollbild.
Das war eine super Idee mit dem Reinstall von MWR Tools.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das sowas bringt.
Sehr schön.
Wir haben wieder Vollbild.
Krass.
So, wir können weitermachen.
Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt...
Auch hier noch mal rein und schreiben da einfach überall DE davor.
So, hier.
Da.
DE.
Noch mehr DE.
Und dann ist es gut.
So.
Noch mal Update.
Ja, wir können weitermachen.
Perfekt.
Äh, hast du irgendwas Richtung Informatik studiert?
Nein, ich habe nicht studiert.
Ich habe eine Ausbildung mal gemacht.
Vor einigen Jahren.
Das ist wirklich schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ähm, als Fachinformatiker Systemindikation.
Achso.
Nee, okay, das Security-Mirror darf man nicht DE davor schreiben.
Okay, weiter im Text.
Ähm, wir sind stehen geblieben bei...
Install, Update.
Okay, das heißt, jetzt müssen...
Okay, jetzt muss ich die ZFS-Pakete, die Debian-Pakete, die ich, ähm...
Gibt es eigentlich Ubuntu-Security-DE-Mirror, gibt es sowas?
Dresden.
Dresden ist immer gut als Mirror.
Und wie ist die Mirror?
Wie ist die Adresse von dem Ding?
Was gibt es denn da für Mirror?
Das Offizielle ist ja gerade am Abscheißen.
.co.cn klingt vertrauenswürdig.
Archive, okay.
Wir brauchen jetzt aber die Security-Updates gar nicht.
Deswegen tun wir mal so, als gäbe es den.
Dann kackt er halt ab beim Laden, aber ist ja egal.
So, ähm, jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Pakete rüberkopieren.
Unsere, unsere Custom-Debian-Pakete.
Wir haben das ja gebaut hier unter, ähm...
CD, Build, SPL und, äh, ZFS.
Das heißt, das müssen wir jetzt in unser frisch installiertes Ubuntu erstmal rüberkopieren.
Also haben wir hier sowas wie dep nach mnt tmp.
Also, unter mount ist ja, unter mnt ist ja unser frisch installiertes Ubuntu drunter.
So, kopieren wir den ganzen Scheiß da rein.
Und wir werden sehen, wenn ich jetzt hier drinnen in unserem neuen installierten Ubuntu gucke, ist alles da.
Und die Pakete installieren wir jetzt.
Wobei, vorher, vorher installieren wir den Krempel hier.
Current Images.
So, ich muss aufpassen, dass ich keine, keine Zwischenschritte vergesse,
weil sonst bootet das ganze Kleinhet.
Und das wär do.
Wir haben auch noch kein Crap und Bootmanager und sonst was installiert.
Was wir alles noch machen.
Lass uns erstmal Kernel installieren.
Genau, guck hier.
Standardmäßig liegt nämlich das Zeug immer unter slash boot.
So, und slash boot ist ja eine eigene Partition auf unserer Platte.
Ist ZFS dein beliebtes, äh, liebtes Dateisystem?
Kommt drauf an für was, also, ähm...
Für, äh, für Server, auf denen man, also mit denen man relativ viel macht.
Die quasi einzelne Systeme, die relativ viele Sachen anbieten.
Ist ZFS wunderbar.
Ist ZFS gut, richtig gut.
Äh, es hat vorhin auch jemand gefragt, wie ich's finde für ZF, äh, wie ich ZFS finde für KVM und, äh, LXC und, und sowas.
Container, Containerhost.
Dafür ist das wie, wie geschaffen quasi dafür.
Für ein einzelnes Desktop-System.
Hau X4 drauf und gut ist.
Aber, so ein ZFS ist auch auf dem Desktop-System.
Sehr nützlich.
Sei es nur durch die ganze Snapshot-Funktion.
Und dass es einfach guckt, dass, äh, Daten nicht kaputt gehen und sich gewissen Grenzen auch reparieren kann.
Dass man halt auch Volume-Manager, Encryption und Software-Rate und sowas alles in einem hat.
Also es macht auch Sinn für Desktop, ja.
Es braucht halt ordentlich RAM, dass es gut funktioniert.
Das ist wichtig.
ZFS braucht RAM ohne Ende, dass es...
Oh, das hätte gerne RAM ohne Ende.
Es funktioniert auch mit ein bisschen weniger.
So, ähm...
Jetzt hab ich den, den, den Kernel installiert.
Jetzt muss ich in unserem neu installierten Ubuntu noch dafür sorgen, dass er auch unsere Kernel-Module nämlich lädt.
Weil der würde wieder das alte laden.
Deswegen, das haben wir vorhin ja schon gemacht.
Haben wir vorhin schon rausgekriegt, musste man ja hier einfach extra reinschreiben.
Aber bevor ich das mache, muss ich die Pakete noch installieren.
So, und die liegen hier.
Das sind die...
Deswegen habe ich vorher Debian-Pakete gebaut und nicht einfach nur ZFS-Kompilierten installiert.
Weil...
Ich will es ja in meinem neuen Ubuntu auch installieren können.
Ähm...
Deswegen installieren wir jetzt hier einfach mal die Pakete.
Machen wir hier so eine ganz...
Das Ganze...
Upt...
Install...
Hier einfach...
Einfach alles mit Debian-Paket drin.
Bam!
Wird jetzt installiert.
Ein paar Sachen konnte er nicht installieren.
Weil...
Äh...
DKMS...
Ja, das ist kein Wunder, dass er es nicht installieren kann.
Das ist okay.
Da kann ich mit leben, dass die zwei...
Dass die...
Äh...
DKMS-Pakete...
Nicht funktionieren.
Stand ja sogar im Tutorial drin, dass das nicht klappen wird.
Okay.
Äh...
Und jetzt machen wir depmod...
A-V.
Und stellen fest, er hat den Kram geladen.
In der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Sehr schön.
ZFS-List.
Okay, funktioniert.
Okay, er wird...
Er lädt...
Er hat auch den richtigen geladen.
Alles gut.
Hat funktioniert.
So.
Ähm...
Habe ich...
Habe ich installiert.
Wunderbar.
Passt.
Ähm...
Das muss ich machen.
Das heißt, ich muss in meine EFAS-Tab, also sprich dort, wo die...
Ähm...
Ja...
Was ist eine EFAS-Tab?
Ähm...
Da, wo drinsteht, was beim Booten gemountet wird im Endeffekt.
Oder dort, wo welche Laufwerke gemountet sind, muss ich eintragen, dass mein...
Nicht für Lux.
Wie gesagt, wir verwenden kein Lux.
Wir verwenden ZFS-Native-Encryption.
Aber wir müssen ja dafür sorgen, dass Slashboot oder zumindest sollte Slashboot ordentlich
gemountet werden.
Also sprich hier, devsda2 ist unsere Boot-Partition und das Ganze soll in die EFAS-Tab rein.
Warum eigentlich Ubuntu und nicht Debian, weil ich Ubuntu mag?
Allerdings nicht auf dem Desktop.
Nein, das brauchen wir nicht.
WTF?
Crypt-Setup brauchen wir nicht.
Ich meine, kein Lux.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht.
Ähm...
So.
Jetzt...
Jetzt wird's spannend.
Crap installieren.
Kann man eigentlich hier über diese Leiste oben Snapshots machen?
Ja.
Wie geht das?
Ha.
Und Snapshot zwischendurch.
Kann nämlich nie schaden.
Snapshot.
So.
Install Crap.
Jetzt wird's spannend.
Für Legacy MBR BIOS-Booting.
Nope.
Das wollen wir nicht machen.
Wir wollen UEFI-Boot.
Also installieren wir DOS-Tools.
Jawoll.
Dann müssen wir unsere UEFI-Partition noch formatieren.
Das ist bei uns devsda3.
Übrigens, es wird an jeder Stelle empfohlen...
Ob Crap so ausgesprochen wird?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich würde mal sagen, dass das Crap ausgesprochen wird.
Ähm...
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Grub ausgesprochen wird.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Äh...
Ja, es wird überall empfohlen, dass man ZFS eben nicht hier direkt auf das Device...
Ähm...
Also nicht direkt auf das Device gibt.
Sondern unter devdisk ist es glaube ich bei ID oder bei UID.
Einfach weil es immer eindeutig ist pro Platte.
Und diese Sachen hier wie devsda theoretisch wechseln können.
Aber ich bin in der VM.
Da geht das nicht so ohne weiteres.
So.
UEFI-Partition anlegen.
Die muss auch gemountet werden.
Beim Start.
Oder es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, wenn die gemountet wird beim Start.
Das kann ich auch einfach so hinschreiben.
Das ist jetzt devsda3.
Das haben wir ja heute ganz am Anfang schon angelegt.
Boot Dings nach FSTAP.
So.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal in unsere FSTAP reingucken.
Stehen die beiden Systeme drin.
Das heißt Boot wird gemountet.
Und das UEFI-Partition wird gemountet.
Mounten wir die UEFI-Partition nochmal von Hand.
Und jetzt installieren wir Grub.
Gut.
Ähm...
Bla.
Okay, anscheinend braucht das Ubuntu, dass es funktioniert.
Dann machen wir das.
Danach setzen wir ein Root-Passwort.
123456.
Ganz furchtbar spannendes Passwort.
So.
Und jetzt...
Das brauchen wir...
Brauchen wir nicht.
Haben wir nämlich gar nicht angelegt.
Diese Datasets.
So.
Und jetzt sollen wir sagen.
Grub.
Probe.
Slash.
Okay.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Hier steht zwar Verify.
Also wir sollen sicherstellen, dass das hier auch wirklich als Ausgabe kommt.
Aber.
Bei uns ist es okay, dass Anon-File-System kommt.
Weil.
Wir haben ja da nicht einfach ein ZFS drauf.
Sondern.
Wir haben ein verschlüsseltes ZFS drauf.
Das heißt.
Das verstehe ich noch.
Dass das jetzt nicht funktioniert.
So.
Ich mache nochmal einen Snapshot.
Weil jetzt kommen ein paar kritische Schritte.
Wo wir aufpassen müssen.
So.
Und zwar.
Das können wir jetzt schonmal machen.
Das müssen wir aber wahrscheinlich gleich nochmal editieren.
Und ich muss vor allem erst gleich mal aufs Klo.
Gut.
Jetzt gucken wir in unsere Grub-Config rein.
Und dort werfen wir.
Na das war es schon.
So.
Das steht nämlich in der Anleitung nicht drinnen.
Aber das war essentiell bei meinem Ubuntu-Server, den ich letztens installiert habe, auf ZFS-Root.
Sonst hat es nicht funktioniert.
So, und Timeout machen wir weg, weil Timeout wollen wir nicht.
Und der Rest ist eigentlich so okay.
Okay, so.
Update Group.
Rup.
De.
Arte.
Rup.
Äh, hast du die Kaufversion von VMware Workstation?
Die kostenlose Version heißt ja, glaube ich, VMware Workstation Player.
Ja, ich habe es gekauft.
Eine der Sachen, die ich wirklich gekauft habe.
Äh, was auch immer.
Adding Boot Entry.
Install Bootloader.
Ja, machen wir.
Und danach können wir wahrscheinlich booten.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Aber wir können gucken, ob wir das von Hand unlock kriegen dann.
Äh, äh, äh.
Äh, Crop Install auf SDA.
Genau.
Auf keine Partition, sondern direkt auf SDA.
Oh, fuck.
Ne.
Jetzt habe ich, habe ich jetzt Mist gemacht?
Ja, ich habe jetzt Mist gemacht.
Ah.
Ich hätte das machen müssen.
Falsche ausgeführt.
Naja.
Bügeln wir es mal drüber und hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Fuck.
Kann ich, kann ich das jetzt wieder removen?
Haha.
Hoffentlich funktioniert das jetzt.
Aber gut, ich habe ja einen Snapshot.
Das heißt, ich kann auch wieder einfach zurück.
Verify das CNS, äh, dass das ZFS-Module so geladen sind.
Jawohl, ist geladen.
First Boot.
Snapshot machen wir.
So, wenn jetzt irgendwas nicht klappt, dann können wir auf den Snapshot zurück.
Und ich habe auch hier Vmware-Snapshots und alles.
Hallo, Jokosch.
So, jetzt können wir rebooten und gucken, wie weit wir kommen.
Jetzt bin ich aber echt gespannt.
Ähm, Exit.
Und dann sollen wir anmounten.
Anmounten.
Machen wir alles.
So, und wenn wir es jetzt irgendwie schaffen, das System zu booten von ZFS,
danach bauen wir ein, dass wir es, ähm, dass wir es relativ einfach beim Booten anlocken können über SSH.
Ähm, Falcon, ja, das ist normal.
Das kann man in quasi jedem Linux-System machen, solange du, ähm,
solange du den Crop, dein Crop nicht passwortgeschützt hast.
Es muss kein Ubuntu sein, und es ist auch egal, ob ein Root-Passwort gesetzt ist oder nicht.
Du kannst den nämlich im Crop einfach, ähm, eintragen, dass du eine Bash starten, dass er eine Bash starten soll, quasi, anstatt von Init.
Und dann hast du Zugriff auf jedes Linux-System, solange die Festplatte nicht verschlüsselt ist.
Deswegen Festplatte verschlüsseln.
Was hältst du vom neuen Tesla Roadster?
Bei Autos kannst du mich ja alles fragen, aber ich kann dir nichts zu sagen.
Okay, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
So, unmount den ganzen Krempe.
Äh, Z-Pool, Export, R-Pool, jawoll.
So, und jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit, Reboot.
Okay, Reboot hängt, wahrscheinlich wegen dem CD-Laufwerk oder so.
Deswegen lassen wir den jetzt, sagen wir ihm jetzt einfach mal hier, komm, scheiß drauf, Power, restart Guest.
Bam, und mal gucken, wie weit wir kommen.
Okay, also, äh, äh, Crop startet schon mal.
Gucken wir uns mal die Boot-Optionen an.
Gitter ist von ZFS drin.
Boot gleich ZFS.
Root gleich ZFS, Root Ubuntu?
Das stimmt nicht, das müsste R-Pool, Root Ubuntu sein, aber gucken wir mal, wie weit wir kommen.
Ich seh nix.
Ah, hier.
Haha, haha, haha, okay.
Okay, hey, das ist, das ist besser als ich gedacht habe.
Das ist besser als, also der ist jetzt nicht gebootet.
Also, falls das, jemand denkt, dass das jetzt normale Scherz, der ist, der ist beim Booten abgekackt.
Allerdings, genau an der Stelle, wo ich erwartet habe.
Also, der ist jetzt nicht gebootet.
Nämlich beim Versuch, das ZFS zu starten, beziehungsweise den, den ZFS-Pool, ähm, zu starten, zu importieren.
Was er ja nicht kann, weil der ist ja verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, solange die ihre Start-Skripte nicht anpassen, dass es mich nach einem Passwort fragt, geht das nicht.
Deswegen muss ich das jetzt von Hand machen.
Also, haben wir hier Z, mit welcher Tastatur ist das ja?
Englisch.
Zpool, kann man hier, blö.
Kann man hier sowas machen, die Load, Loadkey?
Keyes.de?
Nein, das ist natürlich nicht drin.
Also, Zpool, äh, Import, minus R auf Root.
So, und jetzt wollen wir nicht minus N haben, sondern, das habe ich nämlich in einem anderen Tutorial gesehen, wir wollen minus L.
Minus L fragt beim Laden von ZFS nach dem Passwort von einem verschlüsselten Pool.
Und dann muss man den Namen noch angeben, das Ding heißt R-Pool.
Er hat ihn gefunden, er fragt uns nach dem Passwort.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
Bam.
ZFS-List ist geladen.
So, und wenn ich jetzt Exit tippe, ist die Frage, ob er fertig bootet oder nicht.
Wenn es jetzt nicht geht, haben wir ein Problem.
Wenn das funktioniert, ist es echt geil.
Dann ist das hier quasi die erste, in Anführungsstrichen, Anleitung, die ich im Internet gefunden habe.
Wie man, also, ne, das, dieser Stream hier dann.
Das erste, wo man, wo das mal irgendjemand quasi nachvollziehbar ausprobiert hat, booten von Encrypted ZFS.
Oh, fuck, funktioniert nicht.
He, he, scheiße.
Ah, ja natürlich.
No such file, root Ubuntu.
Das gibt's ja auch nicht, das ist ja auch falsch.
Das ist ja auch falsch, das geht ja auch nicht.
Funktioniert ja auch nicht.
Das ist, das ist ja auch verkehrt.
Was, was, was, was, was da, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der.
Ubuntu-Installer eingetragen hat.
Das ist ja auch nicht Root-Ubuntu,
sondern das ist AirPool
Root-Ubuntu.
So, machen wir den ganzen Scheiß nochmal.
Also, ich bin momentan
im ersten Semester Informatik und verstehe
nur Bahnhof. Das hat nichts damit zu tun,
ob man Informatik studiert oder nicht.
Das sind einfach
gewisse Linux-Kenntnisse
müssen dafür
vorhanden sein,
beziehungsweise auch sich dafür interessieren.
Einfach nur, weil man Informatik studiert.
Das ist genauso, wie man Kunst
studiert, kann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht
direkt super malen oder so.
Permission denied.
AirPool cannot mount. Permission denied.
Fail to mount.
Jaja, das ist schon klar.
Okay.
Zpool
import
minus R
nach Root
L
AirPool
heißt der Krempe.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt falsch rum gemacht?
Irgendwo verschrieben?
Ups, oh, ich hasse
englische Tastatur.
Moment. Ach, ist der schon importiert
oder was?
Ah, der ist schon importiert.
Zpool export
AirPool
schmeißen wir den mal wieder raus.
7, 8
importiert.
Ah, ich weiß, was ich vergessen habe.
Ja, es bringt ja nichts, wenn ich meinen
Es bringt ja gar nichts, wenn ich den Pool
importiere. Ich muss ja auch noch
Ich muss ja auch noch meinen, meinen, meinen, meinen
Root mounten. Was er ja nicht automatisch
macht, weil das ein verschlüsselter Pool ist.
Okay.
Wisst ihr was? Ich reboote
nochmal.
Wenn wir das jetzt von Hand gefixt kriegen, also
quasi, wo wir uns hier gerade befinden,
ist
der Zwischenschritt zwischen
Bootmanager und quasi
gestartetem oder oder
Linux-System, was anfängt zu starten.
Wir befinden uns quasi in so einem
in so einem Mini-Linux,
ähm, wo er normalerweise
einfach versucht, die
Filesysteme, also die Laufwerke zu
mounten, um dann das richtige Linux komplett
zu starten. Und
er sagt, er kann halt nicht weiter booten,
weil er sein Root-Laufwerk nicht findet.
So, machen wir mal weiter. Ich habe
ja auch vergessen, das Root-Laufwerk zu mounten eben.
Das kann ja auch nicht funktionieren.
Empfehlt ihr eigentlich nach Java noch C++
zu lernen? Ähm,
es schadet auf jeden Fall
nix, wobei ich ganz ehrlich kein Java-Fan
bin. Das wissen wahrscheinlich
aber mittlerweile schon alle.
So, zpool import
minus r
root minus
l. Und jetzt rpool,
hab ich vergessen. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8 ist gemountet. Und jetzt,
das, was ich vorhin vergessen hab, zfs
mount. Und zwar will ich
mounten rpool root
ubuntu nach
root. So, äh,
ach nee.
Ah, fuck. Das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Doch, kann funktionieren.
Da ist mein System. Komm jetzt.
Jawoll, in your face!
Funktioniert!
Krass.
Das ist ja geil.
Das ist ja nice.
So, Root-Passwort haben wir gesetzt.
So, loadkeys.de
auf jeden Fall, sonst können wir nix schreiben.
So,
wir haben von unserem
verschlüsselten ZFS gemountet.
Von unserem selbstkompilierten,
ja, gegen ZFS Master.
Selbstkompilierten,
verschlüsselten ZFS-Laufwerk
haben wir gebootet.
Das ist echt schon geil.
Und das ist ein absolutes
Minimalsystem jetzt. Wirklich. Absolut
minimal. Mehr minimal kannst du nicht sein.
Also,
nicht mit Ubuntu nicht minimaler.
Wir haben jetzt,
ähm,
quasi, wir haben, ähm,
700 MB ungefähr belegt.
Das kommt ungefähr hin, was halt so ein normales Ubuntu nach der Installation hat.
Ja, das ist geil.
So, dann, dann machen wir jetzt nochmal zwei Sachen.
Und zwar,
also, wir probieren jetzt erstmal, ob wir das nachvollziehbar rebooted bekommen.
Also, man muss quasi
beim Reboot
den Pool von Hand importieren,
Root-Filesystem von Hand mounten
und halt dazwischen, ähm, das Passwort einladen.
Und dann kann man dann auch noch ein paar Sachen eingeben und danach aus der, aus der Shell rausgehen und es bootet.
Also, das ist im Prinzip eigentlich so, wie das bei allen anderen Systemen auch funktioniert, aber
mit dem Unterschied, dass eben die Boots, die Skripte beim Booten für ZFS noch nicht angepasst sind, dass sie eben das von Haus aus machen.
Deswegen müssen wir es jetzt von Hand machen.
Aber das ist okay.
Also, probieren wir mal, ob, ob, ob das nachvollziehbar ist.
Also, sprich, ob das jetzt nochmal funktioniert.
So, also,
also, im Endeffekt gehen wir jetzt hier rein, editieren.
Ups, ne, editieren brauchen wir nicht.
Wir lassen ihn ganz normal booten.
Dann machen wir einen Import vom Z-Pool
und
Passphrase eingeben und mounten.
Und gut ist.
Okay, probieren wir das nochmal.
Also, Z-Pool, Import auf Root.
So, ähm, das Ding heißt Airpool
und ich will Keys laden.
7, 8.
So, ZFS mount.
Airpool.
Root.
Ubuntu.
Exit.
Bam.
Easy.
Das ist ja viel einfacher, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Das ist total simpel.
Jetzt müsste man eigentlich nur noch ein ordentliches Skript basteln.
So ein paar Zeilen, was das halt quasi, was dich im Booten nach, nach der Passphrase fragt,
dass du das nicht jedes Mal von Hand machen musst.
Aber, ähm, was wir jetzt noch machen ist, wir bauen jetzt noch, ähm, nen, nen SSH Server
quasi, äh, in den Boot.
Äh, in den Boot-Prozess ein, dass wir das System quasi unlocken können,
ohne dass wir lokal ne Tastatur dran brauchen.
Weil das ist immer nervig.
Das wollte ich schon immer ausprobieren, wie das funktioniert.
Da müssen wir jetzt hier mal gucken.
Ähm, Unlock System SSH Encryption.
Da gab's nämlich so nen Mini-SSH-Server, den man einbauen konnte.
Genau, die ist hier, Top-Bier.
So nen Mini-SSH-Server, den man einbauen konnte.
Okay.
Also gut, Passwort.
Kriegen wir denn überhaupt schon ne IP?
Ja, äh, ne.
Warum kriegen wir keine IP?
Was ist hier los?
Warum krieg ich keine IP?
Was soll das?
Krieg ich jetzt ne IP?
Jetzt krieg ich ne IP.
Loadkeys.de
Hab ich mich hier irgendwie verschrieben?
Ach ja.
Ich hab mich vertippt.
Ich weiß nicht, heißt es ja auch, mein Netzwerk.
Okay.
Jetzt versuchen wir den Grafis da irgendwie noch einzubauen.
Wie funktioniert denn das jetzt?
Äh, Install Top-Bier.
Also erstmal installieren wir Open SSH Server.
Dass man jetzt mal mit ner ordentlichen Shell hier rein kann.
Ordentliche Shell für Windows noch installieren.
Download.
Weil ich mein, wir können jetzt hier drin nicht viel machen.
Wir haben jetzt hier das hässliche Windows-Konsolen-Fenster,
was halt, ne, 640x480.
Ne, 800x600 und ohne irgendwas.
Na, das ist Mist.
Wir loggen uns jetzt mal per SSH ein.
Dazu brauchen wir erstmal ne ordentliche Windows-Shell.
Hallo?
Download?
Ach hier.
Hab ich Servenzip drauf.
Ich lad mal lieber das Zip runter.
Ja, aber das ist ja geil.
Also im Prinzip haben wir das Hauptziel schon mal erreicht.
Wir können booten von ZFS.
Von nem native verschlüsselten ZFS.
Kann man booten.
Das ist schon mal, das ist schon wirklich gut.
Das einzige, was jetzt halt nicht ordentlich funktioniert,
ist rebooten, ohne da was eintippen zu müssen.
Aber das ist ja egal.
Das sind drei Kommandos, die man eintippen muss.
Und richtig geil wär's jetzt halt,
und das ist jetzt das nächste, was wir probieren,
wenn ich zum Unlocken von dem System eben nicht an,
nicht lokal dran sein muss,
sondern das Remote machen kann über SSH.
Das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Zack.
So.
Boah, jetzt wird es hier erstmal wieder alle
kleinen Dateien entpacken.
Das dauert jetzt wieder ewig.
Wahnsinnige Highspeed.
5 MB.
Bei ner M.2 SSD.
Irgendjemand war doch vorher da, der gesagt hat,
er hat's auch schon mal ausprobiert mit ZFS.
Und hat's mit Passphrase nicht hingekriegt.
Hast du das so ähnlich,
falls du noch da bist,
hast du das so ähnlich gemacht wie hier?
Und bist dann an der Stelle gescheitert mit,
beim booten Mountain, oder?
Wo hat's bei dir gehakt?
Weil ich mein, im Prinzip funktioniert's mit Passphrase jetzt.
Es funktioniert viel einfacher,
als ich mir das vorgestellt hab, ja?
Achso, bei dir war's nur Home.
Na gut, das ist dann
theoretisch nochmal ne Nummer einfacher,
weil das System ja schon gestartet ist.
Kann das sein, dass mein Stream laggt,
weil ich hier Zeugs entpacke?
Wubbelwubbelwubbelwub.
Die Musik, ja.
Wir haben jetzt entpackt. Zack.
Bam. So, erstmal
Schrift ein bisschen hochstellen.
Äh, wo war das?
Settings.
Schön fett.
Und Transparenz aus.
So, okay.
Äh, jetzt können wir uns per SSH verbinden.
Auf, was hat das Ding für ne IP gekriegt?
Äh,
162.
Bam.
Aber nicht als Stream, sondern als Root.
Hack ist der
beste Font, da geb ich dir recht.
So, jetzt sind...
Äh, ah, das geht nicht, weil
Rootlogin wahrscheinlich verboten ist.
SSH
HD
Config
Permit
Permit Rootlogin.
Und zwar...
Yes.
Wir wollen uns per Root einloggen können.
Okay, jetzt sollte
es eigentlich funktionieren.
Ja.
So, jetzt sind wir in unserer VM,
allerdings mit ner bisschen schöneren Konsole.
Ähm...
So, und ich wollte jetzt den SSH so einfach in den
Boot-Vorgang einbauen. Also.
Das haben wir uns doch schon ne Anleitung rausgesucht,
wie das funktioniert.
Also,
das hab ich schon mal gelesen, also den nimmt man
dafür wahrscheinlich, wirklich.
To auto start at boot.
Okay.
At
change start, no start 1 to no start 0.
Ne, die Anleitung ist
komisch.
Das wollte man so nicht.
Oh, es gibt sogar ne deutsche Anleitung. Cool.
Ja, so kenn ich das, genau.
NETRAMFS
Config
Dann schreiben wir das hier rein.
Yes.
Netzwerkkonfiguration
Device. Das stand hier oben
schon irgendwo. Device.
Das ist, dass er sich beim Booten was zieht.
Device ist ENS33.
Äh, wir wollen uns per DHCP
was ziehen.
Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert. Klar, bin ich mal
gespannt.
Hab ich, hab ich SSH-Keys?
Ne, SSH-Key, gern.
Ja, ja.
Passt.
Ah, ne, warte, warte.
Ah!
Kack, Default-Key-Bindings.
So, kopieren wir den Key rüber,
dass ich mich beim Booten per SSH dran
verbinden kann.
Jetzt brauch ich die Anleitung dafür überhaupt nicht.
Ich hoffe bloß, dass das jetzt funktioniert.
So, Authorize-Keys.
Okay, das darf ich anscheinend.
Das ist anscheinend nicht im Pass.
Update.
Äh.
Keine Ahnung.
Uh. Ah.
So, und jetzt
rebooten wir. Und das Ziel davon
ist, dass wenn ich
reboote, dass ich mich per SSH verbinden kann.
Und wenn ich mich
per SSH während dem Booten verbinden kann,
bedeutet das automatisch, ich kann
quasi über SSH mein System
anlocken. Was natürlich richtig geil
ist. Da brauch ich keine Tastatur und ich muss
nicht an das System ran. Und ich muss
ja während dem Booten
was machen, dass ich die Festplatte anlocken kann.
So.
Rebooten
wir mal und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal hier zu, was er beim Booten
macht. Ja, Enter.
Mal gucken, ob er
jetzt den SSH-Server startet beim Booten.
Ich meine, er schmeißt
mich wieder auf die Shell, ja?
Was?
No device to configure ETH1.
Oh, ne. Habe ich mich
verschrieben? Ich glaube, ich habe
mich verschrieben. Kann das sein?
Oh, ne.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich verschrieben.
Näh.
Ja. Ich habe ETH1
reingeschrieben anstatt ENS33.
Oh, ich kacke noch. Da muss ich noch einmal von Hand machen.
Zpool.
Zpool import.
R,
Root, L, Rpool.
Minus L.
Sieben, acht.
Das ist nervig.
Deswegen will ich das unbedingt per SSH machen.
Mount,
Rpool,
Ubuntu,
Exit,
Booted. Okay.
Nochmal hier verbinden mit.
Nein, als Root, nicht als Stream.
Als Root.
So, wo habe ich denn mich hier vertippt?
Init, RAM,
FS, Tools,
RAM, FS, Conf.
Ach, hier.
Device, ENS33, IP, ETH0.
Das ist ja bescheuert. Das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren.
ENS33.
Ich muss da rein.
Okay, jetzt rebooten wir nochmal.
Und jetzt hoffe ich, dass es funktioniert.
BitLocker, lol.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist das
benutzbar geworden, BitLocker.
Aber ich würde es auch nicht verwenden.
Wie gesagt, ich habe hier auf
meinem Windows ganz normal VeraCrypt.
BitLocker
traue ich nicht über den Weg.
So, der sollte jetzt eigentlich
von alleine booten,
einen SSH-Server starten,
dass ich remote mein System unlocken kann.
Ja, er zieht sich eine IP.
Das ist, das ist,
das ist gut, das ist gut.
153.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, nice.
Na, krass.
Das funktioniert ja richtig einfach.
Also quasi, ich kann
jetzt den Server rebooten.
Der startet während dem Booten
einen SSH-Server. Darüber kann ich mich
einloggen, kann meine Festplatte
entschlüsseln und kann ihn weiterbooten
lassen. Ne, ich kann ihn nicht weiterbooten lassen,
weil er, weil er ja
noch in der Shell hängt. Wobei, ich kann die Shell
einfach abschießen. Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was uns da noch einfällt.
Also, jetzt kann ich das hier nämlich remote
über SSH machen.
Zpool import
minus R of root
ähm,
Rpool minus L
Zpool nicht gefunden. Ah, okay,
dann ist der Pass nicht richtig gesetzt.
S bin Zpool, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Äh, S bin ZFS
mount, und zwar
wollen wir mounten, Rpool
root Ubuntu.
Fertig.
Und jetzt müsste ich den doch irgendwie überreden,
dass er weiterbootet.
Also, kann ich,
kann ich nicht einfach
äh,
ne, nicht bash, shell.
Kann ich nicht einfach die Shell abschießen?
Ha! Ha, ha, ha.
Probier, das, das könnte man,
das könnte man mal ausprobieren.
Ob ich nicht einfach die Shell abschießen kann.
Und ob es dann
weiterbootet.
Ob ich,
ob ich selbst mal einen Kram abschieße.
Er bootet! Er bootet!
Ha! Nice! Funktioniert!
Ja gut, das hängt natürlich beim SSH,
das ist logisch. Das ist nice!
Also,
schon alles geklappt.
Jetzt nochmal zur Erklärung, wie, wie, wie,
das ist ja, das ist ja mega nice.
Wir haben jetzt ZFS selbst
kompiliert.
Wir haben unsere Festplatte mit ZFS
verschlüsselt, haben Ubuntu
so eingerichtet,
dass es von
unserem verschlüsselten ZFS
Pool bootet.
Dann kackt es natürlich während dem
Booten ab, weil
das einfach noch nicht,
weil es das einfach
noch nicht kann von Haus aus,
einen verschlüsselten ZFS Pool
zu mounten, während die Booten und den User
nach einem Passwort fragen.
Daraufhin haben wir uns einen SSH Server installiert,
der während dem Booten angeht,
wo ich mich remote verbinden kann
auf meinen Server per SSH,
ich kann meinen Z-Pool importieren
und quasi weiter booten lassen.
Das ist alles, was man braucht.
Das funktioniert.
Funktioniert alles.
Und nach dem Booten kann ich mich ganz normal
per SSH auf mein System
verbinden und gut ist.
Das ist doch sehr nice, oder?
Echt nice.
Finde ich jetzt.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Was bringt ZFS? ZFS
ist ein, jetzt noch ein Skript schreien,
aber welches Skript?
Wir könnten ein Skript basteln,
was quasi,
dass man quasi diese drei Befehle
beim Booten nicht mal ausführen muss,
sondern quasi nur noch ein Skript
ausführen muss beim Booten, was einen fragt.
Dieses Skript müssten wir dann aber in
initramfs einbauen, dass es verfügbar ist.
Das können wir
noch machen, wenn ihr wollt.
Was die Vorteile von ZFS sind?
Also mal ganz grob gesagt,
ZFS ist ein Dateisystem, was aber noch
mehr kann, als ein einfaches Dateisystem.
Also spricht ZFS
jetzt mit diesem
Verschlüsselungspatch, den wir hier jetzt
ja quasi selbst mitkompiliert
haben,
ersetzt es quasi
MD-Rate für Software-Rate,
LUX für Verschlüsselung und LVM für
Volume-Management.
ZFS kann sich selbst reparieren, ist
relativ schnell, ist sicher,
also quasi bei
so was
wie Stromausfällen und
wenn Sektoren unlesbar werden auf
der Platte, kann sich selbst
bis zu einem gewissen Grad selbst
reparieren.
Software-Rate ist eingebaut, was
für mich ein riesen Vorteil ist. Du kannst
eines der besten Sachen, du kannst
Snapshots machen und wieder Restoren.
Also sprich, du kannst, bevor du ein Systemupdate
machst, machst du einen Snapshot vom System.
Wie ging das? Minus T,
Snapshots.
Nee, ach fuck, wie konnte man sich Snapshots
auflisten lassen?
Du machst quasi
einen Snapshot.
War das nicht List?
Wie konnte man sich
ZFS machen? Das ging doch irgendwie so.
Bin ich jetzt irgendwie total?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ging anders. Ah ja,
hab ich doch gemacht. ZFS List
minus T Snapshot.
Ah, ja.
Hä?
ZFS List minus T Snapshot hab ich doch gemacht.
Ah,
Snapshot. Ich hab Snapshots gemacht.
Ähm,
also ich hab hier, wie du siehst,
ich hab einen Snapshot gemacht
nach der Installation.
Das könnte ich auch von einem Paketupdate machen.
Dann würde ich einen Snapshot von meinem
System machen. Wenn das Paketupdate
irgendwelche Probleme hat, restore
ich den Snapshot
und alles wird wieder wie vorher. Das ist eines
der richtig geilen Sachen von ZFS. Und du
kannst diese Snapshots auch ziemlich einfach
übers Netzwerk, also sprich auch übers Internet
an einen anderen Server mit ZFS schicken und
hast dann dort deine Snapshots quasi als Backup.
ZFS ist eine richtig
geile Geschichte.
Und es hat noch 100.000
mehr Möglichkeiten, ja.
An der Oberfläche gekratzt.
So, jetzt müssen wir halt
bei jedem Mal booten
im Endeffekt
zwei oder drei Befehle ausführen, dass das
System startet. Das ist aber halb
so wild, weil ich mein, wir machen das über SSH.
Einfacher, komfortabler
könnte es eigentlich nicht sein.
Das wird erst komfortabler, wenn
quasi, ähm,
die Boot-Skripte von denen
angepasst sind, dass sie quasi
das gleiche auch ermöglichen.
Und ich glaube, den SSH-Server werden die nie einbauen.
Also im Prinzip funktioniert alles.
Na, also ich mein, man könnte jetzt
man könnte sich selbst so ein
irgendwie so ein
keine Ahnung, Unlock
ZFSH haben. Man könnte
so ganz simple Skripts
basteln, was im Endeffekt
Zpool, was
das quasi die Befehle, die wir von Hand eingeben,
was das für einen macht.
Das könnte man
machen, ja.
Also quasi Zpool import
äh
äh, root
minus l rpool und dann
ZFS mount
rpool root
ubuntu
Das könnte man machen und das könnte man
dann ausführen
nach dem Reboot.
Allerdings müsste man sich
dazu in das initiale
die initram fs das
irgendwie einbauen. Da weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie
das funktioniert. Deswegen machen wir das jetzt nicht.
Naja, ich weiß nicht,
wie man in die initram fs was eingebaut kriegt.
Müsst ihr erst mal nachgucken.
Wobei, hier haben sie es
doch stehen.
Take a look
etc initram fstool
Was heißt das machen wir jetzt nicht?
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Hooks
Ich mein, wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Ausprobieren.
So, und was soll man da jetzt reinpasten?
Ahem
Ach ne, Moment.
Das ist ja
kompliziert gemacht.
Also man
also quasi
man
schiebt nicht das Skript hier rein, sondern man
schiebt ein Skript hier rein, was dann das Skript da reinschiebt.
Uh
Probieren wir das mal aus.
So, neu formatieren.
Oh, da da da.
Die Formatierung ist...
Ach du Scheiße, die ist im Arsch.
Die ist immer voll im Arsch, die Formatierung.
Die stimmt ja hinten und vorne nicht.
Aber das wollen wir eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, das interessiert mich aber, wie das funktioniert.
Die hatten ja doch auch sowas.
Ja, das
hab ich schon mal gemacht.
Muss dahin.
Das hab ich schon mal gemacht, irgendwann.
Copy, Exec, da kann ich jetzt quasi sagen,
kopieren wir mal hier root
unlock keys hieß das, ne?
Unlock zfs sh
Kopieren wir das mal nach sbin
unlock
zfs.sh
Gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
List
content init ram fs
Google, beste!
Oh, ohne Google kannst du vergessen.
List content of zfs
image
boot
boot init
crep nach
zfs. Ey, das ist...
Ist das nicht der Game of Thrones Intro?
Das Game of Thrones Intro, was da im Hintergrund läuft?
Okay, das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert, was ich hier gemacht hab.
Heißt das überhaupt so?
Unlock zfs.
Hab ich das richtig gemacht?
Ja, das heißt so.
Oh!
Oh, Moment.
Da hab ich irgendwas vergessen, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Dann hab ich irgendwas vergessen,
wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Ah, das da. Guck mal, das da brauch ich.
Dann funktioniert das auch.
Update
Oh, mal gucken, ob es jetzt drin ist.
Wenn es jetzt nicht drin ist,
dann lassen wir das.
Hey! Hat funktioniert.
So, mal schauen.
Ich mein, man bräuchte jetzt noch ein Skript,
was quasi das
andere dann killt, ne?
Also quasi...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was haben wir?
Was muss man da killen?
Die... Ja, guck.
Gucken wir mal. Reboot.
Ja, ne. Das haben wir jetzt ja quasi
in diese initiale, in diese
Mini-RAM-Disk eingebaut am Anfang.
Das Skript, dass ich das zur Verfügung hab.
Gucken wir mal.
So.
Jetzt bootet er.
Kann das nicht mounten.
Jetzt verbinde ich mich per SSH dahin.
Und sag
sbin unlock
zfs.
Und es funktioniert nicht.
Ah, es funktioniert nicht,
weil ich die...
Weil ich noch Fade setzen muss.
Ne, nicht echo. Was mach ich denn da?
Export.
Hey, es funktioniert.
Ach, ne. Hier muss ich...
Hier müsste ich exit machen.
Ja, also von der Idee her funktioniert das.
Das Skript braucht noch ein wenig Feintuning.
Das...
Das macht noch nicht so ganz das, was es machen soll.
Also das muss auf jeden Fall schon mal
sbin sein. Und das muss auch
sbin sein, weil ich keine
Fade gesetzt hab.
Rebooten wir nochmal. Gucken, ob
das jetzt besser funktioniert. Aber das ist geil.
Ich mein, es...
Im Prinzip funktioniert alles. Also es gibt
jetzt nichts, was mal... was nicht gehen würde oder so.
Es klappt einfach.
So. Es rebootet.
Ich verbinde mich auf meinen Server
per SSH. Führe
sbin unlock ssh aus.
Hä?
Ist... liegt das überhaupt noch sbin?
Ah, ich hab vergessen zu updaten.
Oh, ich noob.
Ich hab... ich hab vergessen, das Skript zu updaten.
Ah, ich... wenn ich
das denn noch richtig schreib...
So, und dann muss ich... dann muss ich die...
Dann muss ich die erste
Shell muss ich killen.
Wie krieg ich denn die hier raus?
Ja.
Dann muss ich dann die erste
Shell killen. Äh, nicht
tail, head.
Huh, head gibt's nicht.
Krieg ich dann das erste raus?
Krieg ich mal mit tail irgendwie
den ersten raus? Ne, keine Ahnung.
Ah, boah, jetzt machen wir Trick 17.
Das ist zwar das uneffizienteste, was ich
mir so vorstellen kann, aber es funktioniert.
Äh, drei. Ja.
So.
Ha! Funktioniert!
Ha! Krasses...
Krasses Skripting.
Krasses Skripting-Gott hier am Werk wieder.
Aber ich bin...
Ich bin begeistert, wie einfach das ist.
Ich mein, das ist nicht schön hier.
Ja, das ist... funktioniert.
Es funktioniert.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
So, was hat... wo war jetzt nochmal das Problem?
Was hab ich gesagt, muss ich noch machen?
Genau, das Include.
Und hier, das muss ausführbar sein.
So.
Ist ja wieder die NSA am Hacken.
Ne, bisschen
einfacher diesmal.
So, ähm...
Alles noch ziemlich... Ja, das ist schon noch
alles ziemlich Proof of Concept, aber...
Also wenn das jetzt
ein Stable ZFS Release wäre
und ich bräuchte
einfach ein Custom Skript
oder ich müsste drei Zeilen beim Booten eingeben,
dass es funktioniert, ich würde es verwenden.
Weil ich mein, es ist ja klar, dass er beim Booten abkackt,
solange das offizielle Skript nicht
das Anlocken per Passwort
erlaubt.
Das ist ja kein Fehler in dem Sinn.
Das ist erwartet, dass es dann nicht weiter geht.
Dann locke ich mich ein, anlocke von Hand
und es funktioniert.
Mal gucken, wie das jetzt klappt.
Aber das ist doch geil,
wie das Anlocken per SSH beim Booten
funktioniert. Das ist doch der Wahnsinn.
Ist doch echt super.
Kann man noch nichts sagen.
Ich sollte vielleicht den Server nicht unbedingt
per DHCP seine Adresse beziehen lassen.
Das ist jetzt
nicht so clever, dass sie sich immer
ändert.
Wobei...
Mal was ausprobieren.
Ähm...
Der hat ja automatisch SSH...
Also
der trägt sich ja automatisch
Server ein bei mir.
Das Ding hieß ja
hostname, ganz toll.
Ja!
Guckt, der hat den Server bei mir automatisch
im DNS eingetragen.
Ist doch nice.
So, und jetzt rufen wir mal hier unsere auf.
sbin unlock zfs
12345678
Funktioniert! Easy!
Easy Eats Clap!
Na also, komm.
Komfortabler kannst du es doch jetzt beim besten Willen
nicht mehr machen.
So, jetzt ist das System gebootet.
Jetzt kommen wir ganz normal
per SSH drauf.
Das ist doch einfach.
Mehr kann man doch jetzt echt nicht haben wollen.
Mehr kann man nicht wollen.
Man rebootet
den Krempel jetzt.
Also, wir gehen jetzt mal von aus, das ist ein Server,
der am anderen Ende der Welt steht. Ich muss den jetzt
rebooten. Hat verschlüsselte ZFS-Platte.
So, ich hab jetzt reboot eingetippt.
Ich warte jetzt, bis der
hängen bleibt
und mir es erlaubt, mich per SSH einzuloggen.
Ich meine, ich muss
nichts dazu machen. Der macht alles automatisch.
Ja.
Da startet ein SSH-Client, da startet
ein SSH beim Booten.
So, jetzt warte ich, bis er das gemacht hat.
So, und jetzt, das ist der Server hier.
Da steht jetzt, keine Ahnung, in
Zimbabwe oder so.
Warte ich einfach eine Weile.
Und dann sag ich hier,
äh, äh, wo hab ich mein...
Hä? Ja, machen wir's halt von hier.
Dann log ich mich per SSH dort ein.
Sag, sbin
unlock ZFS.
Gib mein Passwort ein, was
ja essentiell erforderlich ist, weil ja meine
Festplatte verschlüsselt ist. Was ich auch
machen würde mit einem Server, den ich nach Zimbabwe
schicke, schicken würde. Also, falls ich
jemals einen Server in irgendwie
andere Länder schicke, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall immer
die Festplatte verschlüsseln. Unlock, zack
und Boot geht weiter.
Alles von Remote
mit ZFS Encryption
selbst kompiliert.
Ähm, funktioniert.
Ich würd mal sagen,
komplett erfolgreich, der Stream
heute.
Und komfortabler geht's nur beim besten Willen nicht.
Komfortab...
Außerdem hat unser Server den besten Namen
überhaupt. Der heißt nämlich einfach HouseName.
Ja, und jetzt
kann ich mich auf dem System einloggen und
alles machen, was man
...
so macht.
So, wir können mal unsere Sources wieder anpassen.
Aber im Prinzip sind wir fertig.
Das funktioniert alles.
Hier bräuchte ich mir nochmal einen Mirror,
der ein bisschen schneller ist, als der offizielle,
weil der ist mega langsam.
EasyClap, funktioniert.
Du kommst
und der ist zu Ende. Nein, noch ist das Stream nicht zu Ende.
Ähm, aber das, was wir machen wollen,
ist, äh,
also so, so gut
wie's geht, eigentlich umgesetzt. Da kannst du...
Was will man mehr?
Reboot eintippen, kurz warten,
ähm,
also quasi, Remote auf seinen Server verbinden,
der in einem anderen Land steht.
Reboot eintippen, kurz warten,
per SSH einloggen, ähm,
mit Passwort,
wobei ich's nicht mit Passwort machen würde, sondern vielleicht
mit irgendwelchen Keys in dem Fall,
beziehungsweise Passwort-geschützte Keys.
Ähm, Systemplatte anloggen
per SSH,
erbootet, auf System einloggen
per SSH. Mehr
kann man eigentlich nicht wollen.
Ja, Falco und ich hoffe darauf, dass
wenn ZFS 08 dann wirklich rauskommt,
mal irgendwann, demnächst,
dass dort dann die Boot-Skripte angepasst sind.
Also sprich, dass
die das schon eingebaut haben, dass es dich
fragt nach nem Passwort und
sowas. Hoff ich mal, oder geh ich mal
von aus, weil,
naja, wenn mit 08 Encryption
offiziell mit dabei ist, werden sie wahrscheinlich
auch ihre Boot-Skripte insoweit angepasst
haben, dass man
gefragt wird, ne?
Dass man dann nicht so'n komischen
Hack braucht, wie ich das da
hier gemacht hab. Vor allem das mit dem Kill-9
ist bestimmt nicht schön, wenn ich einfach
die Shell kille,
auf die der Server hängt.
Aber es geht, das ist ja die Hauptsache.
Das Skript ist nicht optimal,
der sollte nicht einfach nur direkt nach Passwort fragen.
Ähm,
ja, das stimmt.
Das ist aber kein
Problem vom Skript,
das ist ne Sache vom SSH-Server. Also sprich,
ich müsste jetzt meine
Login-Shell
hier im SSH umstellen,
dass ich nur diesen einen
Befehl ausführen kann, beziehungsweise
dass nur dieser eine Befehl
automatisch
gestartet wird.
Das kann man mal ausprobieren, weil, das weiß ich nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Äh,
gucken wir mal.
Gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Force Command, okay,
sowas wollen wir im Prinzip.
Disregard the command provided by the user
and always run command
Force Command.
So, und wo trage ich das jetzt ein?
Ne, also damit könnte ich wirklich
leben. Damit könnte ich echt leben,
so wie es jetzt ist.
Es ist sogar, ganz ehrlich,
es ist im Prinzip
zum,
zum Basteln sogar besser, so wie es jetzt ist.
Da kann ich nämlich
auf der Shell auch was machen, anstatt
dass ich quasi gezwungen, anstatt
dass ich nur dieses Skript ausführen kann und sonst nichts.
Und die machen das hier auch.
Guck, die machen,
das ist ja witzig. Guck mal, die machen es
genauso wie ich. Ein bisschen eleganter,
ja, ein bisschen eleganter machen sie es. Aber im Prinzip
machen die Typen das genauso wie ich.
Kill minus 9 von der anderen Shell.
Wie ist das denn?
Force Command, genau.
Äh, ich gehe mal kurz aufs Klo.
Dann gucken wir mal,
vielleicht machen wir das noch schnell.
Weil dann ist das wirklich, das ist dann die
Premium-Lösung, ja.
So,
wieder da.
So, also,
wir haben doch hier vorne so ein schönes,
so eine schöne Anleitung
auf Deutsch.
Hatten wir doch eine Anleitung. Da stand doch irgendwie auch
sowas drin wie, mit Command.
Wobei, ne, die geben auch
einen Befehl ein.
Die Frage ist halt, wo trage ich das hier ein?
Ah!
Was, im Authorized Key-File trage ich
das ein? Also im Authorized Key-File,
okay. Geht das so?
Aber dann wäre das, dann wäre das relativ einfach.
Command gleich.
Ist das so einfach?
Ist das wirklich so einfach?
Wie sieht, wie sieht denn so ein Authorized
Key-File mit Command aus?
Haben wir mal ein ordentliches Beispiel für?
Weil ich mein, ich könnte
jetzt, ich könnte hier schon einfach
das hier hinten ranschreiben, aber
so
einfach ist es wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Jaja, nur für einen Key ist es ja gut,
aber wo schreibe ich das hin?
Direkt, einfach hier hinten dran, oder was?
So?
Habe ich noch nie gemacht, ehrlich
gesagt. Äh.
Äh.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht?
Ah!
Davor. Aha.
Davor schreibt man das.
Davor mit Komma.
Also, also da.
Ups.
Äh. Also so,
oder wie? Ach nee, einfach mit
Leerzeichen dahinter. Okay.
So?
Prob, prob. Wir probieren
das jetzt einfach mal. Ich mein, mehr als
uns aussperren per SSH können wir ja nicht.
Mehr als aussperren per SSH
können wir uns ja nicht.
Ja, ich beschleunige den Reboot mal ein bisschen
von unserem Server in Zimbabwe.
Oder was gibt's noch für bessere
Länder? Was gibt's noch für bessere Länder, wo man,
wo man seinen Server nicht hinstellen möchte?
Jetzt mal so
offensichtliche Sachen wie Nordkorea außen vor.
Oh, ich glaub da ein anderer
IP gekriegt.
Ah! Es funktioniert! Es funktioniert!
Guckt's euch an!
Ist das, ist das nice?
Oh fuck.
Ich hab nen Bug gefunden.
Wenn ich das Skript abbreche mag es, mag es
nicht mehr.
Ja, wir sollten dieses, dieses Kill nur
ausführen,
wenn das Skript erfolgreich war.
Guckt euch das mal an, ja.
Ist das net geil?
Wahnsinn.
Und wisst ihr, was man daran auch schön sieht?
An solchen Sachen kann man,
wenn man es übertreibt, ein Leben
lang feilen und es ist nie perfekt.
Das, das
hier möchte man ja natürlich nur ausführen.
Das hier möchte man natürlich nur
ausführen, wenn alles andere erfolgreich
war. Also im Endeffekt, eigentlich
will man, will man sowas hier machen.
Man möchte,
man möchte das zweite Kommando
nur ausführen, wenn das erste Kommando
erfolgreich war und dieses Kill dann nur ausführen,
wenn das davor erfolgreich war.
Was ich für ne Tastatur hab?
Ich hab ein Microsoft Office Keyboard, nur als
das Ding. Aber komme ich am besten mit klar,
das hat so ne ergonomische Handauflage und das ist das,
was ich bei den ganzen Gaming Keyboards
vermisse oder wenn sie es haben,
finde ich die eben nicht ergonomisch.
Vielleicht sollte ich das immer nochmal am Anfang machen.
Äh, ab und zu habe ich noch
Kontakt mit dem Kaboom, ja.
Probieren wir das nochmal aus. Nochmal aus.
Was? Und das in einer Schleife?
Ne.
Schleife brauchen wir nicht.
Das SSH bricht ja einfach ab.
Das SSH bricht ja einfach
ab, wenn ich aus dem
Skript rausgehe. Da kann eigentlich nicht viel passieren.
Gucken, ob das so funktioniert,
wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Für ne IP kriegen wir
wieder die gleiche.
Ja!
Was ist, wenn ich jetzt abbreche?
Geht nicht mehr?
Geht! Nice, man kann abbrechen. Ha!
Das ist, also Leute,
komfortabler geht's nicht mehr.
Also jetzt ist wirklich perfekt.
Also jetzt ist wirklich,
guck mal, das ist mal ohne hinzugucken.
Ähm, wir machen
jetzt noch, äh,
ups, ne, ohne hinzugucken.
So, dann sag ich so, okay, ich mach jetzt hier irgendwie
Upgrade, hab ich
glaube ich schon gemacht. So, ich hab jetzt, äh,
ich hab jetzt einen neuen Kernel oder was weiß ich, irgendwas.
Ich hab jetzt irgendwas Neues gemacht, also ich muss mal rebooten.
Mach ich reboot, zack.
Warte ich jetzt einfach mal ne Weile.
Wie geht denn das unter Windows?
Einfach nur Datum
anzeigen lassen. Keine Ahnung.
Jetzt warte ich einfach mal ne Weile.
Bis der, bis, bis der Server
wieder da ist. In der Hoffnung,
der antwortet auf Ping.
Also mein Server, der steht jetzt am Arsch der Welt.
Das heißt, ähm,
ich kann, kann überhaupt nichts machen. So.
Er ist wieder da.
Der steht jetzt in Bangladesch.
Oder in
Togo and Tobago oder wie das, wie das
heißt.
Ich kann da nicht einfach mal so hin.
Jetzt hab ich rebooted.
Ich anlocke meine
Rootfestplatte und
das System ist wieder
da.
EasyClap.
Ja wunderbar.
Grasser Scheiß. Funktioniert.
Ehrlich gesagt einfacher als ich
mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ich bin echt begeistert.
Trinitat and Tobago heißt sie.
Also ich
bin echt zufrieden damit jetzt.
Wirklich zufrieden.
Das könnte man so einsetzen.
Das einzige,
warum ich es so nicht einsetzen würde ist,
weil es eine
Development Version
von ZFS ist. Also sprich
das aktuellste ungetestete Master
Commit. Ähm.
Und
eine Sache, die mich auch
nerven würde ist,
dass ich quasi
vor jedem Kernel Update
beziehungsweise
vor jedem Reboot
die Kernel
Module neu bauen müsste.
Das würde mich davon abhalten
das produktiv einzusetzen.
Da würde ich noch
1, 2 Monate oder so
warten oder keine Ahnung wann es soweit ist
bis ähm
ZFS 08 draußen
ist beziehungsweise
bis Ubuntu es
entweder in den offiziellen Paketquellen mit dabei
hat beziehungsweise
bis es dann ordentliches Custom oder
ein ordentliches ZFS Repo für Ubuntu gibt
mit dieser neuen Version.
Aber vom Prinzip her sieht man funktioniert
alles richtig gut.
Aimfreaks du hast noch nicht mal
diesen einen Befehl richtig geschrieben.
Doch ich bin da echt zufrieden mit
das hat besser geklappt als ich gedacht habe.
Die
wenn
Krupp irgendwann mal
sprich der Bootmanager wenn der irgendwann mal
Encrypted
Encrypted ZFS kann
dann kann man sich auch
auch hier unsere Bootpartition
sparen weil wir haben ja hier
eine Bootpartition
eine EFI Partition die werden wir immer
brauchen und halt für unser
ZFS Ruby beste
Programmiersprache
das hat jetzt keinen tieferen Sinn was ich hier mache
nur mal so angemerkt
weil wir gerade bei irgendwelchen
Hallo Welt Geschichten im Chat sind
Nein Falkhun
Falkhun ganz
bestimmt nicht
aber ha
der Falkhun hat da gerade was
lustiges eingetippt im Chat
ähm
was passiert wenn ich das hier ausführe
habt ihr eine Idee was passiert
wenn ich das hier ausführe
das ist ein gültiger Befehl
also so ohne das Fragezeichen
hinten dran
habt ihr eine Idee was passiert wenn ich das hier ausführe
ich kommentiere es mal aus
dass ich es nicht aus versehen ausführe
ich glaube ohne Fragezeichen
kann auch sein dass es mit Fragezeichen sein muss
ähm
Load of Doom
ja das kommt der Sache schon
kommt der Sache schon ziemlich nahe
ich führ es mal aus
ich führ es mal aus weil ich meine es ist eine VM
und mehr als 3 Kerne kann sie
ja
kann ja nichts passieren ich führ es mal aus
Bäm
oh mein System macht nichts mehr
guckt es euch mal an
VM hängt volle Pulle
nichts geht mehr System
kaputt im Arsch
Bäm
im Arsch
komplett im Arsch
System im Arsch
ja warum ist das so
also ich kann das jetzt neu starten
warum ist das so
ok also
werde ich das mal erklären
aber erst mal müssen wir unser System wieder anlocken
und guck mal
sogar der SSH Prozess hängt einfach noch
der hat einfach schon keinen Bock mehr
ich erklär es gleich
wenn ich das System wieder gestartet habe
äh was war es äh 5 3
das ist so geil
wie das funktioniert oder
so krass so easy
also
so
wer kann das darf das doch nicht mal echoen
ach ne echo nicht weil da ist das
das Kommentar davor ist
also warum
macht das hier das System kaputt
folgendermaßen
wir müssen das ein bisschen aufsplitten
das hier
deklariert ne Funktion
also man könnte auch sowas hier schreiben
äh das ist in bash
ne Funktion
wenn man die Syntax richtig
hinkriegt
ja das ist das ist in bash ne Funktion
also jedes mal wenn ich hallo aufrufe
führt er jetzt das hier auf
äh führt er jetzt das hier aus
lädt er in der Schleife irgendwas
ne es ist nicht wirklich ne Schleife
also im Prinzip ist das erste
ne Funktionsdeklaration
die Funktion heißt halt nicht hallo wie hier unten
im Beispiel sondern heißt Doppelpunkt
also sprich ich leg hier ne Funktion an
die sich Doppelpunkt nennt
Klammer auf Klammer zu ist einfach nur das bash weiß
dass ich ne Funktion anlegen will
die Funktion heißt Doppelpunkt
in dieser Funktion
das ist der
Body also sprich
das was die Funktion macht also sprich
das was zwischen den Klammern steht ne
die Funktion Doppelpunkt
enthält folgenden Programmcode
einmal ich rufe mich selbst wieder auf
und
ich rufe mich selbst nochmal auf
und schicke es in den Hintergrund
das heißt
jedes mal
wenn ich diese Funktion hier aufrufe
ruft sie sich selbst auf
und ruft sie sich selbst auf und schickt es wieder in den Hintergrund
in den Hintergrund ist wichtig
denke ich mal das es nicht blockt
und
Semikolon ist die Funktionsdeklaration
ist fertig und der Doppelpunkt
sorgt dafür das es einmal aufgerufen wird
also initial
einmal angestoßen wird
also sprich das hier führt das hier aus
und intern
startet es sich unendlich oft neu
deswegen kam es
zu dem Phänomen das ihr oben gesehen habt
ich hoffe ich kann noch hochscrollen man sieht es noch
ähm
Speicher Speicher
kein Speicher mehr da
alles voll komplett am Arsch
ja so wie es 0 0
schreibt das dupliziert sich
unendlich oft selbst
und das gefährliche daran ist
dass der Server davon nicht kaputt geht
ihr habt es ja gesehen
das gefährliche ist das viele Noobs sowas nicht erkennen
denen sagt man dann führt es mal aus
ich meine guckt mal
das hier sieht ja recht unscheinbar aus
ja
das sieht ja nicht aus als
wird da jetzt was
was schlimmes passieren
oder so
die Sony Vegas Readme
ich weiß auch nicht warum habe ich
keine Ahnung
ich drücke immer den falschen Knopf
genau so funktioniert das
so und viele Noobs fallen da halt drauf rein
die führen das dann hier aus
und dann
kackt ihr System ab
wie gesagt der Server geht nicht kaputt davon
er hängt sich halt auf
man kann dagegen was machen
man kann dagegen ein Limit
setzen
wie viele Prozesse gestartet werden dürfen
das geht
was ist das für nervige Musik
habt ihr sonst irgendwelche
Linux Fragen oder technische Sachen
oder so
oder WIM Fragen oder irgendwas
wenn wir jetzt schon mal dabei sind
ich meine unser Ziel haben wir ja nur wirklich
mit wie sagt man
mit Bravour
also
besser hätte es ja nicht laufen können
das eigentliche Ziel vom Stream
also sprich Booten von ZFS
mit ZFS Verschlüsselung
Nolenhard fragt auch wenn er es nicht ernst meint
fragt wie schließe ich
WIM
mir fallen
mir fallen drei Möglichkeiten aus dem Bauch raus ein
wie ich WIM schließe
machen wir doch mal ne Umfrage im Chat
was welche
also mir fallen drei Möglichkeiten ein
was fällt euch ein
um WIM zu schließen aus WIM
also es zählt jetzt nicht ne Shell aufmachen
und WIM zu killen
also mit welchen Kommandos
oder Shortcuts
kann ich WIM beenden
was fällt euch da alles ein
mit Doppelpunkt Q habe ich schon gelesen
ja das funktioniert
ja
Eyesworn das ist auch schon cool
das ist gut
also sprich man kann natürlich auch machen
WQ geht natürlich auch
und X
X ist auch gut
was
Steuerung X
macht was anderes
Steuerung X macht
ne was war das
ich weiß es nicht mehr
oh ich hab ne Donation gekriegt
danke ich muss gleich mal gucken
wer das gewesen ist
ich muss mal warten bis es in meiner Stream Vorschau kommt
Katnajo 5 Euro
Dankeschön
ohne Donation Message
ja also ihr habt recht
WIM beenden mit
Q ist relativ simpel
mit WQ natürlich auch mit X
aber eine Sache
die die wenigsten kennen
und die ich eigentlich ziemlich praktisch finde ist
ZZ
Shift
auch WIM beenden
das kennt kaum jemand
und ich könnte wetten es gibt wahrscheinlich
noch 20 andere Varianten WIM zu beenden
wenn jemand geschrieben hat
Steuerung X
bin ich jetzt gerade blöd war das nicht Steuerung X
was war das denn
ich dachte es wäre Steuerung X
gewesen
ja doch ist doch Steuerung X
ist doch Steuerung X
in WIM ist Steuerung X
nämlich
guckt hier
Steuerung X ist
hoch und runter zählen
Steuerung A und Steuerung X
eine Zahl hoch und runter zählen in WIM
warum es sowas
überhaupt gibt
keine Ahnung aber es gibt es
Masilein fragt
welche Linux Distribution mit welchem Desktop
ist am
ressourcensparendsten
keine Ahnung
ähm
also wenn der Laptop wirklich
so schwach ist
das da nicht mal ein Ubuntu mit einem i3
oder so drauf ordentlich läuft
dann
kannst du mal dein Glück irgendwie mit Tiny Core Linux
oder so probieren
aber ansonsten würde ich sagen mach Ubuntu
eine Minimalinstallation
und dann mach einen ressourcensparenden
Window Manager bzw. einen ressourcensparenden
Desktop drauf
ich bin ja großer i3 WM Fan
allerdings muss man sagen i3 WM
also sparsam ist er auf jeden Fall
sau schnell ist er auch auf jeden Fall
die Sache an i3 WM ist
so die normalen User
ähm haben Probleme
mit i3 WM
ich glaub die werden damit nicht warm
ansonsten nehmen wir halt sowas wie
XFCE oder so
also ich würde Ubuntu
Minimalinstallation nehmen an deiner
Stelle mit einem i3 drauf
oder aber einen Manjaro mit
i3 drauf wenn man ein bisschen besser sich mit
Linux auskennt
benutzt ihr eigentlich sowas wie GitLab CI
bei der Arbeit wir benutzen
Bitbucket als
ähm
GitWebGUI
und Jenkins
als CI Server
das hat historische Gründe
warum wir Jenkins verwenden
und GitLab wurde
bei uns ja durch Bitbucket abgelöst
also
bietet
sich jetzt auch nicht an GitLab CI
zu verwenden
äh ich würde wahrscheinlich wieder Jenkins verwenden
er fragt
was ich sonst verwenden würde wenn wir das nicht hätten
ich würde es wahrscheinlich wieder verwenden
ich finde Jenkins ist eine der wenigen Java Anwendungen
die ich mir tatsächlich gerne installiere
und die ich gerne verwende
ja 0hz habe ich vor
wieder ein bisschen C Sharp zu programmieren in dem Stream
ja
Moment wir mussten ja noch das ASCII
Aquarium installieren
wichtig
oh da muss ich mich abtauschen
abtools oder so installieren
oh
das ASCII Aquarium
das muss jetzt noch
das ASCII Aquarium muss
muss jetzt noch drauf ja das geht nicht anders
kurze Frage Max
hast du bereits ZFS und so gemacht
ja habe ich hat wunderbar funktioniert
soll ich dir mal zeigen was wir gemacht haben
falls du nicht da warst
kann ich das nochmal kurz zeigen
so die Einzelheiten
aber erstmal
oh ne
der hat
was ein Kack Noob
jetzt gibt es schon ein extra Repo für ASCII Aquarium
ja
und der hat kein ASCII Aquarium
Kack Noob
warum habe ich das Repo
warum verwende ich solche Kack Repo
ne ne ne
ich will ein ASCII Aquarium
ja BeatPro dann zeige ich dir mal was wir gemacht haben
aber ich brauche unbedingt ein ASCII Aquarium
unbedingt ist ganz wichtig
ich kann kein
HA
ich muss das jetzt installieren
das geht nicht anders
jetzt erleben wir mal irgendwelche hässlichen
Perl Scripts
die ich normalerweise
Perl ey
kriege ich da schon Anfälle
so jetzt
jetzt gibt es ASCII Aquarium
hast du was dagegen wenn
wenn du Stream rippst
und offline schaust
ne
habe ich nicht
Perl ey
hat das jetzt nicht installiert
oder was
wie heißt die
wie heißen die Build Tools
Ubuntu wie heißt der Krempe
ach das heißt tatsächlich
Build Essentials
ne
heißt doch eben nicht so
BeatPro ich zeige dir gleich was wir gemacht haben
ZFS
ich muss jetzt aber erstmal
ASCII Aquarium installieren
das ist wirklich wichtig
was ist mein Sternzahl ich bin Löwe
also in welchem
wo hat es das jetzt abgelegt
ja und wo hat es das jetzt gespeichert
das nervt mich jetzt
da ist es doch
ach man muss sich das runterladen
ja da ist es
endlich
jetzt bin ich zufrieden
ohne ASCII Aquarium läuft gar nichts richtig
das ist die Version ohne
Haifische kann das sein
warum gibt es eine Version ohne
Haifische
keine Haifische
so aber ich äh
BeatPro hat ja gefragt was er verpasst hat
also wir haben
ein ZFS Pool eingerichtet
beziehungsweise erstmal haben wir uns
ZFS selbst kompiliert
und zwar die aktuelle Master
Version
die aktuelle Master Version
von Github
sieht man hier
ist hier geladen
das aktuelle ZFS Modul
und dann haben wir einen ZFS Pool angelegt
einen
verschlüsselten ZFS Pool
deswegen haben wir uns das auch selbst kompiliert
weil es gibt noch kein offizielles Release
von ZFS für Linux
mit dem Encryption Patch
haben wir einen
verschlüsselten Pool angelegt
haben Ubuntu auf diesem
verschlüsselten Pool installiert
ähm und den Rest kann ich dir jetzt
zeigen wir rebooten jetzt
dann haben wir
einen
SSH Server eingerichtet
der beim booten geladen wird
auf dem Server drauf
und
damit kann ich mich
jetzt quasi während dem booten
auf den Server
verbinden
mein ZFS unlocken
mit einem Passwort
guck man sieht der kann jetzt nicht weiter booten
weil eben der ZFS
Pool verschlüsselt ist
auf dem das Ubuntu installiert ist
kann man sich da drauf verbinden
wenn ich jetzt die richtige IP habe
so
unlock ich mein Ubuntu
mein ZFS Pool
über SSH und du siehst er bootet weiter
und das System ist oben
das haben wir gemacht
und das ist meines Wissens nach
also wir haben so ein Miniskript noch selbst gebastelt
was das halt macht hier
ähm und das ist
soweit ich weiß
einmal dass ich das irgendwo gesehen habe
wie jemand encrypted oder native encrypted
ZFS verwendet und davon bootet
habe ich noch nirgendswo sonst gesehen
und ich habe auch noch nirgendswo eine Anleitung gesehen
dazu sprich das haben wir
komplett selbst rausgekriegt alles im Stream
mit den zwei offiziellen Anleitungen
also was man noch zusätzlich machen muss aber alles
im Stream selbst
rausgefunden
würdest du ZFS auch bei normalen Desktop Rechnern
benutzen
wenn das mein Hauptsystem wäre ja
in der VM nicht
VM kann man so Snapshots machen
VMs haben meistens
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel RAM
na VM würde ich ganz normal
X4 oder XFS verwenden
aber auf meinem Server beispielsweise
läuft ZFS als Root-Datei System
allerdings
ohne ZFS Verschlüsselung sondern noch mit Lux
voll verschlüsselte Festplatten
aber das geile ist halt
an der aktuellen ZFS Version
also an der ZFS Version mit Encryption
du kannst halt
alles was du sonst
mit zig Tools
gemacht hättest
kannst du alles vereint mit ZFS machen
was halt echt geil ist
das einzige was soweit ich weiß
ZFS noch fehlt ist
Trim Support für SSDs
da gibt es aber wohl auch schon
einen Patch für
in BSD ist der schon drin
in der ZFS Implementierung
aber ZFS für Linux
hat diesen Trim Patch für SSDs
noch nicht drinne aber
ehrlich Leute es gibt schlimmeres
als das ich meine SSDs nicht trimmen kann
normalerweise bräuchtest du
um
ähnliche Sachen zu machen
wie man das jetzt hier
kombiniert mit ZFS machen kann
bräuchtest du MD RAID
für
Software RAID
Lux für Festplatten Verschlüsselung
LVM für Volume Management
und die ganzen Vorteile
von ZFS die ZFS an sich bietet
das ist beispielsweise
beschränkte Maß selbst reparieren kann
dass du Snapshots machen kannst
Datasets anlegen und sowas
die hast du dann auch nicht
Beat Pro zu wirklich großer Nachteil
ist es nicht wenn du kein Trim durchreichen kannst
ich meine du kannst
halt unbelegte Blöcke
du kannst mit Trim kannst du
SSD sagen welche Blöcke
nicht belegt sind welche er quasi
wieder irgendwie
wie nennt sich das hier irgendwie in seinem
Haltbarkeits
Algorithmus wiederverwenden kann
so
ja genau das was der Nullen hat da
copy pasted hat genau das ist es
das ist nicht so wild
ja
ich muss sagen ich bin echt zufrieden
ich bin echt zufrieden
durch wie gut das funktioniert hat
Linux Form Scratch
oh das ist doch die richtige Version mit
Haifischen
gedreckt
Fisch
es ist sogar die bessere ASCII Aquarium Version mit diesen Mini Fischen
die gab es bei der alten Version nicht
warum hat der Fisch das überlegt
überlebt
also Beat Pro wir haben schon mal ne
Manjaro Architect
Version installiert im Stream
das ist so
die rawste und lowleveligste
Sache die ich im Stream machen werde
was was Linux Installation
und sowas angeht
also Gentoo selbst kompilieren ist für ein
Stream schon mal ziemlich beknackt
dauert einfach lange
und ist nervig wenn du da einfach nur auf
Compiler Ausgaben guckst
ja klar du musst da auch viel selbst
konfigurieren und so aber das ist dann schon sehr
abgedreht
und Linux Form Scratch ist absolut
hier so außerhalb
der Möglichkeiten
erstens von mir
weil ich es noch nie gemacht habe
und auch sowas im Stream zu zeigen
hinkriegen würde ich es wahrscheinlich
mit Anleitung
ja die Musik passt gut dazu
oder du verstehst
nur 25% von dem was ich sage
aber du guckst gerne ja das ist doch schön
das war gut
demnächst gibt es ja auch mal wieder
normale Gaming Streams
aber ich wollte
das hier mit ZFSE schon eine Weile
mal ausprobieren seit ich gemerkt habe
dass der Encryption Branch
gemerged wurde
seitdem wollte ich das ausprobieren
da habe ich gedacht wir können es einfach mal zusammen ausprobieren
ja
wie findest du
findest du der Mehraufwand
der durch ZFS entsteht ist es wert
wenn es
doch auch
ja
wie auch immer man das jetzt genau ausspricht
da gibt es ja verschiedene Varianten
man kann es entweder BTRFS aussprechen
oder Beta oder ButterFS
oder wie auch immer
ich weiß gar nicht was die richtige Aussprache davon ist
wenn es doch auch sowas wie
BTRFS Build-In gibt
also ich finde den Mehraufwand für ZFS
ist auf jeden Fall gerechtfertigt
weil es Dinger an vielen Stellen
auch einfacher macht
ich muss nicht mit MD-Rate
hantieren ich muss nicht mit LUX hantieren
und LVM und allen möglichen Sachen
sondern einfach mit ZFS
ZFS hat ein super Kommandozeilen Interface
wenn man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat
das macht es finde ich sogar einfacher
und BTRFS ist
naja
sagen wir mal nicht
tot aber
auch nicht sonderlich lebendig
und ZFS ist
sehr lebendig
was Mitarbeiter und Commits
und Leute die Contributen und so
angeht
ZFS ist BTRFS meine Neuheit voraus
sowohl von dem was es schon kann
als auch die Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit
also
das ist eigentlich das beste was man
verwenden kann
LOLBO4
ja funktioniert alles
sogar besser als ich mir
am Anfang vorgestellt habe
Rebooten, Unlocken, Remote
funktioniert alles
XFatal jawoll
ZFS ist in sowas wie
Freenas schon drin
allerdings Freenas ist BSD kein Linux
also wenn man quasi nur
NAS betreiben möchte
mit ein paar
mit ein bisschen Bonus
obendrauf
ja man kann mit Freenas
auch schon noch ein bisschen mehr machen
als nur NAS
also quasi
selbst installieren will auf Hardware
dann ist Freenas eine wirklich super Geschichte
man hat ein schönes
Web Interface
kann damit alles so machen was man mit so einem NAS machen will
für mich kam jetzt Freenas nicht in Frage
auch bei einem Server hier daheim
weil mit dem will ich ja noch mehr machen als NAS
und außerdem wollte ich kein
BSD als Unterbau haben
weil ich mich mit BSD nicht so gut auskennen
ist doch echt entspannend
oder mit der Musik
Gequarium im Hintergrund
danke für den Follow
ich sehe die Namen
leider nur mit Verspätung immer
ich höre aber den Sound
immer gleich
Modst18
ja also
wie gesagt XFatal
kann man empfehlen Freenas ist super
es gibt eh
richtig gute BSD Projekte
also Freenas ist
eine super NAS Lösung
PF Sense bzw. Open Sense
es ist eine super Firewall
schräg schräg Router
Distribution
die beste finde ich sogar
was einer
von ACDC ist heute gestorben
okay es ist nicht so meine Musik
muss ich sagen
ich höre zwar fast ausschließlich
Heavy Metal Hard Rock und sowas
aber ACDC ist
war nie so meins
aber wo wir gerade dabei sind bei Leuten die gestorben sind
habt ihr mitbekommen dass Internet Hulk
gestorben ist?
also für die Leute die Overwatch gespielt haben
kennen ihn vielleicht
letztes Jahr hat er bei Team Germany
mitgespielt dieses Jahr war er bei Team Germany
auch mit dabei
er hat quasi das Overwatch
Envyous Team mitgegründet
und er war glaube ich erst 30
richtig krasse Sache
ich glaube am nächsten Jahr hätte er
am nächsten Jahr hätte er
das
eines der LOL Teams von Team Liquid managen sollen
es hat mich schon ein bisschen
geschockt muss ich sagen
30 ja
er war 3 Jahre jünger als ich
das hat mich echt schon ein bisschen geschockt
muss ich sagen
man weiß ja nicht so genau was ist
man kann sich so ein bisschen zusammen reiben
aus seinen Twitter Messages
aber es kann auch komplett
anders gewesen sein
aber es ist heftig
es sollte sowas wie Spawn Protection
geben
ja das wäre gut
ab 60 läuft die Spawn Protection aus
das wäre gut
das wäre nice
und mit Microtransactions
kannst du deine Spawn Protection verlängern
die wären gut
die würden sich gut verkaufen
die Microtransactions würden sich echt
gut verkaufen
ja oder man genau
man kauft sich einen Season Pass
dann läuft es gar nicht aus
das wäre auch nicht schlecht
und die EA wären
die ersten die sowas verkaufen
entweder 60 Jahre lang
grinden oder Season Pass kaufen
da fällt die Entscheidung
noch einfacher oder
Max spielst du irgendwelche Handy Games
ab und zu mal Hearthstone
ab und zu mal
schon ewig nicht mal gespielt
ist aber das einzige Handy Game was ich öfters mal gespielt habe
aber nachdem ich kein Hearthstone mehr spiele
spiele ich auch kein Hearthstone mehr auf dem Handy
Animal Crossing für iOS
boah
ich bin überhaupt kein Animal Crossing Fan
ich kann den Hype oder dieses
das Animal Crossing überhaupt
so viele Fans halt nicht verstehen
es geht komplett an mir vorbei Animal Crossing
es gibt noch mehr so Serien die komplett
an mir vorbei gehen so Monster Hunter zum Beispiel
auch sowas
juckt mich überhaupt nicht
und was mich auch nicht juckt
auch wenn ich verstehen kann
dass es beliebt ist
ist der ganze Battle Royale
Kram
ich glaub du bist einfach zu alt
ich glaub die Spiele passen einfach nicht mehr zu mir
oder ich nicht mehr zu den Spielen
ich glaub es sind einfach
schlicht und ergreifend der Anteil von
von Kackspielen ist einfach unglaublich hoch
mittlerweile
guckt euch mal das letzte Divinity an
übelst extrem geiles Game
eines der besten
Rollenspiele auf dem PC
aller Zeiten wenn ihr mich fragt
oh Jihan da bist du aber schon
ganz schön lang dabei wenn du seit Black Ops 1 guckst
also
es war ja 2010
oder so
es ist ziemlich genau 7 Jahre her
was ich halt auch cool find
es gibt viele
es gibt viele die sind seit
2010 oder so dabei
und was ich da halt geil
finde ist
das sind halt manchmal Leute die waren halt 2010
oder so ich mein 2010
muss man überlegen da war ich eigentlich 25
so und die waren Leute
die waren damals teilweise 12
oder 13 oder so
also sowas wo ich sagen würde
hey voll Kinder
noch für mich sind Leute mit 12, 13
sind immer noch Kinder
auch wenn natürlich 12, 13 jährige
sagen würden nein das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
so
und die sind jetzt 20
also sprich
die gucken mich seit sie Kind sind
bis quasi jetzt
wenn sie teilweise
studieren und manche haben sie
manche haben sogar schon Kinder und sowas
ja das ist geil also was in 7 Jahren
alles passieren kann
ja ich weiß das da viele
ich weiß das viele schon
schon lange dabei sind ja
aber ich muss euch also eins
muss ich aber echt sagen
ich bin zwar 33 mittlerweile
ja weiß ich das es dem Friseur ähnlich geht
da haben wir nämlich schon
paar mal drüber gelabert
wir sind beide 33
ja also wir sind ziemlich
gleich alt
aber obwohl wir wissen das
wir beide 33 sind
naja also wir fühlen uns so
wie 33 wie auch immer man sich fühlt
wenn man 33 ist ja
also wir fühlen uns nicht jetzt irgendwie
sonderlich alt
ähm
und wir haben auch keinen Bock uns so zu verhalten
wie das vielleicht
irgendjemand vorschwebt
dass man sich eben verhalten soll
wenn man jetzt so erwachsen ist
ja also
in der heutigen Zeit
ist doch eh alles nicht mehr so wild
das ist doch heute alles eh nicht mehr so wild
kannst du heute eigentlich glücklicherweise machen
was du willst
wie alt fühlst du dich denn
ähm boah also ganz ehrlich
ich
hab irgendwie so mit
20 oder so
so mit 20
also man hat ja früher immer so das Gefühl gehabt
so dass ich jedes Jahr irgendwie
ähm
dass man jedes Jahr älter geworden ist
und das man die Welt so quasi jedes Jahr so ein bisschen anders sieht
also ich muss sagen so ungefähr
seit ich keine Ahnung
22 23 bin oder so
ähm
da also
hat sich da nicht mehr so viel getan
ich komm mir immer noch vor wie 22
oder 23 oder sowas
gut ich bin nicht mehr so fit
wie damals das liegt auch daran dass ich den ganzen Tag
auf der Arbeit am Schreibtisch hocke
ja und dann hier teilweise auch noch
vorm Rechner hocke
ich mein mit 22 23 war ich schon
noch viel viel fitter
als du da Sport also zu den Zeiten
ja wenn du da Sport gemacht hast
ging es erst richtig los als du angefangen hast
zu schwitzen heute ist Schluss
wenn du anfängst zu schwitzen
aber ansonsten hat sich da nicht viel
geändert
wie sieht das denn mit dem langen Lachs vom
Kabum aus tja
das musst du ihn selbst fragen
er erzählt ja jedes mal wenn wir
äh wenn wir futtern gehen
was nicht so oft ist aber ab und zu mal
dass er auch noch nicht so 100%ig
immer im Kopf abgeschlossen hat mit Youtube
vielleicht doch
nochmal irgendwann ein Video kommt von ihm
aber er will ja da auch
jetzt irgendwie nichts teasen und versprechen
von dem er noch gar nicht weiß ob es was wird
kennst du noch
Kieler Junge 94 ja
klar
von dem habe ich schon lange nichts mehr gehört
ne Beatport ich denke schon
also bestimmt
nicht mehr das automatisch so viele Leute
gucken würden wie damals
damals gab es nicht so viel Auswahl
aber letztendlich geht es ja um den Inhalt
was gesagt wird und
da finden sich definitiv
garantiert Leute die das anspricht
und äh
wenn du sagst die Qualität ist heute
fast Standard
das mag vielleicht so
das das das Editing und
äh
visuellen Geschichten angehen
wobei da muss ich auch sagen
da wird halt viel viel geklotzt aber
so wirklich gut
gut designt oder gut gemacht
gibt es da auch wenige Videos
das ist ja nur das eine ja
aber wenn man da von inhaltlicher
Qualität spricht
ähm das sieht jetzt auf
Youtube 2017 auch nicht wirklich viel
besser aus
vor allem in Deutschland
ich guck auch wenig auf Youtube
es gibt ein paar Sachen die ich gucke ja
aber so
also von allen Channels
die so quasi dann kommen so mir hier Trends
in Deutschland und sowas
guck ich quasi gar
nichts ja also inhaltlich
ist Youtube Deutschland wirklich komplett
für die Tonne ja
es gibt gute Inhalte
in Deutschland weiß ich nicht
wie viel Gutes da gibt aber international
gibt es schon einige gute Inhalte
und Sachen die ich gerne gucke
Sachen die mittlerweile auch äh
verhältnismäßig erfolgreich
sind
also nicht total
Nischen da sein Fristen so aber in Deutschland
kannst du es vergessen ich guck eh fast nur noch
englischsprachige ich guck ich guck hier gerade
was hab ich denn deutschsprachig noch kurz abonniert
was ich öfters gucke ich kann es euch jetzt
leider nicht zeigen weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt
bin ja
jetzt würde ich euch zeigen was ich was ich abonniert
hab auf Youtube
was ich gerne guck auf Youtube
sind einmal so
so Science
Geschichten
also
so was wie Space Time oder was gibt's denn da
noch alles
sowas in der Richtung so ja so Science Physik
Geschichten
guck ich eigentlich ganz gerne Videos zu
sowas was ich am Rande des
Universums blablabla
sowas guck ich ganz gerne
was ich auch noch ganz gerne guck sind so historische
Geschichten so
irgendwelche Channels die was erzählen
über
äh
Truppenformationen im
Mittelalter und sowas in der Richtung ja das
finde ich auch interessant
oder irgendwie warum
die Schwertkämpfe in Filmen
immer total bescheuert sind und was da dran
nicht stimmt und sowas in der Richtung was die dann
erzählen das guck ich auch immer ganz gerne
ich hab jede Menge Overwatch Channels
wenn ich hier durchscrolle noch abonniert und guck ich auch
noch ab und zu
äh gut
auch jede Menge Programmier
Channels und Technik
Geschichten
was ich mir gar nicht angucke
sind Channels
die so quasi unter Technik
laufen aber wo ich
teilweise das Gefühl hab die Leute haben
keine Ahnung oder ähm
das ist
immer so oberflächliche Sachen dann ja
also jetzt beispielsweise
irgendwelche also Channels
die die sagen wir mal jetzt äh
Smartphone Reviews machen oder so
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
gibt's welche die machen das gut und auch gut
produziert aber das interessiert mich
null gibt's Channels die du
empfehlen kannst wenn es ums Programmieren geht ja
gibt's aber da muss ich jetzt erstmal meine
meine Listen hier durchgucken es gibt richtig coole
Channels auch für unterschiedliche
Sprachen die man empfehlen
kann aber fällt mir jetzt grad aus dem
Kopf leider keiner ein keiner ein
wo ich sagen würde das ist universell
für alle Sprachen gut
Katzen guck ich auch ja muss ich sagen
Funny Cats und was
hast du nicht gesehen ja
das guck ich natürlich auch Simons
Cat guck ich
das find ich auch geil
da so Animations Zeug
aber es geht halt immer nur 3 Minuten oder so ja
guckst du Rocket Beans
ne irgendwie
ich weiß nicht
irgendwie find ichs nicht so spannend
auch wenn ich Game One
immer richtig gern
geguckt hab aber irgendwie
ist so der Funke beim
Rocket Beans Programm jetzt für mich persönlich
nicht übergesprungen
aber wer Spaß daran hat das zu gucken ist wunderbar
das ist zumindest
es ist definitiv kein Mist in dem Sinn
wie ich das
wofür ich andere Channels und andere Angebote
da oder Programme in Deutschland halt
definitiv kein Mist
was kennst du
Semper Video
ja kenn ich
finde ich aber auch nicht so
spannend anzugucken
ich glaub das liegt einfach daran wenn man sich
selbst mit der Thematik auskennt
oder mit den meisten Thematiken
auskennt die da angesprochen werden
dann sind die Videos relativ
oberflächlich was nicht schlecht ist ne also ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass die Videos kacke sind
oder so aber wenn man halt selbst in der Materie
drin ist sind die Videos halt relativ oberflächlich
weil man sich halt schon auskennt
erzähl uns mal ein Schwank aus deiner
Jugend
dann müsste ich mir jetzt erstmal
Gedanken machen
gab es genug richtig dumme Sachen
ja
da müsste ich aber jetzt
da müsste ich jetzt erstmal so richtig im erzählen
sein dann würde mir da auch was einfallen
so ne fällt mir jetzt
keine Ahnung fällt mir grad nichts blödes ein
ich war bei den Pfadfindern
lange
war ich bei den Pfadfindern ja
und fand das noch richtig geil damals
bis ich mich dann irgendwann mal gefragt habe
was mach ich da eigentlich auch dann bin ich dann
immerhin
hab das Gefühl
RocketBeansTV spricht eher junges Publikum
ja musst du ja auch also ich hab das Gefühl sie wollen eigentlich
durch die Bank weg
breite breite
Menge an Leuten ansprechen ja
aber du musst ja jüngeres Publikum ansprechen
wie willst du heute nen Livestream oder
sagen wir mal nen Sender in dem sie ihn betreiben
mit Gaming Inhalten
und sagen wir mal solchen Inhalten wie RocketBeans das macht
ohne junge Leute anzusprechen
das wäre ja auch total bescheuert wenn du nicht junge Leute ansprechen willst
oh
nicht ohne junge Leute
hast du mittlerweile eine neue Katze
ne hab ich noch nicht aber
letzte Woche
war jemand da der nen Zaun
baut also
so ne Firma die die Zäune baut
weil ich will zwischen Hof
und ein Stück vom Garten
will ich nen Zaun machen
dass die Katze nicht mehr in den Garten
beziehungsweise nicht mehr komplett
in den Garten kann weil ich nicht will
dass sie zu den Nachbarn rüber geht und danach
hinter auf die Straße gehen überfahren wird
das ist bei ner alten Katze nicht das Problem
die kannte das Grundstück seit
12 Jahren oder so schon
und konnte eh nicht mehr hoch springen
und ist eh nicht mehr über die Zäune drüber
aber wenn ich mir jetzt 2 neue Katzen hole
und die werden natürlich auch ein bisschen jünger sein
und die kennen das nicht
ich hab keinen Bock dass
die Katzen dann überfahren werden
deswegen bau ich hinten
da ist ja schon ne Mauer
mit Tor
da kommt oben dran und nebendran noch
bisschen Zaun
die Katze nicht mehr hinten im Garten
über den Zaun drüber
gibts noch nen zweiten Git-Stream
ja mach ich noch
was macht man denn bei den Pfadfindern
Zelte bauen
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
ich kann richtig gut Zelte bauen
ich kann 2 Zelttypen bauen
ich weiß nicht mehr wie das Zeug heißt
ich kann einmal dieses komische Ein-Mann-Zelt
mit einer Plane bauen
da hab ich sogar ein paar
gab es immer lokal so ein paar
so Wettbewerbe wer baut das Zelt am schnellsten auf
so dieses Ein-Mann-Mini-Zelt
konnte ich damals zumindest
mega schnell aufbauen
paar Minuten so flup flup flup
neben rein zack vorne
Dings starb und hoch und gut war
und zu zweit
konnten wir auch richtig schnell dieses
wie auch immer zählt das
ich weiß nicht mehr wie das hieß
dieses Zelt bauen mit den 2 Baumstämmen
über Kreuz
das konnten wir zu zweit auch übertrieben schnell
ja
SSJ
finde ich geht mir auch so
ja
machts gut
ganz schön sneaky
ne das hieß irgendwie anders
ich guck jetzt mal
das muss ich jetzt mal gucken
ich schreib schon ZELT TYPE
Liste von Zelttypen
zack
Moment
da
ne
ne ne ne
das da
das konnten wir gut hier
mit dem
mit diesen Baumstämmen drüber
zu zweit konnten wir das gut
und das andere sah ein bisschen
also das andere
was ich alleine sau schnell aufbauen konnte
ein bisschen
sowas hier in der Richtung
war das
das war im Endeffekt nur mit einer Plane
glaub ich drüber
also sowas konnten wir zu zweit richtig schnell aufbauen
kleine finde ich jetzt
nicht mehr
es gibt so viele Sachen die sich schon Leute gewünscht haben
die ich hier mal technisch machen soll im Stream
ich glaub da komm ich gar nicht hinterher
es wollte letztens also wie gesagt GIT soll ich noch weitermachen
ich soll C Sharp weiterprogrammieren
da kam letztens noch jemand der wollte dass
ich LXC
beziehungsweise Linux Container Stream mache
oh da ist noch viel mehr
ich weiß gar nicht was ich jetzt alles machen soll
zumal die Streams gehen ja auch immer lang
der Stream hier jetzt
ging jetzt 4 Stunden oder so schon
gut wir sind schon locker seit einer halben Stunde
quasi fertig
aber es dauert
hast du Erfahrung mit Android Programmierung
ne hab ich nicht
ach du hast das per Twitter
vielleicht warst du ja nicht der einzige
GIT war sehr interessant
ja mir hat der GIT Stream persönlich nicht gefallen
also das liegt nicht an euch
sondern ich fand das von mir
ein bisschen planlos den GIT Stream
ich hätte mir am Anfang mehr überlegen müssen
oder ich hätte
hätte mir das besser gefallen
wenn ich mir am Anfang ein bisschen mehr überlegt hätte
in welcher Reihenfolge ich was erzähle
aber es war schon ein bisschen konfus
ab und zu
heute war das viel besser
heute hat auch alles funktioniert
hallo Halbkorn
gerade umgezogen
ja no second plan
der Stream ist im Prinzip fertig
also ich laber eigentlich seit einer halben Stunde nur rum
mit dem was wir machen wollten sind wir schon durch
und ich bleib jetzt einfach noch so lang on
wie noch irgendwie Fragen im Chat kommen
oder Kommentare im Chat
zu denen ich was sagen kann
oh ich muss
ich muss den Friseur gleich noch
äh
ah das darf ich ja nicht sagen
weil das wäre ja dann Account Sharing
ne ne muss ich nicht
nix ich hab nix gesagt
ja GIT über Kommandozeile verwenden
ist finde ich auch das einzige
sinnvolle
was hältst du von Battlefront 2 Hate
vollkommen gerechtfertigt
äh
auf mehreren Ebenen
ich finde das Spiel kacke
hat mich nicht überzeugt in der Beta
sowas
uninspiriertes
hingeklatschtes
wie Battlefront 2 habe ich lange nicht mehr gespielt
und diese ganze
Microtransaction Shit
das ist vollkommen zurecht ja
hey weißt du wie man
die alte Twitch UI wiederherstellt gar nicht
konntest
die ja früher oben im Menü machen
aber das hat Twitch jetzt entfernt
ja mich nervt das auch
also mich nervt das richtig
ich verstehe den
den Sinn vom neuen Twitch Layout nicht
also ich seh
ich seh erstens kaum nen Unterschied
zwischen dem alten und dem
neuen
dazu kommt das viele Sachen im neuen nicht mehr da sind
zum Beispiel kann man nicht mehr
also zumindest funktioniert das bei mir nicht
ihr könnt ja mal in Chat schreiben ob das bei euch noch funktioniert
früher konnte man nen Stream angucken
und
wenn du dann navigiert hast auf der Seite
ist der Stream minimiert unten rechts
ähm
da geblieben
sowie in der mobilen App
geht jetzt nicht mehr
könnte auch sein dass es ein Better Twitch TV Feature war
keine Ahnung zumindest gehts nicht mehr
ähm Better Twitch TV funktioniert auch nochmal richtig
keine Outdoor Complete von Emotes mehr
das neue Dark Theme sieht kacke aus
also ich
und ich seh halt null
den
der ist am neuen
ich seh keinen Unterschied erstmal
ich seh bloß Sachen die nicht funktionieren
ich weiß nicht was besser ist
vielleicht ist es von der Architektur her für Twitch besser
drunter
keine Ahnung also für mich ist es nervig
Better Twitch TV geht auch nur noch zur Hälfte
vor allem das
das aktuell mit Better Twitch TV die
Emote
das Emote Outdoor Complete nicht funktioniert
ist nervig
vorher hast du geschrieben POC Tab gedrückt
POC Champ draus geworden ne?
du musste das ausschreiben
warum das ist einfach nervig
äh no second plan ich seh deine Emote
genauso groß wie vorher auch
also ich geh mal davon aus
dass Better Twitch TV die Sachen
fixen wird dass es auch auf der neuen Seite funktioniert
aber es dauert halt ne Weile
sowas ich mein das wird wahrscheinlich
ich hab mir den Source Code ne Jahrhunderte angeguckt
ja aber das wird wohl
ein recht komplexe
haufe ja äh groß komplexe
Haufen JavaScript sein
Better Twitch TV
und es dauert ein bisschen bis man das umgestellt hat
worum gehts
ach ich reg mich nur über das neue Twitch Layout auf
dass ich den Vorteil davon nicht sehe
plus Sachen die nicht funktionieren
es gibt jetzt oh doch wichtig
wichtig es gibt Achievements
es gibt Achievements hab ich vorhin gesehen
ich hab nen Achievement bekommen weil ich
meinen Streamtitel geändert hab
geil oder es gibt endlich
ja weil es auch der Grund ist der
mich irgendwie vom streamen abhält
oder zum streamen bringt
dass ich Achievements kriege fürs streamen
ganz wichtig
unbedingt muss sein
ja wo wir gerade bei Plugins sind
neuer Firefox
muss ich mal gucken
ob es da mittlerweile NoScript gibt
wo wir gerade bei Semper Video vorhin waren
da macht er wirklich
gute Videos für sowas
wenn man da technisch nicht so drin ist und sich das
einen das interessiert
dann ist das kein schlechter Channel
ja Bäm
gibts doch nicht nicht aktualisiert
guck mal mal ins
NoScript Blog rein
wo die
die hatten doch irgendwo nen Entwickler Blog
irgendwo hatten die nen
ich weiß nicht wo die hatten irgendwo ne
ne List so nen Blog
der NoScript Entwickler
wo er geschrieben hat das es bis Ende der Woche
auf jeden Fall raus sein soll für Firefox 57
ist es aber immer noch nicht
ich hab jetzt in der Zwischenzeit
weil es kein NoScript gibt
hab ich in Firefox jetzt
U-Blog verwendet
U-Matrix braucht man nicht
weil U-Blog
kann quasi
fast alles was U-Matrix auch kann
wenn man das Advanced Filtering anstellt
kommt man auch mit klar
aber NoScript ist mir trotzdem lieber
was die grüne Meldung oben
welche grüne Meldung oben
wo ist da ne grüne Meldung oben
die NoScript Seite
ist hässlich
auf der Hauptseite von NoScript
ah ja genau
hier ist der Link zum Blog Post
gibt es noch nicht
gibt es noch nicht für
ansonsten ist Firefox 57
das beste was sie je gemacht haben
man kann sich jetzt drüber
streiten ja Addons die
nicht mehr gehen und so
es hat sich eh sehr in Grenzen gehalten
was ich an Addons verwendet hab
für mich ist eigentlich NoScript am wichtigsten
dafür ist der neue Firefox
jetzt hat er mal ordentlich
Speed wieder und
verbraucht weniger RAM
wir müssen da auch schon ein bisschen mit der Zeit gehen
was mich wirklich nervt
auch beim Chrome
beim offiziellen Chrome
deswegen habe ich hier auf Windows auch ein Chromium installiert
und eben kein offiziellen Chrome
ist dass die
beiden Browser nur noch
quasi
Store Plugins
fressen
das nervt mich
es gibt ein paar Plugins die will ich installieren
die installiere ich selber ja also sprich das darf mir gerne sein
ich muss eine Warnung anzeigen
und ich muss das akzeptieren und so ist alles vollkommen ok
aber Chrome und Firefox
erlauben keine Plugins mehr
und die nicht aus dem Store sind
nicht signiert sind aus dem Store
funktioniert nicht
das ist doof
weil es gibt ein Plugin das verwende ich
beziehungsweise das finde ich super
und zwar das hier
das ist ein
Bookmark Sync Plugin
für Nextcloud
oder für Owncloud je nachdem was man
Produkt verwendet
da kann man quasi hier seine Bookmarks
ich habe hier keine Bookmarks drin
weil das ein neuer Account ist
kann man seine Bookmarks auf Nextcloud syncen
und
gibt es für Chrome und
für Firefox
also man kann auch
nur den speziellen Ordner syncen
man synkt nicht automatisch alle Bookmarks
das ist das was mir an dem offiziellen Sync
nicht gefällt
zumal es dann auch auf meinem Server liegt
und da kann ich
spezielle Bookmark Ordner synchronisieren
da kann ich dann zum Beispiel einen Ordner machen
beispielsweise für
für Linux, für Programmieren
für sonst was
die kann ich dann syncen zwischen Firefox und Chrome
über meine Nextcloud Instanz
auch auf verschiedenen Rechnern
das ist ein super Addon
und im Firefox Store gibt es davon immer
nur die bisschen ältere Version
weil es halt eine Weile dauert
und ich glaube für Chrome gibt es das noch gar nicht
im Store und da kann ich dann auch mal
und das kann ich nicht installieren
über den offiziellen Chrome
weil Google der Meinung ist
sie müssen für mich mitdenken
deswegen verwende ich mittlerweile
überall Windows, Linux
verwende ich ein Chromium
ein Chromium ohne diesen ganzen
DRM Scheiß drin
und gut ist
Findest du Firefox
besser als Chrome?
Ich benutze hauptsächlich Firefox
das hat einen Hauptgrund
warum ich auch seit Jahren nur hauptsächlich
mein Hauptbrowser Firefox ist
besser würde ich nicht sagen
das beste an Firefox
nach wie vor ist die Adressleiste
die standardmäßig
History
Seitentitel in der History
Bookmarks
es könnte sogar sein
Seitencontent im Cache
bin ich mir nicht sicher
besuchte Seiten
sowas alles durchsucht
und einem anbietet
also hier
das macht Chrome nicht
es gibt für Chrome
auch kein ordentliches Addon
was das macht
eigentlich diese Leiste
ist der Hauptgrund
warum ich Firefox verwende
es gibt ein paar Chrome Plugins
die das versuchen nachzumachen
aber da muss man dann extra Tabs aufmachen
und das ist alles nicht so schön
für Firefox
woran kann das liegen
wenn ich meinen zweiten Bildschirm
an der Grafikkante anschließe die aber den Bildschirm nicht erkennt
ich muss den Chrome aus
einen Report probieren
DVI spackt manchmal rum
musst du gucken am besten schließt du es per Displayport
oder HDMI an
und ich habe immer hier die Custom Portable
Chromium Builds
soll der Chrome Store nicht abgeschafft werden
ne das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass der Store abgeschafft werden soll
ich meine wo willst du die ganzen Addons dann installieren
bitte posten
hier ist mal ein Link zur Chromium Seite
hier oder
äh
blöd wo hatte ich das denn gerade offen
haha
ja Chromium
Wullis
da nimmst du ja am besten die Portable
Version da ist auch ein Updater
dabei deswegen nehme ich die Portable Version
bei jedem Start guckt ihr ob es die aktuelle
Version ist und lädt die neue Version runter
das ist äh
das sind die Seite
das benutzen sauviele
Windows Builds
das ist halt die Stable Version das hier unten ist
die Beta oder so
ja Chrome Apps sollen abgeschaltet werden Florian
aber nicht äh aber nicht Chrome Addons
ist was anderes
du hattest mal ein Virus und die hat dir Chrome runtergeladen
ja
die Wege sind unergründlich
man weiß nicht warum
übrigens ich habe ähm
jetzt auf meinem Rechner
also ich habe hier den neuen Rechner
mittlerweile installiert und in Betrieb
ich habe außerdem Standard Windows
Defender
Windows Defender noch keinen
neuen Viren Scanner
drauf
wo wir gerade beim Thema Viren sind
ich werde das jetzt mal mit dem Windows Defender
probieren
weil wenn man aufpasst
und ich mache alles
also alles was ich irgendwie mit externen Sachen
interagiere
ja mache ich ja eh mit Linux
die großen Fische
kommen ein bisschen zu oft
vielleicht war es aber einfach nur Zufall jetzt
hast du eine Switch?
ja äh Max
geines
is
ähm ja hast du verpasst
wir sind schon seit einer Stunde oder so fertig
ich sitze jetzt eigentlich einfach nur rum
hab ASCIIquarium laufen
und bin auch ein bisschen am Labern und Chat lesen
hast du verpasst
ja
aber wenn du willst kann ich dir zeigen was wir gemacht haben
würdest du die Switch weiterempfehlen
als als Hardware
ja
aber als
Konsole
es gibt halt nicht viele Spiele drauf
und
wie Nintendo nächstes Jahr
was haben sie gesagt 30 Millionen oder so
ja wie sie so viel davon
nächstes Jahr verkaufen wollen
ist
optimistisch
ist wirklich
optimistisch ich mein es gibt
zwei
Killer Spiele für
Mario Odyssey
und Breath of the Wild
da gibt es noch ein paar andere Spiele die sind ganz nett
Splatoon
gefällt bestimmt auch einigen
was ist eigentlich
aus ARMS geworden
ist doch raus mittlerweile
haben sie dann nicht erzählt sie wollen
eine ARMS
E-Sport League oder sowas
machen haben sie doch vor einer Weile erzählt
gibt es dazu irgendwas neues
wo kann ich mir den krassen ARMS E-Sport angucken
wo gibt es die krassen ARMS E-Sport Tournament
die will ich mir angucken
hehehe
warum
die haben doch so einen großen Winterturm
gemacht so also Max
dann zeige ich dir mal was wir gemacht haben und zwar
ähm und zwar
wir haben äh
ZFS eingerichtet also wir haben ZFS selbst
kompiliert vom
äh aktuellen Master Branch Github
weil dort der
äh Verschlüsselungspatch mit drin ist
oh fuck
MrFryguy ich wollt
ich hab vor ein paar Wochen schon
jemand versprochen ich seine sein
sein ähm Steam Profil
hab das nie gemacht hab ich vergessen warst du das
vielleicht
warst du das vielleicht schon hab ich das nämlich echt
vergessen also wie gesagt äh Max
wir haben ZFS selbst kompiliert
mit der neuesten Entwicklungsversion
ähm
und
haben dann
eine verschlüsselte Festplatte also einen verschlüsselten
Pool eingerichtet
haben Ubuntu drauf installiert
auf dem verschlüsselten Pool
und dann
Ubuntu davon gebootet
eingerichtet dass
wir beim booten einen SSH Server haben
über den wir das System anlocken
können mit Passwort
also sprich ähm den den
die verschlüsselte Festplatte wo das Ubuntu drauf ist
dass wir es anlocken können
beim booten
und dann bootet es
so hört sich jetzt ein bisschen einfacher an als es war
war schon ein bisschen trickreicher
kanns mein auch sein ich mach
irgendwann mal Steam Signing Stream
Hallo CheesyPro
wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon online
jetzt abtime ab
abtime
4 Stunden 40 Minuten
ich bin jetzt bestimmt schon eine Stunde am schwätzen
obwohl wir schon fertig sind
ja das denke ich auch
also
es fehlen ja noch ein paar größeren Nintendo Marken
es fehlt noch ein ordentliches Metroid
ähm
Pokémon muss
ja muss
ein neues Smash Bros
muss auch
es gibt ein paar Nintendo Spiele
also die können da schon noch einiges machen
aber aktuell ist es
halt so
so richtige
so die Killer Sachen
gibt es halt zwei Spiele auf der Wii
äh auf der Wii auf der Switch
äh
aber auf der Wii gab es auch nicht mehr
bis zum Ende der Konsole
ja doch bei der Wii
gab es bis zum Ende der Konsole vielleicht
5 richtig gute Games
was hältst du von dem ganzen Smart Home
Gedöns
gibt es coole Sachen
also so Lampensteuerung und sowas
hat was
auch wenn es eher so nice to have ist
nicht toll
wofür das cool ist
wenn Leute beispielsweise so ein Passivhaus
haben oder sowas
also wo genau geguckt werden muss
wie ist das so mit Sonneneinfall und mit
also wie man das so
reguliert alles
ja Jalousien hoch runter und sowas
in der Richtung dafür ist es natürlich toll
wenn man sich da was basteln
basteln kann Smart Home mäßig
aber da ist die beste
Lösung finde ich auch was individuelles
also sprich ähm
man nimmt sich nen Raspberry Pi oder sowas
mit ordentlichen Interfaces
und skriptet
das selbst dann ist es genau so wie man das haben will
und wie das für das eigene Haus passt
ja Animal Crossing
stimmt wird es bestimmt auch geben
für die Switch
stehen auch mir aus mir unerfindlichen
Gründen viele Leute auf Animal Crossing
nein ich habe kein iPhone X
ich habe ein iPhone 6 das funktioniert noch
sobald es dafür keine Betriebssystem
Updates mehr gibt
gibt es wahrscheinlich dann auch ein neues
aber ich muss das ja eh glücklicherweise
nicht selbst bezahlen
sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich ein Android
Smartphone
na wie sahen denn die Launch Jahre bei der PS4
und der Xbox One aus bei der Xbox One beschissen?
und bei der Xbox One sieht es
immer noch beschissen aus
für die PS4 ist besser
aber am Anfang
war es auch beschissen ja
deswegen hätte ich mir auch nie eine PS4
und eine Xbox One äh
also naja doch habe ich mir
gekauft aber empfohlen hätte ich sie nicht
zur Release zu kaufen
würde ich jetzt übrigens immer noch nicht empfehlen
wenn schon dann eine PS4
weil da gibt es ja mittlerweile schon ganz gute Spiele für
so
ach stimmt Mario Kart habe ich noch vergessen
ja genau
Mario Kart ja
ok es gibt 3 richtig gute Sachen
für die Switch die sich lohnen
Zelda, Mario, Mario Kart
reicht eine
1050Ti aus um die
meisten Games lustig zu zocken
ja der Buchhalter
sehe ich auch so also wenn ich Smart Home
Sachen machen würde dann würde ich selbst
das letzte Wort haben
was wann passiert
ich würde mir nie ein
intelligentes Türschloss einbauen
nie wenn ich nicht
weiß was die Software macht
und das kann ich nur machen wenn ich lesen kann
was sie was ne wenn ich mir den Source Code
angucken kann und verifizieren kann das den
Source Code den ich lese auch der ist der auf dem
Gerät drauf ist am Ende
und selbst dann würde ich mir kein intelligentes
Türschloss dran pappen
andere Sachen würde ich machen wie gesagt
wenn ich ein Passivhaus hätte so eine Steuerung
dass das halt die
Temperatur konstant ist und
bisschen gespart wird und sowas
wie wenn ich Geräte über IP
Steckdosen ein ausschalten ja irgendwelche
Lichter oder so so so atmosphärisch
so so
Lichtatmosphäre wie heißt denn das so so
Ambient Beleuchtung oder so
das ist
das finde ich ganz cool ja
ja solange meine eigene Firma drauf flashen kann
ist das gleich noch mal viel besser
ich meine es gibt
schon ein paar coole Spielereien ja so
Richtung Smart Home ist jetzt nur so
so ein bisschen Smart Home
ja zum Beispiel habe ich es jetzt so
gemacht drüben auf meinem Fernseh
Wohnzimmer drüben
wie gesagt das ist ja dieser der
55 Zoll Sony Fernseh mit dem Nvidia Shield
dran und alles da habe ich jetzt
einen Kodi Addon drauf installiert
das
wenn ich Fernseh gucke
und es ruft jemand
an und dann zeigt es mir auf dem
Fernseh an wer
anruft plus
Bild und
Reverse Lookup
Bild aus der Telefonliste wenn er da drin ist
plus wenn er nicht in der Telefonliste drin ist
Reverse Lookup vom Telefonbuch
und macht gleichzeitig Sound aus
und den Film auf Pause
das ist jetzt zwar nur so
am Rande Smart Home
aber so Funktionen finde ich sehr praktisch
und
das beste ist sobald ich das Telefon wieder auflege
macht der Ton wieder an
und kurz danach macht er
sogar wieder Play von alleine auf dem
Fernseher
das sind Sachen die sind irgendwo
sinnvoll
und wenn ich so
eine Ambient Beleuchtung oder so hätte
dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch
verbinden und vernetzen
aber ich meine man muss nicht
jeden Stumpfsinn da machen
nur weil es sich irgendwie vernetzen lässt
zum Beispiel
die Hausgeräte Hersteller machen
das ja auch mit intelligenten
Kühlschränken und sowas da muss ich ehrlich sagen
den Sinn
vom intelligenten Kühlschrank
habe ich noch nicht erkannt
der Buchhalter
hast du dir schon mal von Elgato
die RGB bzw. die
Beleuchtungssachen angeguckt
die haben auch sowas
habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert
so ich glaube ich mache jetzt echt gleich mal Schluss
jetzt haben wir schon über eine Stunde
sind wir eigentlich fertig und ich labere nur noch ein bisschen rum
ab Dezember
geht es wieder los
zumindest habe ich mir das vorgenommen
Dezember habe ich einen Monat Urlaub
es kann sein dass ich doch
keinen Bock habe ihr kennt mich ja mittlerweile
aber ich habe mir vorgenommen
ab Dezember geht es wieder richtig los
alle zwei Tage ein Video
Livestream volle Pulle
ich muss ja irgendwann mal
300k Abos kriegen auf Youtube
ich sehe
das immer wenn es mal eine kurze Phase
gibt wo ich wieder anfange Videos
zu machen dann dauert es dann 3 4 5 Tage
dann siehst du direkt
dass ich das auch wieder anfängt
langsam zu erholen also sprich
dass ich dann quasi mehr Abos
dazu kriege als Leute die durch
die Aktivität das Konto gekündigt haben
oder deabonnieren und sowas
weil einen konstanten Fluss an Deabos
oder Abos die aufgeräumt werden hast du ja immer
und wenn du keine Videos machst kriegst du halt auch keine neuen dazu
sehe ich dann immer
dann fängt sich das gerade so an zu erholen
und dann habe ich schon wieder keinen Bock mehr
so komme ich nie
auf meine 300.000
wir machen irgendwann mal
Profil Signing Stream
das kannst du mir jetzt eh nicht alles merken
muss man unbedingt 300k Abos haben
unbedingt
wenn man seit 3 Jahren schon 285.000
hat oder irgendwie so in dem Dreh
dann braucht man irgendwann
auch mal 300k Abos
ich krebs doch schon ewig
rum immer
bisschen plus bisschen minus
in den letzten 1,5 Jahren
letztes Jahr weil ich ja kaum was gemacht habe
sogar eher tendenziell minus
noch also irgendwann müssen ja mal
300k jetzt mal
in welchem Bundesland wohnst du in Frankfurt
am Main
und vielleicht
kontaktiere ich irgendwann auch mal
Twitch wenn ich
tatsächlich mal eine halbwegs regelmäßige
Stream
Routine so habe
wie das
mit Subscription und
Partnerverträgen und so aussieht
aber dazu
muss das erstmal
für mich selbst passen
dass ich sage das mache ich jetzt öfters und regelmäßig
und dementsprechend
muss es ja dann auch für Twitch passen
welche Gaming Brand
also Omen Alienware ETC
ist preis leistungsmäßig das beste
ha
gar keins
Affiliate Programme
sind sie ja schon am
wäre ich ja schon zu gespammt hier
ob ich das nicht machen will
ich habe ja den den
weiß gar nicht was er ist
Twitch Deutschland
Community
Manager
weiß nicht was er ist noch in Skype
könnte ich sogar mal anschreiben
wollte ja vor ein paar Jahren schon mal
anfangen zu streamen
habe ich dann aber nie gemacht
aber ich warte erst mal
ich habe wie gesagt auch überhaupt keine
großartigen Ambitionen da irgendwie Partner zu werden
erstmal
und vor allem
wenn ich
wenn ich einen hohen Anteil von irgendwelchen
Programmierer und Linux und sonst was Streams habe
das ist halt jetzt auch nicht
was die 3-400
oder sogar mehr Zuschauer
irgendwie da begeistert
in den Stream bringt
das merke ich eindeutig
ich mein ich find's cool
dass hier jetzt trotzdem so viele gucken
was aber auch hauptsächlich Leute sind
die halt schon eine Weile dabei sind
neue Abos krieg ich ja bei solchen Streams immer relativ wenig
weil kein Mensch guckt
Twitch Creative
und noch weniger guckt Twitch Creative Programming
was blödes Delay
was für ein Delay
soll eigentlich kein Delay haben
was läuft da mit
Alienware nix
werden wir irgendwann später machen
haben wir uns jetzt erstmal dazu entschieden
das nicht zu machen
weil ich auch erstmal wieder aktiver was
was machen will
ich will erstmal wieder aktiver Videos machen Streams machen und sowas
bevor ich das mit
Alienware starte
Max ja bin ich
Interaction ja da war ich
war ich schon
lange nicht mehr auf der Hanauer Landstraße
Interaction
solchen Videos, wo es um technische Sachen geht
und vor allem um Hardware und Computer,
kommen ja immer wieder so die ganz schlauen Leute,
die dann anfangen zu erzählen, also
Max, ich weiß ja nicht, woher du
das und das hast, aber so ist das in Wirklichkeit
gar nicht. Weißt du, also die üblichen
Leute kommen wieder. Da kam dann wieder
irgendjemand, einer an und hat dann
sowas wie erzählt, so, ja Max, also ich weiß
ja nicht, in welchem Rechenzentrum du schon
alles gewesen bist, aber nein, nein, nein, mit der
Belüftung ist das überhaupt nicht so. Ich frage
mich eher, in welchem Rechenzentrum der bisher
gewesen ist, wenn es da keine ordentliche Belüftung
gegeben hat.
Also manche Leute schreiben echt zu komplett ohne
Sinn und Verstand, ja.
Aber das würde ich gerne mal zeigen.
Ähm, darf man leider
nicht. Dezix, das würde ich
unglaublich gerne mal zeigen. Aber ich glaube
nicht, dass sie da ein großer Fan von sind,
wenn ich einfach mal mit der Kamera angucke
und sage, Jungs, darf ich filmen?
Du musst ja schon immer ein Rieselakt machen und dich
wiegen lassen und sowas, bevor du da überhaupt rein
darfst. Dass du keine Bombe ablegst
oder so, weiß nicht, warum man sich da wiegen lassen muss.
Aber Dezix
wäre, ey, das wäre geil. Das müsste man
echt mal zeigen.
Und ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Welche Twitch-Streamer schaust du eigentlich,
Max? Oh, ich gucke, also Twitch,
Twitch gucke ich mehr als
YouTube. Ich gucke
jede Menge. Fangen wir mal an. Bob Ross.
Gucke ich tatsächlich ab, zu wahr.
Ganz viele
Overwatch-Channels gucke ich.
Also alle möglichen Pros durch die Bank
weg. Taimou, mit Abstand mein Lieblings-Streamer.
Was Overwatch angeht.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch hier? TakeTV,
wenn es um StarCraft geht und sowas. Wobei ich da in letzter Zeit
weniger gucke. Die ganzen
ESL-Channels.
Jede Menge. Speedrun-Channels
habe ich abonniert.
Follow Grubby. Eigentlich
zum Entspannen mein Lieblings-Stream.
Ehemaliger Warcraft 3 Pro.
Gibt es denn sonst noch?
Ja, gibt viele Sachen.
Twitch gucke ich eigentlich
mehr als YouTube mittlerweile.
Paladins? Ne, Paladins
will ich nicht spielen.
Ja, Halbkorn in den meisten
Rechenzentren ist es übertrieben laut.
Und je nachdem, wie sie ihre, wie sie
kühlen, entweder
viel zu warm
oder viel zu kalt.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Taktiken, wie man das kühlt, ja.
Also sprich, entweder man kühlt alles
oder man kühlt quasi nur dort, wo die warme Luft
rausgeblasen wird. Äh, Schwachsinn.
Da, wo die kalte Luft angesaugt wird, so rum.
Ähm, gibt's ja verschiedene Taktiken, wie man das machen kann.
Bin jetzt aber auch nicht so der Profi drin.
Äh, Follow Grubby heißt ja.
Sehr entspannender Stream.
Nächstes Jahr Age of Empires 4 werd ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken.
Das ist sicher.
Age of Empires hab ich sehr viel gespielt.
Auch den Dreier, der nicht so gut angekommen ist zu seiner Zeit.
Fand den aber super.
Boah, der Hai. Der Hai Owens.
Und so alle.
So, jetzt mach ich aber Schluss.
Jetzt mach ich Schluss.
Und ich wollte eigentlich zum nächsten Mal wieder
COD streamen.
Zumal das auf dem neuen PC super läuft, allerdings immer noch abkackt.
Aber irgendwie hab ich grad keinen Bock.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.